Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 30.
Das ist die große Told You So Folge. Wir sind ja schon gefragt worden, wann kommt denn endlich unsere Sendung, wo wir zwei Stunden lang sagen, haben wir doch gleich gesagt. Aber haben wir gar nicht gleich gesagt. Also wir haben es zwar gesagt, aber nicht allen. Insofern kann man jetzt eigentlich nicht Told You So bringen, sondern...
Gut, also wir wollen, worüber wir reden wollen heute ist abhören, Signal Intelligence, die Crypto Wars und was so eigentlich die Mechanismen sind, die dahinter stecken und wie die Geschichte ist, vor allen Dingen, weil wir denken, dass um nachvollziehen zu können, was da heute passiert und was wir aus den Snowden Enthüllungen lernen, müssen wir noch mal ein Stück zurück in die Geschichte gucken. Wo kommen diese Geheimdienste eigentlich her? Was war deren Aufgabe? Wie ist deren Mindset? Und warum treiben die das, was sie da so treiben, in dieser Art und Weise und mit diesem Aufwand und mit diesem Selbstverständnis?
Vor allem ist es nötig, um es diesmal besser zu machen. Denn stellt sich heraus, es gibt so alle 10, 20 Jahre, gibt es so einen Aufschrei über die NSA. Es gibt irgendwelche Enthüllungen, die NSA hört uns alle ab, dann geht es in die Presse. Gut, jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz so groß wie bei Snowden, aber es gab mehrere solche Sachen, wo irgendwas über die NSA rausgekommen ist. Dann gab es irgendwie 1990 oder so.
Kommen wir später dazu.
Kommen wir später dazu. Da gab es eine Spiegel-Titel-Story und dann ging es ein bisschen durch die Presse und das EU-Parlament hat sich mal beschäftigt. Aber das kommt alle, alle so und so viele Jahre kommt es und dann gibt es so eine Blase, die sich da aufblubbert und am Ende platzt sie und es passiert nichts. Und damit das diesmal nicht so wird, haben wir uns gesagt, müssen wir ein bisschen in die Geschichte gehen und die Zeit erklären, wie das bisher passiert ist, was passiert ist, was wir bisher gemacht haben und warum das nicht funktioniert hat. Aber wir sollten uns vielleicht erstmal dafür entschuldigen, dass es so lange geklaut hat.
genau, wir hatten da so eine gewisse längere sendepause, die im Wesentlichen darauf zurückzuführen ist, dass Fefe im Ausland unterwegs war und als er dann wieder da war, waren wir wieder abwechselnd verhindert oder krank. Und wir versuchen uns zu bessern, aber wir versprechen nur lieber nichts, weil das haben wir schon so oft verpuntet.
Wir versprechen Besserung, aber wir garantieren nichts.
genau, wir garantieren nichts. Wir versuchen uns zu bessern, aber trotzdem herzlichen Dank an alle, die tatsächlich uns die Stange halten und auch weiter flattern. Das finden wir sehr nett und sehr beeindruckend. Auch eure Fanpost hat uns gerade heute sehr erfreut beim Brief veröffnen. Ja, also vielen Dank dafür und vielen Dank für die Treue. Die Geschichte der Krypto.
Das ist eigentlich eine sehr spannende Sache, weil sich der Großteil davon in der Neuzeit abspielt. Die Sachen sind alle gar nicht so alt, wie man vielleicht denken würde.
Die Art und Weise, Nachrichten zu verschlüsseln, hat sich natürlich über die Zeit entsprechend dem technologieniveau geändert. Also aus der Antike und der Frühzeit sind halt so Sachen überliefert, wie dass man einen Kurier hatte, dem man halt eine Botschaft auf den Kopf tätowiert hat, auf den rasierten Kopf, und ihn dann so lange noch da bleiben ließ, bis seine Haare wieder gewachsen waren, und ihn dann zu dem entsprechenden anderen Herrscher schickte, sodass er keine Botschaft bei sich trug, also kein paar Püros oder ein anderes Pergament oder so, was man unterwegs bei Kontrollen finden konnte. Und was auch so ein bisschen darauf hinweist, dass es damals auch nicht so einfach war, physische Gegenstände von A nach B zu verbringen.
Und das hat auch eine Weile gedauert, das heißt, die Haare wuchsen auch während der Reise. Aber zusammenfassend kann man sagen, der Name Verschlüsselung ist eigentlich unpassend für diese antiken Systeme, weil es keinen Schlüssel gab. Sondern das Verfahren an sich war eben das Geheimnis.
Gut, also diese Kopftytografie-Geschichte war eigentlich de facto, würde man sagen, Stichografie heute. Nur ein bisschen aufwendiger. Es gab aber tatsächlich auch Verschlüsselungssysteme, die zum Beispiel darauf beruhten, dass man einen Stab mit einem bestimmten Durchmesser hatte, also der eine bestimmte Dicke hatte, um den dann ein Band aus Textil oder aus Leder geschlungen wurde. Dann hat man halt quer auf dem Stab die Botschaft geschrieben. Wenn man den Stab abgewickelt hat, dann hatte man halt nur einen schmalen Streifen mit den entsprechenden Buchstaben drauf, aus denen man halt nicht ohne Weitost die Botschaft erkennen konnte, wenn man nicht wusste oder ausprobieren konnte, wie dick der Stab ist. Hat natürlich nicht so richtig gut gehalten, weil auch damals waren die Leute schon clever und haben einfach Stäbe von unterschiedlicher Dicke ausprobiert, bis sie was zusammenbekommen haben. Dann gab es halt alle möglichen Schiffrennsysteme, die meistens Substitutionsschlüssel waren. Das heißt also, wo man Buchstaben des Alphabets ersetzt hat, so was, was man halt in der Schule gemacht hat, um so Briefe hin und her zu schicken.
Das ist natürlich immer noch alles scheiße, weil manche Buchstaben eben häufiger als andere vorkommen und dann kann man das immer noch zurückpupeln.
genau, also Substitutionsschlüssel zu knacken ist sehr einfach. Davon wurden dann aber komplexe Systeme entwickelt, die wiederum es dann schwieriger machen sollten, also den Aufwand erhöhen sollten, ohne das Codebuch, also ohne den dazwöhrigen Schlüssel. Das System zu erraten, also ein typisches Beispiel dafür, ist das sogenannte Buchcypher, der darin besteht, dass man ein bestimmtes Taschenbuch oder so nimmt, und zwar eine bestimmte Ausgabe, die Sender und Empfänger haben, und dann einfach die Worte, die man braucht, als Zahlen codiert. Also wenn man zum Beispiel ein UND braucht, dann steht da halt 2342, heißt halt das 42. Wort auf der Seite 23 und dann kann der Empfänger halt eben in seinem Buch nachschlagen, was das jetzt gerade für ein Wort ist. So ein Buchcypher hat den großen Nachteil, dass natürlich die Gegner kennen sowas auch. Also Buchcypher wurden auch im Zweiten Weltkrieg zum Beispiel von den verschiedenen Widerstandsgruppen häufiger verwendet, was dann eben aber dazu führte, dass die, wenn nicht von Agistapo verhaftet wurden, dann haben die erstmal in deren ganze Bibliothek mitgenommen, um zu gucken, ob sie mit diesen Buchschlüsseln einen Erfolg dagegen erzielen. Da gab es halt eine ganze Reihe von so handtauglichen Kryptosystemen, die am Ende alle brechbar waren. Es gab halt nur sehr wenige Systeme, die bis heute ungebrochen sind in dieser Kategorie, die richtige Verschlüsselung in der...
Wobei wir sollten vielleicht mal erklären, was brechen heißt in der Krypto. Das ist nämlich auch so eine Sache, die sich vielleicht dem Leiden nicht so erschließt. Also brechen heißt in der Kryptographie nicht unbedingt, dass man es irgendwie so zack entschlüsselt, sondern die Anforderungen an Verfahren, die frisch erfunden werden oder die zur Standardisierung vorliegen, sind sehr hoch. Da reicht es also zum Beispiel, wenn man bei einem Verschlüsselungsverfahren am Ende ein Verfahren zeigen kann oder ein Programm schreiben kann, was den Output, also die verschlüsselten Daten von Zufall unterscheidet. Das reicht schon, um zu sagen, das Verfahren ist nicht sicher genug. Nun gut, es gibt ja keine...
Du solltest mal erklären, warum.
Es gibt keine festgeschriebenen Grenzen.
Du solltest mal erklären, warum das reicht. Die Art und Weise, wie man versucht, ein Kryptosystem zu brechen, also zumindest, wenn man es per Hand macht, ist indem man versucht, Struktur darin zu finden. Also tatsächlich in den Daten, die man bekommt, irgendeine Art von Korrelationen zu dem Klartext zu finden. Das heißt also, irgendeine Art von Abhängigkeit zu finden zwischen dem Klartext und dem verschlüsselten Resultat. Und wenn man die gefunden hat, dann kann man in der Regel entweder über statistische Verfahren oder mathematische Verfahren oder auch über Implementierungsschwächen in dem Kryptoverfahren ist man in der Lage, größere Teile von dem Klartext meistens zu rekonstruieren. Und deswegen muss halt der Output eines guten Kryptoverfahrens von reimen Zufall nicht zu unterscheiden sein, weil sonst kann man nie ausschließen, dass es nicht noch einen mathematischen Hebel gibt oder einen statistischen Hebel, mit dem man aus diesem verschütteten Text den Klartext rekonstruieren kann.
Den kannst du natürlich immer noch geben, aber er soll zumindest nicht offensichtlich sein.
Vor Zeiten von Telefon und Telegraf waren die Kryptoübermittlungen zwangsweise briefsbasiert. Also es gab ein Postsystem und wenn man halt Nachrichten verschüttet übermitteln wollte, dann musste man die entweder im Klartext aufschreiben und dann halt versuchen, Transportsicherheit zu betreiben. Also indem man sie versiegelt hat und sie einem vertrauenswürdigen Kurier gegeben hat, der sich um die quasi allgegenwärtigen je nach Zeit und Land Straßenkontrollen drumrum gemogelt hat.
Das gibt es ja immer noch bei diplomatischer Post, dass es so ein Siegel gibt auf dem...
Na gut, aber diplomatische Post ist halt anders, weil da sagt man halt, okay, da gibt es halt die Vereinbarung, dass Diplomatenpost immun ist und nicht kontrolliert wird.
Naja, aber diese Idee, dass man es versiegelt.
genau.
Also wenn ich schon nicht verhindern kann, dass sie reingucken, dann würde ich es zumindest erkennen können, um sie dann nicht beschweren zu können.
Vor allen Dingen willst du wissen, ob die Nachricht gefälscht wurde. Also ein Wachsiegel ist tatsächlich eigentlich eher eine Signatur, die nachweist, dass zum einen, wenn es heil ankommt, dann wurde es unterwegs nicht gelesen. Und zum anderen ist der Absender tatsächlich derjenige, der vorgibt zu sein. Natürlich wurden diese Siegel mit 1000 Methoden nachgemacht, gefälscht, abgelöst, wieder angeklebt. Also da gibt es so ein ganzes Handwerk von Brieföffnungstechniken, mit denen man um so Siegel drum rumkommt. Bis hin heute, also so moderne Siegel, die sich so zerstören, wenn man sie ablöst und so. Was macht man denn?
Macht man da jetzt Isotope rein, damit man erkennt, dass das das selbe macht, wie ich meine?
Da können wir eine eigene Sendung machen, aber ich kann da, wenn wir gerade dabei sind, abzuschäufen. Ich will kurz abwarten. Siegelhämalten beruhen ja darauf, dass du physikalische Eigenschaften hast, die jemand, der es versucht zu fälschen, nicht ohne Weitens replizieren kann, ohne dass du es mitbekommst. Nehmen wir mal ein einfaches Beispiel. Du hast einen Wachsiegel. Du versiegelst einen Brief. Dann hast du drei wesentliche Eigenschaften. Die erste Eigenschaft ist deine Peitschaft, also dein Stempel, den du da reindrückst, dass der eine bestimmte Form hat, dass da bestimmte Sachen draufstehen und dass der immer gleich aussieht, dass dein Empfänger weiß, so muss es aussehen.
Aber den kann ich doch abgreifen, wenn ich so einen Siegel vor mir habe.
Naja, du kannst ihn abformen, mit heutiger Technologie ohnehin, weil du eine gute Plaster hast, mit der du das machen kannst. Damals war es ein bisschen schwieriger. Auch da gab es Techniken, mit denen man so eine Abformung machen konnte. Allerdings ist in der Regel der Rand des Stempels nicht so knackscharf wie mit einem Stahlsiegel. Das heißt, du musst halt schon...
Dann kann ich doch aber feilen an meinem abgegriffenen Ding.
Ja, aber es hat schon ein gewisser Aufwand. Also kannst du nicht mal eben on the fly so machen. Es gibt Möglichkeiten, gerade wenn die Perspektive nicht besonders gut ist. Dann geht das auf jeden Fall. Aber wenn du so einen Siegelstapel hast, der extrem komplexe, feine Formen hat und so, wo du auch nicht mit einer Abformung hast und so gut reinkommst, kriegt man schon eine gewisse Sicherheit. Eine zweite ist, dass du einen Siegelwachs nimmst, was bestimmte Eigenschaften hat. Also indem du den Siegelwach so anmischst zum Beispiel, dass es bei einer bestimmten Temperatur schmilzt. Also dass du halt weißt, dass dieses Siegelwachs musst du so und so auf diese Temperatur bringen oder mit dieser Art und Weise schmelzen, damit es schmilzt. Dann kann dein Empfänger sehen, ob zwischendurch jemand ein anderes Siegelwachs verwendet hat. Der weiß halt, du nimmst immer dieses Siegelwachs mit rot, mit blauen Schlieren zum Beispiel, was genau bei 140 Grad schmilzt oder so eine Sache. Und dritte ist natürlich die Gesamtstruktur des Briefes, also wie er gefaltet ist, ob du eine Schnur drum wickelst und ob du es verhinderst sozusagen, dass jemand da reingucken kann. Und wenn man heutzutage so einen Siegel nimmt, also es gibt halt natürlich verschiedenste Dinge, wo man Sachen versiegeln muss. Nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel eine Produktversiegelung zu diesem echtheldaufkleber auf Pillenpackungen. Zum Beispiel diese holographische Siegel. Und auch da versucht man es möglichst aufwendig zu machen, das zu reproduzieren, macht die Art der Anbringung des Siegels auf dem Untergrund, so dass man es nicht unerweit ablösen und woanders wieder draufkleben kann. Und du versuchst eine Wiedererkennung zu machen, indem der Empfänger im Zweifel weiß, so muss es aussehen. Und das ist halt scheiße schwer. Also genau sagt, kriegt das quasi niemand hin. Also es gibt schon Wege, wie man Siegel richtig anwenden kann. Aber die involvieren halt zum Beispiel, dass du auch noch einen Side-Channel zum Empfänger hast, dem du sagen kannst, so habe ich heute meinen Siegel anwacht. Oder so ist der Swirl von dem blau in roten Wachs, ist heute rechtsrum. An geraden Tagen immer rechtsrum, an ungeraden Tagen immer linksrum. So dass du halt so Side-Channels hast. Dann gibt es natürlich das Problem, dass so Siegel-Aufkleber sind in der Regel meistens mit chemischen oder physikalischen Methoden ablösbar, indem du halt kalt machst oder warm machst oder die richtigen Lösungsmittel findest. Da gibt es halt ganze Forschungsgruppen, die interessanterweise bei Nuclear Proliferation angesiedelt sind, bei den nationalen Laboratorien, weil die haben nämlich genau dieses Problem, dass sie Siegel entwickeln müssen, mit denen sie solche Container versiegeln. Oder zum Beispiel die Kameras, die die internationale Atomenergiebehörde in Atomkraftwerke oder Uranspeicher oder so hängt, oder Aufbereitungsanlagen, die sind halt auch so monster versiegelt. Und da machen die mittlerweile richtig abgefahrenen Scheiß. Zum Beispiel gibt es da so Siegel, in denen eine Glasfaser drin ist. Da wird eine Glasfaser-Loop um das Objekt drum geschlungen. Und die Elektronik in dem Siegel, die da total verbunkert drin ist, misst die ganze Zeit.
Ach, wenn das anschneidest, machst du das Kabelkram?
Ob diese Glasfaser unterbrochen ist, ob die sich deren Biegungsradien verändern. Also du schlingst die halt irgendwie da drum rum und dann machst du das Siegel scharf und dann weiß die Elektronik da drin so, okay, das ist die Eigenschaft von der Faser da gerade.
Oh, der Scheiß.
Und auf dem niveau sind Siegel heutzutage angekommen. Und nur da, zum Beispiel im Lawrence Livermore gibt es so eine Gruppe, die sich mit Siegeln beschäftigt, sagen die, okay, die kriegen wir jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres auf. Aber das andere, was es auch in kommerziellen Klebesiegeln gibt, zum Beispiel haben die ja platt gemacht.
Das ist ja auch nicht, da geht es ja auch nicht darum, solche Leute abzuhalten, sondern die chinesischen Produktfelcher.
Ja, interessanterweise kann man aber auch tatsächlich mit so kommerzieller Klebesiegel-Technologie physikalische Sicherheit erzielen. Aber da musst du genau wissen, auf welchen Untergrund klebst du das? Also geht der Kleber von dem Siegel einen festen Bond mit dem Untergrund ein.
Und dann machst du das sichtlich so, dass das nicht abgeht, sondern dann so zerfetzt, ja?
Ja, das ist super.
Hast dich ja mal.
Also, ich habe mich da ein bisschen ausführlicher beschäftigt, aus Gründen. Zurück dazu. Diese Art und Weise des Posttransports implizierte halt, okay, wenn der Brief gefunden wird, dann wird das im Zweifel gelesen. Es gab ein solches Postmonopol. Und dieses Postmonopol hatte, über viele Jahrhunderte, hatte zwei Gründe. Der eine Grund war natürlich...
Aber ja, teilweise immer doch. England hat es, glaube ich, immer noch. Die kämpfen gerade damit, ob sie es nicht doch privatisieren wollen.
Ja, der hatte natürlich den Grund, dass die damit Geld verdient haben, die Länder. Und zum anderen wollten natürlich alle Nachrichten lesen können. Und da gab es die sogenannten Black Chambers, also die schwarzen Räume, schwarzen Büros genau, in denen die Post geöffnet wurde und wo die Leute saßen. Die wussten, wie man so Siegel aufmacht und nachmacht. Oder da durch Ecken reinguckt und liest mit so Spiegelsystemen.
Oder so Chemikalien aufbringen, damit man da durchlesen kann durch den Brief.
genau, durch den Brief durchlesen kann oder mit Dampf öffnen kann, was die Stasi auch in großem Umfang gemacht hat und so. Oder auch die Alliierten, die Alliierten, genau. Also so eine Systeme gibt es halt schon immer. Und okay, wenn man also damit rechnen muss, dass die Nachricht auf dem Weg gelesen wird, bleibt also nur sie zu verschlüsseln. Im Internet ist ja quasi genau dasselbe. Wir haben ja nur Postkarten im Internet. Also jeder, der auf dem Wege ist, wenn so lange es nicht verschlüsselt ist, kann es halt lesen. Und deswegen brauchen wir Verschlüsselung. Und was wir halt lernen aus den alten Verschlüsselungssystemen, diese Substitutions-Cypher und Vigenär und wie sie alle hießen, ist, dass die Einschätzung darüber, wie sicher so ein Kryptosystem ist, ist eigentlich zu fast allen Zeiten zu optimistisch gewesen. Also die meisten Sachen konnten dann eben doch entschlüsselt werden, weil es Mathematiker gab, die dann durch die Kryptosysteme durchgestiegen sind oder weil sie halt einfach durch den Kammerdiener haben beobachten lassen, mit welchem Buch sich jemand da hingesetzt hat und seine Sachen verschlüsselt hat. Also da gab es halt immer alle Möglichkeiten, Mittel und Wege.
Wir haben ja auch den Leidensdruck unterschätzt, mit dem die Gegner versuchen, die Post zu öffnen. Das ist auch eine Sache, die sich über die Jahrzehnte immer wieder zeigt, dass man irgendwelche Systeme entwickelt, also gar nicht mal nur Verschlüsselung, auch so Sachen wie Telefonate zwischen West-Berlin und Westdeutschland, die gingen jahrelang über so eine Richtfunkstrecke, von einem Golfplatz der Alliierten war das.
Marienfelle oder so.
Wieso, es gab so einen Tower, der steht da immer noch. Und irgendwann haben sie dann, wann war das eigentlich, Anfang der 80er oder so, gesagt, wir machen jetzt mal Glasfaser. Und waren sich aber so sicher, dass es nicht abhörbar ist, dass sie da auch gar nicht große Gegenmaßnahmen gemacht haben und Verschlüsselung sowieso nicht, weil Glasfaser kann man nicht abhören. Und das ist dann, wie sie später herausgestellt hat, hat die Stasi das noch abgehört, bevor das Kabel vollständig im Boden lag. Das ist eine Sache, die man immer wieder diagnostizieren kann. Die Selbstüberschätzung davon, ob eine Technologie jetzt sicher ist oder nicht und ob man da irgendwelche Gegenmaßnahmen braucht oder nicht, die ist immer wieder zu beobachten durch die Jahrzehnte. Und was einfach fehlt, das ist ja nicht nur bei Kryptographie so, das ist ja auch bei anderen Sachen so eine Technikfolgenabschätzung, dass man sich hinsetzt und sagt, okay, wir teilen das Team jetzt auf in der Mitte, die linke Hälfte macht ein Verfahren und die rechte Hälfte muss es dann brechen. Ja, und dass man richtig Druck erzeugt und sagt, ihr müsst es jetzt brechen. Denn normalerweise, was die Leute halt machen, die so ein Verfahren entwickeln, die sagen sich, ja, das kann man schon brechen, aber der Aufwand wäre ja hoch. Ja, und dann rechnet man sich das ja selbst schön. Und wie das so ist, wenn man sich Sachen schön popelt in der Forschung, dann überliest man irgendwie Details, wo man im Moment glaubt, dass sie noch nicht ausnutzbar sind und so. Und man ist einfach zu konservativ in der Schätzung davon, was geht auf der Gegenseite. Und das ist einfach ein Problem, was es immer wieder gibt.
Mal zurück zur Geschichte.
Eine der berühmtesten Black Chambers war in Amerika, Yardley's Black Chamber. Die ist deswegen berühmt, weil sie mit den Worten aufgelöst wurde. Gentlemen don't read others emails damals. Also da geht es um tatsächlich Briefe. Und da hat dann der, ich glaube der Präsident war das damals gesagt.
Nee, der zuständige Staatssekretär hat die aufgelöst.
Er hat gesagt, das macht man nicht, das haben wir nicht nötig.
Nach dem ersten Weltkrieg haben wir...
Wir sind die Guten, wir machen das nicht.
genau, also nach dem ersten Weltkrieg war das, das ist ihnen nie wieder passiert.
Da war er allein auf weiter Floh mit der Einschätzung.
Ja, genau. Das war halt zu Zeiten, wo dann der Telegraf das hauptkommunikationsmittel war. Natürlich war eigentlich allen klar, dass alles, was über Telegraf lief, wurde von allen Ländern mitgelesen, durch die diese Telegrafenleitung lief. Das war eigentlich so klar, dass das so war.
Wer das anders annimmt, ist selber schuld.
Deswegen gab es interessanterweise dann so genannte Commercial Codes. Die hatten einen doppelten Nutzen. Der eine Nutzen war, dass er die Anzahl der Zeichen zur Bemittlung der Nachricht reduziert hat. Das war ein Kompressionscode, der dazu diente, Telegrafenkosten zu sparen. Da gab es dann so große, dicke Bücher, die man kaufen konnte. In denen stand dann für alle möglichen Güter, die man zum Beispiel geordert hat über einen Telegrafen oder wo man Preise übermittelt hat über einen Telegrafen, standen Codes dafür drin. Bis hin zu Details von Klamotten. Also völlig bizar, so richtig dicke, riesige Bücher. Und in diesen Commercial Codes wurde typischerweise ein Großteil des Telegrafenverkehrs abgewickelt.
Also dieses Konzept gibt es ja immer noch bei Kompressionsverfahren. Das heißt auch immer noch Codebook.
genau, da kommt es her.
Das ist ganz lustig.
Und die war natürlich, wenn man dieses Codebook nicht hatte, war es natürlich so eine Art Verschlüsselung. Also man halt dann nicht ohne weiteres, ohne länger zuzuhören und zuzugucken, wusste, was nur eigentlich ist. Aber auch schon damals wurde berichtet, dass die Telegrafenangestellten, die diese Telegramme aufgenommen und irgendwie ausgegeben haben, dass die dann diese Codebooks teilweise schon am Kopf kannten, weil die...
Na ja, die wichtigen Wörter natürlich, ist ja eine Sprache, die du sprichst, oder?
Na ja, und vor allen Dingen, wenn du halt die ganze Zeit hast und siehst, so dann...
Ich habe ja so ein lustiges Detail gelesen, die Tage auch im Telegrafengingster. Und zwar haben sie relativ früh versucht, es zu automatisieren und haben Maschinen gebaut, die die Arbeit von den Telegrafisten machen wollten. Und haben festgestellt, dass die Clerks einfach besser waren.
Okay.
Die haben mehr Durchsatz gehabt. Und dann haben sie die Maschinen nicht eingesetzt, aber die sind dann an die Dienste gegangen. Weil die hat man ja nicht gebraucht. Und die Dienste haben die dann benutzt, um...
Zum Dekodieren.
Zum Dekodieren, ja, weil da war Zeit nicht so wichtig. Es musste nicht in Echtzeit gehen. Und so ist das halt häufiger mit Technik, dass die die Folgen am Schätzungen, es läuft alles ganz anders, als man sich das überlegt hat. Und die sind noch viele Jahre im Betrieb gewesen, selbst als es keine Telegrafen mehr gab, weil die Technik auch benutzt werden konnte. Und diese... Die früher haben die Telefone mit Pulswahl gewählt. Also wenn man fünf gewählt hat, klang auf der Latte so... Und das haben diese Geräte halt auch erkannt. Und deswegen sind die jahrelang benutzt worden, um die Metadaten von Telefonaten aufzuheben. Also es ist alles sehr abgefahren, was da an Technologie Details gibt. Aber schon damals, unabhängig von diesen Commercial Codes, gab es eine unüberschaubare Menge an mehr oder weniger absurden, bizarren Kryptoversuchen.
Aus heutiger Sicht, ne?
Ja, damals natürlich als Bleeding Edge. Und da muss man auch bei heutigen Systemen immer so rangehen, dass man sagt, das sieht jetzt aus heutiger Sicht vielleicht cool aus, aber das soll ja auch in zehn Jahren noch halten.
Ja, in der Folge des ersten Weltkriegs gab es so die ersten Verschüssungsmaschinen, die dann mechanisch, also hat man die Nachricht eingetippt, also quasi für Fernschreiben oder für Telegraf, die die Nachricht mechanisch verschlüsselt haben. Das heißt, es waren meistens so walzende Rotationsmaschinen. Das war dann so der Typ, der sich relativ bald durchsetzt. Das heißt also so was wie die Enigma. Also die Enigma war halt der bekannteste, also weitaus bekannteste Typ davon. Aber von so ähnlichen Maschinen mit lauter Tweaks und unterschiedlichen Tricks, die da verwendet wurden, gab es enorm viele. Also im Prinzip funktioniert es so, man drückt halt eine Taste, diese Taste schließt einen Stromkreis und dieser Stromkreis geht durch eine Serie von rotierenden Walzen durch, die mit jedem Tastendruck weiter gedreht werden. Und innerhalb dieser Walzen befindet sich eine Anordnung von Drähten, die das Signal sozusagen durch diese Walzenkombinationen durchleiten und auf der anderen Seite erscheint es einer anderen Position auf der Walze und entspricht einem anderen Buchstaben. Also so funktioniert halt auch dieses Enigma-System. Da gibt es dann auch so Tricks mit Reflektionswalzen und Substitutionswalzen und solchen Sachen, die halt das System ein bisschen komplizierter machen und am Ende versucht man zu sagen, man hat eine Substitution des Buchstabens, also aus A wird halt irgendwas, E oder so. Aber das ist nicht fest? genau, wenn du das nächste Mal A drückst, dann kommt irgendwie was anderes bei raus, weil die Walzen sich eins weiter gedreht haben und es hat auch kein multialphabetischer Substitutionszeifer, also wo du halt eine Abfolge von Alphabeten hast, sondern es quasi zufällig, also quasi zufällig anhand der Walzen Stellung und Rotationen substituiert. Und von diesen Systemen gab es Dutzende. Also wir haben da so einen Link in den Shownows drinne zum Crypto Museum. Da gibt es halt so mehrere Dutzend so mechanischen Kryptosysteme.
Und die waren auch für die Zeit damals richtig cool, das war nicht klar, dass die brechbar sind.
Nee, also, naja.
Mit der Technik, die es gab, sagen wir mal.
Mit der Technik, die es gab. Aber die entwickelte sicher relativ frasant, was? Da können wir gleich noch zum zweiten Weltkrieg kommen. Ein wichtiges Detail war noch, dass im ersten Weltkrieg wurden zum ersten Mal im größten Maße Feldtelefone verwendet. Das heißt also Telefone, die in den Schützingreben installiert wurden, wo man halt so ein Draht irgendwie durch die Gegend gespannt hat und dann ein Telefon am anderen hatte. Aus zwei Gründen. Zum einen gab es damals noch nicht so richtig gut, fällttauglich benutzbare Funkgeräte in billig, die waren halt ziemlich teuer.
Und die wären abhörbar gewesen natürlich von der Gegenseite.
Und sie wären halt schon von der Gegenseite abhörbar gewesen, genau.
Und selbst wenn sie nicht abhörbar wären, wäre ja schon die Zunahme an Funk.
Und sie waren anpeilbar.
genau, das ist halt noch schlimmer. Also das heißt, man weiß genau, wo gerade was geplant ist.
Damals im ersten Weltkrieg war es halt auch so, dass hier halt einfach Modes teuer waren und zufällig waren. Also noch sehr, sehr, sehr in Anfängen.
Also was spannender an so einem Feldtelefon ist ja, dass es nur ein Draht ist. Wie funktioniert denn das?
Na es gibt verschiedene Systeme. Also damals hatten halt Systeme verwendet, die halt nur einen Draht hatten, unter anderem um Kupfer zu sparen, weil Kupfer auch teuer war. Und man hat die Erde, also sozusagen den Boden, als Return verwendet, um den Stromkreis zu schließen. Das heißt, man hat dann so einen fetten Nagel in den Boden gerammt. Und das Interessante daran war aber natürlich, dass man, wenn man einen entsprechend guten Verstärker hatte, dann konnte man aus diesem Signal wiederum rekonstruieren, was auf der anderen Seite telefoniert wurde. Weil die Schützengräben waren halt teilweise nur irgendwie 100, 200 Meter auseinander. Und dann haben die sich halt so die ersten, ich glaube, das waren sogar Röhrenverstöcker, dafür gebaut, um solche Signale von den Feldtelefonen der anderen Seite abzuzapfen und die halt mitzuhören. Und dann kamen die Zweirad-Feldtelefone mit, die das halt nicht mehr brauchten, weil die halt einen eigenen Rückkanal hatten. genau. Und dann war das erledigt. Aber damals war das halt so eines der sozusagen der ersten Anwendungsfälle von so genannter taktischer Signal Intelligence. Also die halt nicht strategisch, man stellt irgendwo einen riesigen Antennenpark hin und hört den Gegner ab über hunderte von Kilometern, sondern so richtig so unmittelbar, wenn du das weiß im Augen des Gegners siehst, dann hörst du trotzdem sein Telefonat ab.
Ja, aber das war ja trotzdem auch damals noch nicht so verbreitet, die Statistik. Das war eigentlich der ursprüngliche Sigint, oder?
genau.
Du müsstest vielleicht mal erklären, also Sigint ist Signal Intelligence. Das heißt, man stellt sich hin und hört sowas wie Funk ab. Wenn ich jetzt konkret ein Kabel abhöre, das ist eigentlich nicht Sigint, sondern ComInt.
Also diese ComInt, SigInt, Elint-Klassifizierung, die ist halt so schwammig an vielen Ecken und Enden, dass man sich damit auch nicht weiter aufhalten muss. Also das ist halt, das Signal Intelligence ist halt der Überbegriff für alles, weil halt alles im Zweifel ein Signal ist, auch wenn du irgendwie brüllst. Interessant daran ist halt, dass die Technologie, um zu verschlüsseln damals, war halt primär Kotbücher, aber es gab auch schon die ersten Leute, die mit sogenannten One-Time-Pads gearbeitet haben.
Haben die denn ihre Feldtelefone verschlüsselt oder nur die?
Da war nur der Generalstab so ein... Telegrafenverschlüsselung gab es.
Gut, aber das geht ja auch durch Land, was man nicht unbedingt kontrollieren kann. Es muss ja klar, dass das sein muss.
Ja, richtig interessant wurde dann die Sache, als es um die Unterwasserkabel ging. Die Kabel über den Atlantik, da gab es halt schon so die ersten, die eine Weile funktionierten.
Wichtiger war es aber zwischen Afrika und Europa im Mittelmeer. Das waren so auch die Sachen, wo strategisch gerade Krieg geführt wurde. Und da gab es lustige Details, wie das die die Technologie noch nicht hatten, um andere Leute Kabel abzuhören.
Jedenfalls nicht unter Wasser.
Jedenfalls nicht unter Wasser. Aber was sie dann gemacht haben, ist, dass sie einfach sich gegenseitig die Kabel immer durchgeschnitten haben. Die haben dann geguckt, wenn sie ein Kabel gefunden haben, was nicht ihr's war, haben sie es durchgeschnitten und haben aber ihr eigenes daran gebunden. So haben sie schnell verbunden in der Hoffnung, dass dann noch irgendwas lief und dass wir das dann empfangen können. Das heißt, im Wesentlichen haben die da eine unglaubliche Materialschlacht geführt gegeneinander, um sich immer ihre Kabel durchzuschneiden. Völlig absurd rückblickend. Aber so ist das eben Sigint heute. Da hat sich das Wertegefüge verschoben. Heute lässt man Kommunikationsinfrastruktur bestehen und hört zu. Und wie weit das ist, da kommen wir nachher auch noch zu. Früher hat man halt lieber kaputt gemacht. Aber je mehr man abhören kann, am besten noch noninvasiv, ohne da irgendwas zu beschädigen dabei, desto wertvoller ist es, dass das weiter bestehen bleibt. Das heißt, heute haben wir das so, dass eigentlich sehr selten Kommunikationskanäle kaputt gemacht werden. Höchstens von Betreibern selbst, wenn der glaubt, die sind nicht mehr sicher.
Oder wenn zum Beispiel in Ägypten die Abhörkapazitäten überladen sind, also sie halt einfach nicht mehr genügend Kapazitäten zum Abhören haben.
Ja, aber es war auch Ägypten selbst, was das Internet zugemacht hat in Ägypten. Es war nicht irgendwie, dass die Amis das Internet abhören.
genau, aber da war es halt die Regierung versus die Opposition. Da war es dann irgendwann offenbar der Punkt erreicht, wo die Regierung die Opposition nicht mehr komplett abhören konnte, weil die Opposition zu groß geworden war und sie dann halt eben lieber ausgemacht haben, weil sie eben nicht mehr zuhören konnten. Zurück zur Geschichte. Zwischen den beiden Weltkriegen, dem ersten und zweiten Weltkrieg, gab es einen riegerichten Boom der mechanischen Kryptomaschinen.
Der ging auch gar nicht unbedingt von Deutschland aus, sondern wie war das, die Schweden hatten da irgendwie?
Schweden, Schweiz, Frankreich, in Deutschland aber auch.
Deutschland auch. Die Polen waren relativ gut dabei.
Ziemlich viele Länder in Europa haben halt so Kryptomaschinen damals gebaut. Das war interessanterweise so eine Szene von so, naja, heute würde man sagen Start-ups, also von individuellen Erfindern mit ein bisschen Wagniskapital, die dann angefangen haben, so Kryptomaschinen zu bauen. Also damals fingen halt so Sachen an, dass dann der Staat gesagt hat, naja.
Das patentieren wir jetzt aber nicht, sonst weiß der Gegner, wie es geht.
Das zum einen und zum anderen aber auch mit Backdoors, also dass man irgendwie mal eine Erkenntnisse darüber hatte, wie man so eine Maschine so bauen konnte, dass man aus subtilen Zeichen zum Beispiel in dem Text wissen konnte, was der Schlüssel war, dass man dann Einfluss genommen hat auf diese Leute. Also viele von den Mechanismen, die wir heute sehen, Einflussnahme, Verschlüsselungstechnologie, die gab es damals auch schon so in den 20er und 30er Jahren. Im zweiten Weltkrieg war es halt so, dass die Signs Intelligence von allen Seiten explodierte. Eigentlich in allen Armeen gab es große Abteilungen dafür. Und auch Krypto brechen spielte plötzlich eine Rolle.
genau, das spielte plötzlich eine Rolle, die zunehmend wichtiger wurde. Eine der Keimzellen davon, auch heute noch bekannt und berühmt, ist ja Bletchley Park. Das war der Kryptogramm der Briten. Die Polen waren auch relativ gut im Krypto brechen. Die waren der Auslöser dafür, dass die Enigma gebrochen wurde. Und zwar teilweise wohl über wissenschaftliche Publikation. Also das fand ich relativ witzig. Das war nicht alles nur klandestin, sondern die haben sich Details von Leuten, die da gearbeitet hatten oder von irgendwelchen Publikationen darüber genommen und hatten herausgefunden, so wie grob die Enigma funktioniert.
Was halt so ein Teil damit auch zu tun hatte, dass gerade die Enigma eben auch ein kommerzielles Kryptosystem war, was die Leute, die es initial gebaut und erfunden haben, zwischen den Kriegen halt auch als kommerzielles System verkauft haben und die militärischen Varianten dann davon abgeleitet waren. Und da ging es halt zum Beispiel um die Anzahl der Walzen, wie häufig die sich weiter drehten, wie komplex die innere Verdrahtung dieser Walzen war. Das waren halt so die Parameter, aus denen die Güter eines Kryptosystems damals gestanden.
Und das hat sich auch während des Krieges noch geändert. Also die Nazis haben gegenüber dem von den Polen analysierten System dann so 1939 oder so, ich hab jetzt das Datum vergessen, haben sie die Komplexität um eine Faktor-10 erhöht. Und das hätte eigentlich die ausländischen Vermehrungen getötet. Aber dann haben die Polen ihre alten Erkenntnisse an die Briten weitergegeben und damit haben die Briten das dann brechen können.
Diese Enigma-Geschichte ist ja relativ weit, auch Popgold wäre verwurstet worden. Also da gibt es halt irgendwie Bücher und Filme und dergleichen Dinge.
Aber was mir gar nicht klar war, ist, wie lang das gedauert hat, bis den Deutschen überhaupt klar war, dass die Enigma gebrochen ist. Das war ja keineswegs so, dass 45 die Deutschen oder sich vorher vielleicht schon gesagt haben, hm, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht. Sondern das ist nach dem Krieg noch im Einsatz gewesen.
Interessanterweise gab es, also es gab durchaus deutsche Krypto-Offiziere, die eine klare Ahnung hatten, dass da was nicht stimmt. Und der Grund, warum es halt auch so spät war, dass die Deutschen oder in Deutschland klar wurde, dass dieser Enigma gebrochen war, war unter anderem auch, dass die Briten einen riesigen Aufwand getrieben haben, die Amis auch, um zu verschleiern, dass sie dieses Kryptosystem gebrochen hatten. Also zum einen...
Das war übrigens nicht nur bei Kryptosystemen, sondern es war auch bei Agentensachen. Es gibt da diese sehr witzige Geschichte von einem Doppelagenten, ein britischer Agent, der bei den Deutschen eingeschleust werden sollte und der denen erzählt hat, er sei jetzt ein Agent, der für sie in England eine Fabrik sabotieren würde und haben die da wirklich eine Explosion gemacht. Sie haben wirklich eine Explosion gemacht. Also die haben jetzt nicht ihr Material vernichtet, aber es gab da wirklich eine Explosion, eine große rauchwolke und die Presse hat darüber berichtet, dass die Fabrik in die Luft geflogen ist.
Um dessen Legitimität herzustellen.
genau, um dessen Legitimität herzustellen. Und dieses Prinzip ist aus der Zeit sozusagen, das wird ja heute immer noch gemacht, vielleicht nicht ganz so krass. Aber man weiß es nicht, heute ist das ja auch einfacher.
Der Verfassungsschutz tut es dann auch schon noch.
Heute ist es auch einfacher, so eine Nachricht zu fälschen und zu sagen, hier ist das und das passiert. Aber früher...
Ich glaube, damals war es einfacher. Da gab es weniger Zeitung.
Ja, aber heute kannst du einfach ein bisschen rumtweeten und die Leute glauben dir nicht.
Na, da gibt es so viele Leute, die dann da warnen und nicht...
Na gut, aber das ist ja Verfassungsschutz. Ja, das stimmt.
In Deutschland gab es halt schon Crypto-Offiziere, die der Meinung waren, das kann nicht mit rechten Dingen zugehen und da hat sich zu viel angehäuft an komischen Vorkommnissen und so dachten sie schon, dass da irgendetwas Fischi ist. Und deswegen gab es auch immer wieder zwischendurch, dass sie das Thema umgestellt haben.
Neue Code-Bücher verteilt haben. Ja, aber das ist halt nicht so einfach, wenn man so eine U-Boot-Flotte hat, die da unterwegs ist, den kann man halt nicht ein neues Boot per Post schicken, sondern das ist ja ein Logistikproblem.
genau, und die Briten haben halt sehr umfänglich an den Stories gearbeitet. Also die haben halt immer versucht, wenn sie halt zum Beispiel angefangen haben, U-Boote zu versenken, haben sie halt vorher Flugzeuge in dieses Seegebiet geschickt. So quasi rein zufällig.
Also auf Patrouille.
Auf Patrouille, um dann zufällig diese U-Boote zu finden. Und den deutschen U-Boot-Fahrern fiel es halt irgendwann auf, weil sie immer Flugzeuge gesehen haben und sich dann irgendwann ausweichen konnten, okay, die Briten können nicht so viele Flugzeuge haben, um den ganzen Atlantik zu patrouillieren. Und dass die immer da auftauchten, war ein bisschen komisch. Und dann haben die Briten alle möglichen Stories zirkuliert und sie haben teilweise eben auch Erkenntnisse nicht verwendet. Also sie haben halt, wenn sie nicht in der Lage waren, eine Cover-Story zu bauen dafür, dann haben sie häufiger mal, also zumindest anfangs, die Erkenntnisse nicht angewendet. Also dann saßen sie auf den Ergebnissen und haben teilweise zugucken müssen, wie viele Schiffe verloren haben oder Schlachten verloren haben, weil sie nicht plausibel erklären konnten, wo sie jetzt diese Erkenntnisse hatten, außer durch ein Boot des Kryptosystems. Und dann haben sie halt drauf gesessen, weil sie sich sagten, okay, langfristig ist sinnvoller, dieses Kryptosystem weiterbrechen und mitlesen zu können, als jetzt diese eine Schlacht möglicherweise nicht zu verlieren.
Sowas erzählt man sich ja auch von paul Haber.
Ja, paul Haber, Coventry, da gibt es eine Menge Geschichten, wo die Indizien relativ dicht sind, dass es schon gewusst wurde, dass da was passieren wird, also dass da ein Angriff passiert. Und dann aber, dass nicht genutzt wurde, die Information um den Bruch des Kryptosystems zu schützen.
Es ist überhaupt eine technisch sehr spannende Zeit. Also es ist ja auch radar erfunden worden. Funktionierte nicht von Anfang an in allen Dimensionen und mit richtig Range und so. Und dann haben die sich versucht, da die Prototypen zu sabotieren, gegen sie eher so sehr spannende Geschichte. Ich hoffe, da kommen noch mehr Details raus.
Man darf nicht vergessen, einiges davon ist halt in Großbritannien immer noch unter dem Official Secrets Act. Also ist immer noch nicht die gesamte Geschichte vollständig. Jedenfalls diese Bletchley Park Geschichte lohnt es halt zu lesen. Also auch die popkulturellen Verarbeitungen davon. Also da gibt es halt so Filme und von Robert Harris gibt es ein Buch über die Enigma. Das ist ein Roman, der sich aber relativ dicht ans historische Vorbild hält. Und auch eine Menge andere Publikation, zum Beispiel auch die Biografie von Alan Turing und so. Man muss ja auch sagen, so Alan Turing, der quasi der geistige Vater des modernen Computers, der hat halt da gearbeitet. Und viele von den Dingen, die wir heute als Selbstverständlichheit in der Datenverarbeitung ansehen, sind damals erschaffen worden, um deutsche Krypto zu brechen. Auch interessant ist halt der riesige Aufwand, der da betrieben wurde. Also um einzelne Nachrichten zu brechen, haben da tausende von Leuten gearbeitet. Zu Kriegszeiten, wo eigentlich, na ja.
Jede Hand gebraucht wurde.
Jede Hand sonst gebraucht wurde.
Das ist überhaupt eine Lektion, die wir nicht häufig genug wiederholen können. Immer wenn man denkt, na ja, so viel Aufwand werden die schon nicht treiben, doch. Doch, kann man zusammenfassen, doch tut sie. Ja, schon im Krieg gab es dann das erste Agreement zwischen den Briten und den USA, um in Intelligenz-Angelegenheiten zusammenzuarbeiten. Das hieß damals BA. USA. Das ist 1943 formalisiert worden. Vorher gab es auch schon so ein paar Treaties, aber das war so das erste richtige Abkommen. Das ist später ausgebaut worden. Hieß dann UK USA und ist heute Five Eyes. Also Britain USA, das heißt eben erstens die Amerikaner, aber zweitens eben nicht nur die Engländer, sondern auch das Commonwealth, also auch Kanada, Australien, Neuseeland.
genau, dann die fünf Five Eyes.
Und das sind heute die Five Eyes. Das geht zurück auf ein Abkommen von 1943, das natürlich nicht öffentlich war. Du hast das alles viel später erst rausgekommen. Ja, die NSA gab es noch nicht zu der Zeit. Da gab es eine Vorgängerveranstaltung, die hieß Air Force Security Agency, AFSA. Und die hat schon 1945 offiziell den Auftrag gehabt, die Telegramme abzufangen. Und zwar nicht nur die vom Feind, sondern alle aus dem Ausland. Also das ist so die erste dokumentierte Wir müssen jetzt alles abhören Order, die ich finden konnte. 1945, das hieß Project Shamrock. Shamrock ist eigentlich Klee, wie ein Blättriger Klee. Tja, dann wahrscheinlich haben sie gehofft, damit gemeint, dass sie Glück haben werden, dass noch mal was dabei ist. Das lustige ist, dass es halt die Technologie noch nicht gab. Das heißt, dass ist alles tatsächlich manuell gemacht worden ist.
genau, tausend von Leuten.
Die haben von Western Union und anderen Leuten, die damals Telegrafen betrieben haben an den Grenzen, haben sie fette Ausdrucke gekriegt und haben die einfach jeden Abend abgeholt und haben die dann mit einer Armee von Leuten gesichtet. Der Aufwand war enorm, aber es reicht halt gelegentlich mal was zu finden, was sich dann als richtig wichtig herausstellt, um so ein Projekt insgesamt zu rechtfertigen. Nach dem Krieg haben die Alliierten auch in Deutschland Abwehrstützpunkte installiert. Dutzende, die bekanntesten waren Berlin Teufelsberg und Bad Eibling, aber es gab ganz viele. Teilweise kann man die Rudamente, glaube ich, heute noch sehen. Ich weiß nicht, also es gab einen Link, das war mal ganz gut zu sehen, wenn man mit dem ICE aus München nach Berlin fuhr. Dann gab es so kurz hinter München auf der rechten Seite gab es so eine Antenneninstallation, die sehr deutlich nach Sigint aussah. Wir können jetzt mal beschreiben, wie so was aussieht. Das muss man sich vorstellen wie so konzentrische Kreise. Das sieht so ähnlich aus wie, wie würde das mal... In Berlin gibt es so eine Installation, wo dran steht, das sei zur Gasvermessung in der Atmosphäre oder so was. Und das ist irgendwo in Westberlin im Grundewald. Das ist auch so ein rundes Gitter aus zaun. Im Wesentlichen sieht es aus wie zaun. Geht irgendwie 10, 20 Meter hoch oder so. Also der Durchmesser ist 50 Meter, schätze ich mal so.
Ja, die sind teilweise auch größer. Also der Nickname für diese Dinge ist Elephant Cage, also Elefantenkiefige.
Und da gibt es halt drei Kreise. Die inneren beiden sehen aus wie zaun. Und der äußere sind so Pöller. Das sieht sehr charakteristisch aus. Wenn man das einmal gesehen hat, erkennt man das dann wieder.
genau, und es sind halt Systeme zum Kurzwellenpeilen. Also um festzustellen, aus welcher Richtung ein Kurzwellensignal kommt. Kurzwellensignale, die immer noch verwendet werden, tatsächlich im verschiedensten Gebieten, werden an der Atmosphäre reflektiert. Und was man halt mit diesem System macht, ist zu gucken, von wo sieht man dieses Signal zuerst und von wo später. daraus kann man dann ausrechnen, aus welcher Richtung es kommt. Andere Systeme zum Abhören, also zum Beispiel für Mikrowellensysteme, Richtfunkverbindungen, da hat man entweder dann halt einen Turm, also so eine Richtfunkstrecke stellt man sich immer vor, da sind zwei Türme und da sind oben Antennen drauf, die aufeinander gerichtet sind und dazwischen wird dann ein stark gebündeltes Signal geschickt.
Diese Antennen sehen aus wie so eine Trommel, kann man sich vorstellen.
Ja, genau, wie so Trommeln. Und die enden halt nicht an dem Empfangsturm. Also das Signal... Die strahlen gehen halt weiter.
Und strahlen dann in den weltraum.
Geht halt immer weiter und die NSA hat dann halt irgendwann in den 60ern, als sie festgestellt haben, dass die Sowjetunion in großem Umfang ihre riesigen Gebiete mit Mikrowellen-Schlüsseln erschließt. Also mit so Türmen, die halt so alle 30 Kilometer stehen, wobei so Mikrowellen-Antennen drauf sind. Die 30 Kilometer ergeben sich halt so aus dem...
Aus der Erdkörmung.
Ja, ergebts nicht aus der Erdkörmung. Also weil die Erde ist halt nicht keine Scheibe, sondern rund, auch wenn es jetzt einige überraschen mag. Und daraus folgt halt, wenn man versucht, von einem Punkt zum anderen auf der Erdoberfläche zu senden, dann trifft man halt irgendwann, wenn die Punkte weit genau auseinander sind, die Erdkörmung und dann kommt es ihnen halt nicht mehr an. Deswegen hat man zum einen große Türme, damit man ein bisschen mehr Platz hat bis zur Krümmung. Und zum anderen gibt es halt einen definierten Abstand, wie weit man die Dinge auseinander stellen kann. Kann man auch ausrechnen, könnte man als hausaufgabe machen, wie weit man so Mikrometer auseinander stellen kann. Die Sowjets haben halt echt viele davon hingestellt, weil die haben halt ein riesiges Land. Und da so irgendwie alle paar Dutzend Kilometer mal so einen Turm hinzustellen, geht halt, aber da überall Kabel durch den Sumpf zu legen in Sibirien, ging halt eigentlich nicht. Und deswegen ging halt oder geht halt auch immer noch in den Großteil der Kommunikation da über Mikrowellenverbindungen. Und da die Amis da jetzt nicht direkt ran kamen, sie konnten ja schlecht in Sibirien da halt mal einen Abhörturm errichten an der zentralen Stelle, haben sie dann ausgenutzt, dass die Mikrowellenverbindungen weitergehen ins Weltall. Das heißt also von der Antenne aus werden die weiter gesendet, dann wird ein kleiner Teil dieses Signals an dem Empfängerturm empfangen und der Rest geht halt prima weiter ins Weltall. Und dann haben sie halt riesige Satelliten geparkt, um diese Signale aufzufangen.
Weil physische Nähe so wichtig ist, ist auch einer der hauptgründe, warum West-Berlin in Amerikanischer und Alliater Hand geblieben ist, dass sie dann eine wunderbare Abhörinstallation auf dem Teufelsberg hinbauen können. Das ist eigentlich eine relativ ebene Landschaft. Das heißt, da ist auch kein Gebirge auf dem Weg Richtung moskau. Also es ist natürlich wieder Erdkommung und so.
Bis moskau kam man vom Teufelsberg aus nicht, was jetzt irgendwie im normalen Mikrowellen geht. Aber dieser Turm, also wenn ihr euch mal so Bilder vom Teufelsberg anguckt, dann habt ihr diesen...
Kurzwellen ging wohl.
Ja, aber wir sind ja gerade von Mikrowellen gewesen. Und wenn man sich diesen Turm vom Teufelsberg anguckt, hat er diese charakteristische zwei Kugeln unten und dann dieser weiße Turm in der Mitte mit der kleinen Kugel oben. Und dieser weiße Turm in der Mitte, der hat halt so Etagen. Und wenn man auf diese Etagen guckt, dann sind die verkleidet mit so einem weißen Textil, was mittlerweile da in Fetzen rumhängt. Und dieses weiße Textil ist eine besonders funkdurchlässige Wetterschutzmembran. Und dahinter haben die auf diesen Etagen Mikrowellenantennen gehabt, die sie umherfahren und präzise ausrichten konnten. Und das diente tatsächlich dazu, um auf möglichst großer Entfernung die Mikrowellen-Signale von DDR-Mikrowellenstrecken zu empfangen und abzuhören. Das heißt also dieser Turm dient nicht nur dazu, das ist ein Radom oben möglichst hochzukriegen, sondern der hat glaube ich sieben oder so Etagen, auf denen halt diese Mikrowellenantennen standen. Wenn man da hochgeht, dann sieht man auf dem Boden tatsächlich auch die Markierung, wo diese Antennen standen und die Bolzen, mit denen die festgeschraubt waren. Und das war halt extra so ausgerichtet, also auch mit durch die Etagen gehenden Klappen mit so einem Aufzugssystem, wo man neue Antennen hochkriegte, damit die möglichst flexibel, wenn im Osten eine neue Mikrowellenstrecke hochging, sie möglichst gut ausrichten können. genau, dass sie die Ausrichtung möglichst präzise hinbekommen konnten. Und dieser Teufelsberg ist auch so ein klassisches Beispiel dafür. Für so einen Aufwand würden die doch nie treiben.
genau, Kost gespielt, keine Rolle, wenn es darum geht.
Wenn man sich diesen Teufelsberg anguckt, also mittlerweile ist leider alles echt ganz schön vandalisiert, aber wir waren damals ja da, als es noch relativ viel zu sehen war. Da können wir auch mal verlinken, die Bilder von damals. Also ich habe mir verschiedene aufgelassene Abhörstationen im Osten angeguckt, Stasi-Stationen, die haben da schon ziemlich einen Aufwand getrieben, aber dieser Teufelsberg, das war halt schon echt beeindruckend.
Rocket Science.
Naja, auch einfach die Dimension von Geld spielt keine Rolle, die sie da betrieben haben. Also einfach dieses ganze Gebäude da irgendwie so in Abstrahl sicher zu bauen, mit irgendwie noch mal extra Kupfer, verbunkerten Kellergeschoss und irgendwie noch mal extra abstrahlgeschützten raum hier und da.
Und dieser coole Monsterschrenner.
Und dieser Monsterschrenner, genau. Und überall an den Stellen, wo es wichtig war, Fasern, also wir reden von den 80er Jahren, also Fasern in druckgefüllten Röhren, also um sicherzustellen, dass niemand an die Faser geht. Das hat so eine Technologie, also du machst quasi ein Druckluftrohr oder genau gesagt manchmal sogar ein Edelgas, damit du merkst, falls da irgendwo Luft zieht. Und da drin verlegst du deine Faser.
Und wenn es jetzt jemand aufbohrt?
Und wenn jemand da ran will, dann muss er halt irgendwie sich einen Weg ausdenken, wie er halt in diesem Rohr sozusagen ohne, dass der Druck da weggeht, diese Faser manipuliert bekommt. Und sowas haben die da verbaut schon in den 80ern. Wir haben da halt einen bauplan, der lag da im Dreck, gesehen, wo man den Grundriss vom Rechenzentrum sah, irgendwann aus den 80er Jahren, wie die Rex standen so. Und was man da gesehen hat, waren dann so, ich glaube vier oder sechs, so Omega-förmige Dinger. Und das waren halt die Krays, die da standen. Das heißt, die hatten da oben mehr Krays als in allen Unis in Westdeutschland zusammen zu dieser Zeit. Und die standen da einfach nur, um Codebreaking zu machen und irgendwie Sachen zu sortieren. Und von diesen Abhörschutzfunden, gut, also Filsdreschen-Törfelsberg war mit die wichtigste und größte so, die halt auch zusammen mit den Briten betrieben wurde. Aber davon gab es halt auch mehr. Also und zwar interessanterweise auf beiden Seiten. Auf östlicher Seite die größte war auf dem Brocken im Harz, die weitgehend von den Sowjets betrieben wurde. Und war auch so ein Riesending, wo sie halt mit Unmengen von Leuten den Funkverkehr im Westen abgehört haben.
Und lustigerweise auch ein Radio betrieben haben, ne? Die haben noch da dieses Verarschungsradio betrieben, wo sie immer lustige Botschaften durchgesackt haben.
Das gab es auch da ja. Also der Brocken ist halt deswegen geeignet, weil so eine hohe Erhebung in einer sonst relativ flachen Landschaft ist, von der man halt auch relativ weit in den Westen reinhorchen kann. Also gab es auf beiden Seiten der Grenze so Ketten von so Abhörstützpunkten, die jeweils betrieben wurden, bis hin zu so super obskuren Sachen, dass zum Beispiel der BND einer Quelle zufolge über Jahrzehnte hinweg eine Abhörstation in China betrieben hat. Offenbar in Kooperation mit den Chinesen. Damals meine China waren halt schon nicht die Freunde.
Der Klassenfeind.
War eigentlich schon der Klassenfeind, aber da ging es halt gegen die Sowjets. Und das heißt, die haben damals die Telemetrie und auch den Funk von den sowjetischen Intercontinentalraketentests von China aus abgeschneuchelt und Gerüchte halber halt eben die Erkenntnisse halt mit den Chinesen geteilt, deswegen sie halt da diese Station betreiben durften. Oder zum Beispiel diese Geschichte mit dieser automatischen Sigint-Station, die die Amis im Himalaya verloren haben.
Ja, wo dann ihre nukleare Plutoniumbatterie verloren gegangen ist und sie wissen bis heute nicht in welche Rezept der genau gefallen ist. Ja, ganz furchtbar. Also das ist unwirtliches Gelände, na.
Da haben sie halt eben auch, um an sowjetische Intercontinentalraketentelemetrie zu kommen, mit einer Monsterexpedition so ein Abhörsystem ins Himalaya stellen wollen.
Aber so eine typische Anmi-Aktion, so Hail Mary, das funktioniert jetzt entweder oder wir haben halt verloren.
Ja, vermutlich. Und mit einer Plutoniumbatterie, und die ist ihnen dann irgendeine Gebirgsspalte gefahren.
Und verstrahlt jetzt das Grund, was da da... Also der Aufwand ist schon immer, nicht nur im Kalten Krieg, ist immens, der für sowas ausgegeben wird.
Ja, aber der Kalte Krieg ist halt wichtig dafür, weil der das Geld spielt, keine Rolle Mindset geprägt hat. Also zum Beispiel, was die ja über lange Jahre betrieben haben, waren ja diese Grenzflügel.
Ja, ganz furchtbar. Also es gab ja über DDR ein Gebiet drei Korridore, die freigegeben waren für zivile Luftfahrt nach Westberlin. Und die Amerikaner haben dann zivile Flugzeuge genommen und haben da unten Schnüffel-Elektronik reingebaut und haben dann den Piloten gesagt, der soll wie so ein Besoffener immer so Schlangenlinien fahren, damit er beim Kurve machen mit dem Boden immer außerhalb des Korridors zeigt und möglichst großes Gelände mitnimmt. Und die haben also wirklich, kann man nur als Provokation bezeichnen, ein Wunder, dass da nicht dauernd zum Krieg gekommen ist. Aber so ging das halt im Kalten Krieg. Das war der Mindset. Wir müssen das wissen, also machen wir das. Auch diese U-2-Flüge waren ja im Grunde eine Frechheit.
Und da gab es ja auch eine Menge Geschichten, wo die Amis an den Südgrenzen der Sowjetunion da so lang gekurvt sind mit Flugzeugen, also auch mit Sigint-Flugzeugen, um Radar und Funk aufzuklären. Da gab es dann so ein paar Zwischenfälle, wo die Sowjets davon so genervt waren, dass sie die Funkfeuer, an denen sich diese Flugzeuge orientiert haben, verschoben haben.
Oh, jetzt sitzt sie doch auf unserem Hoheitsgebiet.
Sodass sie über sowetischem Hoheitsgebiet waren, haben sie Eisenhardt abgeschossen. Also einfach ohne weitere große Warnung abgeschossen. Also bei der NSA betreibt sie das National Cryptologic Museum.
Was man ja heute noch macht, diese GPS-Manipulation funktioniert ja auch so, dass man einfach die Idee des Opfers ändert, wo es gerade ist.
genau. Also direkt vor dem NSA-Gebäude gibt es ein Museum, das National Cryptologic Museum. Wer mal dahin in die Gegend schafft, sollte da unbedingt hingehen. Das ist wirklich sehr sehenswert. Und in diesem Museum gibt es halt vorne so ein Altar. So ein, also der sieht halt echt spooky aus. Es gibt auch Bilder im Netz. Das ist halt so ein dreiecksförmiges, schwarzes Marmor-Ding mit der Überschrift They Served in Silence.
Ach mein Gott, der ganze Opfer des Kalten Krieges.
Wo sie dann halt ihre 190 oder was auch immer sind. Die Leute, die ihnen halt, nicht nur Kalte Kriegs, sondern...
Die NSA Leute.
Die NSA Leute. Also insbesondere halt die, die von den verschiedenen Armeen und sonstigen Waffengatten zu NSA abgeordert sind. Also NSA ist ja nicht nur eine reine zivile Organisation, sondern die besteht zum großen Teil aus Militärpersonal.
Ist da auch die USS Liberty beteiligt, ja, ne?
Ja, da sind auch die USS Liberty.
Erzähl doch mal kurz die Geschichte.
Also die USS Liberty ist so eine dieser Geschichten, wo sich das so zeigt, dass es halt so, also Sigint erzählt uns halt eben nicht nur Gefährliches, wenn man halt an den ansovetischen Grenzen lang fliegt und dann da reingelockt und abgeschossen wird. Die USS Liberty war ein NSA-Schiff, also ein Sigint-Aufklärungsschiff, was im Mittelmeer rumgeschippert ist und vor der libanesisch-israelischen Küste. Und die wurden von den Israelis zusammengeschossen, also mit Dutzenden von Opfern.
Also richtig zerballert, so um die Flugzeuge wie ein Käse am Ende mit mehr Löchern als noch Stahl übrig.
Also halt so mit Maschinenkanonen, halt irgendwie so mit mehreren vielen Anflügen, halt komplett zerballert. Und die Israelis haben sich dann hinterher mit, ja, ach ne, Entschuldigung, das war wohl eine Verwechslung. Wir dachten, das war irgendwas anderes und es tut uns ja wirklich leid.
Und das nimmt die NSA heute noch übel. Also das war so richtig, das hat ganz schlechte laune gemacht.
Also dieses Detailer lohnt sich halt, diesem NSA-Museum nochmal zehn Minuten zuzubringen. Also da gibt es halt diesen Altar da mit diesem Self and Silence, wo es auch so unter anderem Eintracht gibt, halt irgendwie für NSA-Personal, wo dann steht Name withheld, also wo sie bis heute nicht zugeben, dass es irgendwie einer der irren war. Und dann gibt es rechts daneben gibt es halt diese Wand. So yours is liberty. So und wo sie und die offizielle Geschichte ist ja so, ja gut, die Amis haben in die Israelis halt irgendwann geglaubt, dass es halt ein Versehen war und tut uns sehr leid, und wir sind ja alle Freunde hier.
Das war so ehrlich, die diplomatische Einigung.
Ja, aber da wird halt schon ganz klar, das ist nicht so ganz vergeben und vergessen. Das gibt da schon durchaus noch ein institutionelles Gegrummel deswegen. Also immer noch so. Und jedenfalls dieses Detail, aber von diesem Altar da, mit diesen Dings, da ist halt eben durchaus, dass die meisten Leute, die da umgekommen sind, halt Vietnamkrieg, yours is liberty und jetzt Irak und Afghanistan. Das sind halt so die drei Gruppen, wo sie am meisten Opfer haben, woraus man noch sehen kann, wo sie am meisten Leute am Einsatz hatten. Und das ist halt eben auch so eine der Aufgaben, die die NSA halt hat, sind diese Frontline Cryptologic Operators, die halt deren Decryption und Single Intelligence Geräte direkt an der Front betreiben und halt dafür sorgen, dass es keinen allzu langen Dips gibt.
The best intelligence for our troops.
genau, ist das Schlagwort dabei.
Mikrowellen und Richtfunk, der nächste Schritt war Satelliten.
genau.
Und Satelliten funktionieren so, dass der Satellitesignal zurück zur Erde reflektiert, aber der zielt halt nicht punktgenau wie so ein Laser. Das heißt, wenn man in der Gegend eine zweite Schüssel hinstellt, dann kriegt man dasselbe Signal. Und dementsprechend gibt es für Intel SAT-Satelliten eine Menge zweite Bodenstationen irgendwo im Urwald. Ja, in Neuseeland gibt es eine, die ist relativ bekannt, weil da einfach mal ein Fernsehteam reingelaufen ist, da kommen wir auch noch zu. Aber das sind Stationen, die sehen tatsächlich genauso aus, wie kopiert die offizielle Bodenstation und die nehmen halt einfach dieselben Signale mit und leiten die weiter. Also so fängt man Satellitenkommunikation ab. Dann kann man natürlich Kupferkabel verlegen. Das lässt sich auch abhören, sogar nicht invasiv, weil man das Signal per Induktion abgreifen kann. Das ist technisch ein bisschen anspruchsvoller, weil man ein bisschen größeres Equipment braucht, aber man macht halt so eine Spule darum im Wesentlichen und rechnet dann das Signal zurück. Und das Schöne ist, dass man eben das Kabel nicht kaputt machen muss dafür. Das heißt, das ist nur zu erkennen daran, dass das Signal ein bisschen schwächer wird. Aber das ist so wenig, wenn man es richtig macht, dass das im Grunde nicht nachweisbar ist. Im Übrigen ist es ja so, dass so ein Untersehkabel, also die Kabel, die man anzapfen will durch so was, diese Kabel sind ja so lang, dass es auf dem Wege Signalverstärker gibt. Das heißt, das Signal hält gar nicht von allein in den ganzen Weg. So ein Kabel hat Dämpfung. Und das heißt, dass die Dämpfung, die durch dieses Induktionsabhören entsteht, die geht nur bis zum nächsten Verstärker am Ende, kann man die nicht mehr sehen. Oder man kann auch direkt den Verstärker angreifen natürlich. Das wird teilweise auch geschehen. Aber es gibt eben auch Fälle, wo man das Kupferkabel per Induktion angegriffen hat. Da kommen wir auch noch zu. Und die nächste Evolution sind Glasfaserkabel.
Also darüber funktioniert eigentlich der Großteil der Modellkonfektion heute.
Also über 99 Prozent. Glasfaserkabel kann man auch abhören, obwohl das am Anfang gedacht wurde, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Aber da gibt es mehrere Verfahren. Man kann das Kabel so ein bisschen biegen. Dann geht zwar der hauptteil des Signals weiter in dem Kabel, aber ein Teil streut eben aus, den kann man messen.
Ist das so ein Biegelkoppler, wenn man dann stichwurzelt so nach Google?
Dann gibt es auch bei Glasfaserkabeln, wenn die lang genug sind, Verstärker, wo man rangehen kann. Und dann, wenn die gespleißt sind, kann man ein Teil des Lichts abgreifen. Ja, das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste. Also es gab ganz am Anfang so Geschichten, dass die Prismen ins Kabel einbauen. Das war so in einer der 80er-Jahre Veröffentlichung über die NSA. Ob das wirklich wahr ist, weiß ich nicht, weil das ist halt nicht die einfachste Methode. Theoretisch ist das natürlich denkbar.
Die Stasi hat schon in den 80ern einen Biegelkoppler gekannt. Man kann den Stasi-Biegelkoppler sich tatsächlich in Berlin hier angucken. Der liegt in dem Posten-Kommunikationsmuseum in der Leipziger Straße. Ist halt in so einem Schorkasten eingebaut, aber das ist das Original, was sie da benutzt haben.
Es gibt auch ein KGB-Museum, stellt sich aus, in moskau. Das haben wir entschieden, dass wir da mal hinfahren wollen. Und da gibt es angeblich einen von diesen Kupferkabel-Induktions-Taps, die die Amis angebracht haben, zu sehen. Das möchte ich ja schon mal sehen, wie das aussieht. Aber grundsätzlich, man kann also alles abhören. Alle Technologien, die es gibt, kann man abhören. Sogar der neueste Schrei war, dass man sagt, man hat Quanten-Kommunikation und die ist völlig unabhörbar. Aber auch dafür gibt es inzwischen Ideen. Da ist zwar nicht die Physik angreifbar, aber man spricht ja ein Protokoll darüber, muss damit umgehen, wenn ein Teil der Botschaft nicht ankommt. Darüber kann man dann eben doch Rückflüsse ziehen.
Ja, und du kannst halt über Replikationen der Photonen arbeiten. Da gibt es verschiedenste Angriffsmöglichkeiten.
Also jedenfalls der Punkt ist, es gibt kein bekanntes Verfahren zur Kommunikation, das man nicht irgendwie abgreifen kann.
genau. Alle elektronische Kommunikation ist abhörbar, kann man sozusagen sagen.
Geht davon aus, wenn ihr irgendwas macht, wird das abgehört. So, Wanzen, genau, als wir noch mal ein paar von abgefahrenen Wanzentechnologien.
genau, also wenn man an die Kommunikation nicht rankommt, weil die zum Beispiel verschlüsselt ist, dann versucht man natürlich, die abzugreifen, bevor sie verschlüsselt wird. Also typischerweise, wenn es ein gesprochenes Wort ist, dann versucht man eine Audiowanz zu haben oder wenn es kein Audio bekommt, dann entweistens Video. Die Innovation, die halt bei so Audioabhörern getrieben wird, ist halt schon ziemlich enorm. Und da gibt es halt auch eine Menge Technologien, die sind so abgefahren, dass man eigentlich nicht glaubt, dass sie den Aufwand treiben würden.
Und das ist überhaupt funktioniert?
genau, das ist überhaupt funktioniert.
Ganz am Anfang waren es einfach so Tapes. Lustigerweise auch diese Kupferkabel-Abbreif-Taps der Amerikaner.
Das waren auch Tapes.
Das waren auch Tapes. Da sind die dann einmal ein Monat hin gefahren mit ihrem U-Boot, haben die Tapes gewechselt.
Ja, natürlich. Tapes waren halt...
Das war die Speichertynologie.
Die haben mehrere Dutzend Megahertz Funkspektrum auf Tape geschrieben. Der typische Weg für so eine Wanze zum Abhören, was man halt so tun, ist halt ein Mikrofon. Und dann zeichnet man es halt irgendwo auf, also auf einer SD-Karte oder Funktelefon dahinter. Aber wenn man sich halt dagegen schützen will, dass der Abgehörte rausfindet, dass er abgehört wird, dann kann man halt alle möglichen Varianten verwenden. So ein relativ einfacher, das ist ein solches Körperschallmikrofon. Das heißt, man nimmt ein Mikrofon, was nicht den Luftschall aufnimmt, sondern zum Beispiel in eine Wand reingebohrt wird. Also zum Beispiel in einen Dielenfußboden oder so, oder daran gesaugt wird und halt die Vibration aufnimmt und verstärkt. Dazu braucht man halt ein moderner Hochtassungsverstärker, der können halt Schall mehrere Millionen Mal problemlos verstärken. Das heißt, man kann extremst feine Schallschwingungen aufnehmen. Dann gibt es halt auch Methoden, dass man zum Beispiel, habt ihr vielleicht mal in einem James Bond Film gesehen, wobei bei James Bond kam es nicht vor.
Die Laser an die Fensterscheibe.
genau, ein Laser an die Fensterscheibe. Das heißt, man benutzt die Vibration der Fensterscheibe. Also, wenn man in einem raum spricht, vibriert die Fensterscheibe ein bisschen im Schalltakt damit. Dann kann man am Laser gegen die Fensterscheibe bounceen und die Reflektion von dem Laser auffangen und daraus halt ein Schallsignal rekonstruieren. Dann gibt es halt Methoden, die so ähnlich funktionieren, wo man eine kleine bewegliche Membran vorne an einer Glasfaser dran hat. Dann baut man halt ein sehr, sehr dünnes Loch oder vielleicht so eine Tapetenritze oder so, wo diese Glasfaser lang gelegt wird und macht am Ende dieser Glasfaser, die auch relativ lang sein kann, also mehrere Dutzend Meter, tut man dann erst die Elektronik hin, sodass sie außerhalb des Bereichs ist, den das Opfer zum Beispiel durchsucht. Und dann hast du halt nur so eine ganz dünne, feine Glasfaser, die da irgendwo lang geht über die...
Und das ist Glasfaser und kein Metall, das heißt, Metalldefektor findest du auch nicht.
Findest halt nichts.
überhaupt die Achilles-Phase von solchen Wanzen ist normalerweise die Stromversorgung. Deswegen wird die üblicherweise in der Nähe von bestehender Stromversorgung angebracht, so in der Steckdose oder im Telefon oder so.
Ja, oder halt eben...
Wo man halt fünf Volt angreifen kann.
Oder halt eben so. Ja, außerhalb dann halt. Dann gibt es halt natürlich noch so Varianten, wo man halt Heizungsrohre zum Beispiel, wenn man also normale Heizungen in einem raum hat, dann braucht man sich da über Abhörsicherheit keine Gedanken machen, weil...
Da koppelt der Schall einfach durch in der Leiterwunde.
Da koppelt man den Schall einfach in irgendwie ein paar Mal weiter ab, überhaupt kein Problem. Ja, also so gibt es halt verschiedenste Methoden. So der Prototyp von diesen...
Die coolste Wanze war doch diese russische Wanze.
genau, diesen Aufwand, den sie nie treiben wurden, war halt diese Tereminwanze. Und zwar, was der, also der russische Physiker Teremin, nachdem auch dieses Instrument benannt ist, was halt so Schwingungen macht. Wenn man halt die Hand in der Nähe der Antenne bringt, dann fängt das Ding halt an, seine Schwingungen zu ändern und andere Geräusche zu machen. Das ist natürlich auch so ein cooles Projekt, Open Teremin, könnte ich mal angucken. Jedenfalls basierend auf dessen Forschung wurde halt eine Wanze gebaut. Also manche sagen von ihm selber, weil er gezwungen wurde vom KGB. Und diese Wanze bestand eigentlich im Wesentlichen aus einem kleinen Metallzylinder mit einem Bran und einem Draht. Und was diese Konstruktion gemacht hat, ist, wenn man da mit HF-Energie, also Radio, drauf strahlte, hat sich die zurückgekoppelte und zurückgestrahlte Energie im Takt der Sprache verändert, die in dem raum gesprochen wurde, also des Audios. Das heißt, man hatte dann quasi eine Wanze, die halt keine elektrischen Teile hatte, also keine Transistoren oder irgendwas, die keine Stromversorgung hatte. Das einzige war halt, dass sich die Leute in dem raum ein bisschen unwohl fühlten, weil die Russen natürlich mit enormer HF-Energie reingeballert haben, damit das Ding halt irgendwie ordentlich schwankt.
Der einzige echte Fall von Unwohlsein durch Elektrosmog.
Und dann haben sie halt dann irgendwann gefangen, nachdem sie noch andere Indizien hatten, da mal ein bisschen zu suchen und haben dann gefunden, dass diese Wanze in einer Plakette, also so eine große Holzadlerplakette, die der amerikanische Botschafter in moskau von einer Jugendveranstaltung geschenkt bekommen hatte.
Der ist heute auch ausgestellt.
Das ist ein Museum, genau. Das ist halt auch so ein typisches Beispiel, dafür was für einen Aufwand die treiben. Nach diesem Verfahren gibt es halt auch heute noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man gar nicht in den raum reinkommt, indem man ein Gespräch abhören will, dann kann man auch mit Radar in diesen raum reinschießen und die Vibrationsänderung des Kehlkopfes der Leute, die da drin sprechen, zur Schall rekonstruieren. Das heißt also, du brauchst halt keine Wanze mehr da drin, sondern dein Kehlkopf ist halt irgendwie den, ursprünglich wurde das halt angeblich entwickelt, um Verschüttete zu finden, anhand ihres Dopplers vorm Herzschlag. Bis dann irgendjemand mal feststellt, dass man nur mal hier noch ein bisschen und da noch ein bisschen, und dann könnte man halt danach und dann kriegt man halt die Sprache daraus. Ja, also das ist halt so der Aufwand, der da reingesteckt wird, um einander abzuhören. Also was man halt nie vergessen darf, der typische, einfachste und simpelste Abherweg ist eine Vermittlungsstelle.
genau, die meisten Leute werden nicht für einen Wanzen abgehört werden, sondern weil man es einfach bei der Telekom abgreift oder sonst wo.
genau, deswegen sind Hintertüren in solchen Vermittlungsknoten, also auch zum Beispiel in Internetknoten oder in Telefonvermittlungsstellen oder in Wortknoten, sind der wichtigste und die ergiebigste Abhörquelle, was wir jetzt auch aus den Snowden Dokumenten gelernt haben, dass die NSA dann riesige und die British Q, also die Briten halt auch einen großen Aufwand daran treiben, in diese Knoten reinzukommen. Interessant war jetzt diese Geschichte über Belgacom. Vielleicht sollten wir da noch mal kurz darauf eingehen, weil ich glaube, einige Leute haben nicht ganz verstanden, was das bedeutet. Was da passiert ist bei Belgacom, ist, dass die Briten mit ziemlich gezielten Angriffen den Network Engineers von Belgacom hinterher gestiegen sind, denen Mailware auf ihre Rechner getan haben, um Zugang zu den Belgacom, also bzx Vermittlungssystemen zu bekommen, also den Switches. Und was es halt heißt, ist, dass Network Engineers sind Primärziele.
genau, Prioritätsziele.
Alle Leute, die tatsächlich der System Administrator für Netzwerksysteme sind, müssen echt darüber nachdenken, wie ihre operational security aussieht. Und zum Beispiel auch darüber nachdenken, ob die Rechner, die sie in ihre Switches hängen, um sie zu administrieren, ob die dieselben sein sollten, mit denen sie auf Facebook benutzen oder ihren Porn klicken, da sollte man mittlerweile mal ernsthaft darüber nachdenken. Also weil die Systeme werden mit Mailware angegriffen, und zwar die Laptops von den Leuten, um an die Rechner und an die Switches zu kommen und die Router, die von ihnen administriert werden.
Wobei das auch mal wieder so ein told you so Moment war, denn das war genau was wir angesagt haben, als sie damals ihre lauf- und intersektive Schnittstellen per EU-Regulierung definiert haben. Da haben wir gesagt, wenn ihr Schnittstellen schafft, dann werden die auch von anderen Leuten gebraucht werden.
Ja gut, da gab es ja diesen Griechenland-Fall.
Ja, aber so gesehen, das ist ja auch genau das, was hier gerade passiert.
Nein, was da passiert ist, was anderes, was die da gemacht haben, ist, die haben versucht, die Rechner anzugreifen. Also nicht mal LI. Schnittstellen zu benutzen, weil die viel zu schmal waren, nicht für das, was wir wollten, sondern sich halt treffengöcklich zu besorgen haben.
Aber es ging auch um gezielte einzelne Verbindungen abhören, denn Belgacom ist der staatliche, ich glaube Ex-Monopolist, aber Telekom sind sie, glaube ich, noch Monopolist. Internet nicht mehr, aber Telefon sind sie, glaube ich, noch Monopolist im Festnetz. Und die sind unter anderem die Telekommunikationsgesellschaft, die das Europäische Parlament und die diversen EU-Behörden verbindet. Das heißt, darum ging es. Es ging natürlich gar nicht irgendwie so um die einzelnen Leute, obwohl man das natürlich mitnimmt.
Aber die einzelnen Leute waren der Weg dahin. Also, die Network-Engines.
Nein, aber es ging auch nicht um das Abhören von irgendwie einzelnen Belgiern, sondern es ging um die EU. Aber wenn man schon mal da ist, nimmt man die anderen natürlich mit. Ja, so, wir haben hier so eine kleine Timeline aufgebaut. Die gehen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen durch. Wir haben ja schon gesagt, 1943 ging es los mit diesem Abkommen. Das Problem bei diesen ganzen Geschichten ist, dass man da frühestens 15, 20 Jahre später was von hört. Ja, das dauert immer ewig und drei Tage, bis das irgendwie dann nochmal die Öffentlichkeit berührt. So und die erste Sache, wo man sich mal ein bisschen informieren konnte, wie Codebreaking überhaupt funktioniert war, 1967 ein Buch von David Kahn, The Codebreakers. Das ist immer noch ein Standardwerk, was auf weiter aktualisiert wird. Spannenderweise war das so früh, dass es diverse Sachen noch gar nicht drin hatte. Deswegen gab es neue Auflagen. Also das ist noch vor DESS zum Beispiel, was ja nun einer der großen Wiegepunkte ist, vor der Erfindung von Public Key, Kryptographie. Also das Buch ist vergleichsweise alt, aber es gibt neue Auflagen davon.
Also er hat das einfach kontinuierlich weitergeschrieben. Und man muss sich darüber im Klaren...
Aber historisch das erste Werk, absolut ein wichtiges Standardwerk in der Beziehung.
Interessant daran ist, dass 1967 war halt vielen Leuten immer noch nicht klar gewesen, bis dahin, dass die Enigma eigentlich gebrochen wurde. Also man muss sich überlegen, der Bundesgrenzschutz in Westdeutschland hat bis 1961 Enigmas eingesetzt.
Weil sie es einfach nicht wussten.
Weil ihnen das offenbar niemand gesagt hat. Und erst danach haben die halt andere Systeme eingeführt. Die Russen haben das wahrscheinlich zu dem Zeitpunkt als Fingerübung für ihre neuen Kryptoanalysen zum Knacken gehabt oder so.
Also das Detail, ich meine, das liegt auch immer vom Land ab natürlich. Aber so in England gibt es halt den Official Secrets Act, der sowas betrifft.
Ja, was irgendwie der fieseste Geheimhaltungsgesetz der Welt ist.
Ich lese da gerade ein Buch drüber, das ist ein Kracher. Ich werde hier mal die Buchdaten in die Liste tun, das kann ich nur jedem empfehlen. Das ist so ein Lacher, als wäre dieser Act von den ganzen Politikern gemacht worden, weil sie Angst davor hatten, dass ihnen die Journalisten ihre Sachen veröffentlichen. Und was dann tatsächlich passiert ist, dass die ganzen Politiker selbst das in ihren Memoiren veröffentlicht haben. Aber so dutzendweise. Und einer der Übelsten war ein Ex-Premierminister, da hat sich einfach schlicht keiner getraut, das Gesetz auf den anzuwenden, weil der einfach so eine wichtige Figur war. Und lustigerweise hat der dann, eigentlich war das wohl relativ unsympathisch, aber so den einen, den er geschont hat, war Churchill. Weil der war gerade politisch am Ende, das war, bevor er selbst Premier wurde, der war gerade politisch am Ende, hatte keinen Cent mehr und eigentlich war da wohl so ein paar Absätze drin, die Churchill vollständig verdichtet hätten. Aber ihm ist halt gut zugeredet worden, komm lass mal hier, das ist aber nicht Gentlemanly und dann haben sie Churchill rausgenommen und das hat die zukünftige Karriere von Churchill ermöglicht. Das ist alles eine unglaubliche Geschichte, kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, das Buch.
Wie heißt es?
Classified, glaube ich, von Moran. Hervorragendes Buch. Aber jedenfalls diese ganze Geschichte von Geheimdiensten ist in allen Ländern ein ausgesprochener Lacher, deswegen ist das ja auch geheim alles. Ich hatte das glaube ich neulich schon mal im Blog erklärt, wie es zum MI5 kam. Das war ein hysterischer französischer Autor, der in England lebte und der sich die fixe Idee ausgemalt hat, dass das Kaiserreich England komplett mit Spionen durchsetzt habe und eine Invasion plane. Und er hat da eine Reihe von Romanen geschrieben und hat die dann mit der Daily Mail zusammen veröffentlicht und hat eine riesige Hysterie losgetreten, die am Ende dazu geführt hat, dass sie halt einen Geheimdienst eingeführt haben. Na gut, wir müssen mal was machen, weil irgendwie die Leute sind alle nervös. Mit unglaublichen Details, wie das sie dann die Daily Mail darauf bestanden hat, die von ihnen gewählte Route, über die die Deutschen einmarschieren, zu ändern, damit möglichst viele Gegenden betroffen sind, in denen viele Daily Mail-Leser drin waren. Also es ist alles so grotesk. Das kann man sich gar nicht ausdenken. Unter anderem schreibt er halt, dass der MI5 mit seiner gesamten Geschichte nicht einen ausländischen Agenten enttarnt hat, sondern es alles so Zufallsfunde waren. Oder weil die Polizei halt...
Oder Walk-Ins oder sowas.
genau, Walk-Ins, Verräter. Aber ihre eigentliche Aufgabe haben die nie erfüllt und das wird bei uns eh nicht aussehen. Es gibt auch Enthüllungsbücher über die CIA. Über die NSA noch nicht, da warten wir alle noch drauf. Aber es gibt relativ vernichtende Bücher über die CIA. Die Geheimnisse sind alle so. Wenn wir was erfahren, ist es immer viel später. Ein Beispiel dafür war Tempest. Tempest ist heute relativ bekannt, Popkultur auch. Das sind elektromagnetische Emissionen von Geräten. Und es stellt sich nämlich raus, wenn man oben im zweiten Stock an seinem Desktop irgendwas eingibt. Das zum Monitor gehende Signal über das VGA-Kabel damals noch, das lässt sich abgreifen. Und zwar indem man einen Fernseher umbaut, lustigerweise. Das heißt, es war so relativ plakativ, man konnte es leicht sehen. Das gilt auch für alle möglichen anderen Dinge. Man kann auch Tastaturemissionen abfangen und so. Und weil die Erdung häufigerweise sich geteilt wird von solchen Geräten, kann man es teilweise an der Heizung abgreifen, die dann im Keller irgendwie rausgeht und außen an einem Rohr rauskommt und so. Also die Möglichkeiten waren relativ erschütternd und das ist rausgekommen, weil die Briten die französische Botschaft so abgehört haben, wenn ich recht in Sinne.
Na da ging es um ein anderes System. Also da ging es tatsächlich um ein verschlüsseltes Fernschreibersystem, wo sich rausstellte, dass auf der Leitung nach draußen, auf der eigentlich nur das verschlusselte Fernschreiben sein sollte, waren die... Als kleines Echo tauchte der Klartext mit drauf. genau. Das ist sehr lachend. Was sie dann halt rekonstruiert haben und dann...
Aber das gilt eben für alle anderen Geräte auch. Das ist auch heute noch ein echtes Problem. Und einer der größten Lacher war, dass die Leute, als sie das gesehen haben mit dem CRT und dass man das auf dem Fernseher abfangen kann, sind die in Panik auf Flachbildschirme umgestiegen, wo das Problem noch viel schlimmer ist.
Anders, aber schlimmer. Die Reichweite ist halt größer.
Das ist ein generelles Problem und das ist gar nicht so einfach, das zu machen. Da muss man natürlich Galvanisch trennen und eine ordentliche Erdung haben.
Ja, ist schwierig.
Kupfer den raum, verkupfern und blablabla. Also das ist nicht so einfach. Es gibt da Spezialtablete für Paranoide. Also das ist ein echtes Problem. Und wenn jemand wirklich eure Daten haben will und euch beim Tippen zusehen will, dann kann man mal davon ausgehen, dass er das tun kann.
Interessant ist, was relativ wenig beleuchtet ist, wo wir hoffentlich vielleicht auch noch was hören werden. In Enthüllungen ist es unter Aktive Tempest. Da gibt es auch noch so unterschiedlichste Codenames dafür. Man kann nämlich mit Software auf dem Computer oder auf dem elektronischen Gerät dafür sorgen, dass diese Abstrahlung maximiert werden.
Oder minimieren, da gab es mal ein lustiges Käufer von Markus Kuhn. Der hat irgendwie seine Fonds Lowpass gefiltert oder so. Nein, Highpass, wie war das? Ich hab dir Details vergessen, aber der hat irgendwie spezielle Fonds genommen, die dann keinen Abbild mehr gegeben haben.
Zumindest auf den einfachen Tipps. Auf den, ja. Aber man kann eben auch dafür sorgen, dass zum Beispiel bestimmte Daten auf Offline-Systemen rausmodelliert werden. Also wenn man halt ein AirGap hat, also man sagt, okay, man hängt seinen Computer mit den kritischen Daten nicht ans Internet. Kann man sich da trotzdem eine Mailware darauf einfangen, die die Daten nach draußen funkt. Und zwar über Hardware in dem Computer, in dem sie halt bestimmte Hardware rhythmisch benutzt, die halt dafür sorgt, dass halt eine Modulation zustande kommt. Und die Modulation kann halt so komplex sein, dass man die auch umscannert. Ich sieh da, hört man nur rauschen. Wieder mal so ein typischer Fall von den Aufwand, würden sie doch nie treiben, ja doch, den haben sie getrieben.
Naja, man kann sich das so vorstellen, dass man den Platten Schreiblesekopf speziell bewegt oder sowas. Dann hört man es ja sogar.
Ja, oder den Rambus.
Ja, natürlich funktioniert es in der Praxis subtiler, aber man kann sich das schon relativ deutlich vorstellen, wie sowas funktionieren könnte.
Bis hin zu irgendwie auf Kurzwelle Senden mit dem Monitor-Grab.
Das hat, glaube ich, auch mal jemand per Soundkarte gemacht. Oder hat die Soundkarte benutzt, um die DVB-Signal zu erzeugen. Also es gehen da die abgefahrensten Sachen mit relativ billiger Hardware. Halt nicht gut genug, um damit so professionelle Standards zu genügen, aber das muss man ja auch nicht für Geheimdienst haben.
Na gab es halt damals ja noch diese 90er, diese Promise-Skandal. Kannst du das noch erinnern?
Ja, so grob. Das war irgendwie Polizei-Software.
Das ging uns halt eben um so eine Polizei-Intelligence-Software, die offenbar mit so einer aktiven Tempest-Geschichte versorgt wurde.
Die wurde doch geklaut, wie war das nicht? Wurde die nicht von irgendwie Geheimdiensten geklaut, die nie bezahlt haben und so?
genau, so Zeug. Und dann haben sie die halt geleakt an die Russen, glaube ich. Und da ging es eben unter anderem darum, dass die durch rhythmische Benutzung von Speicher oder ähnlichen Dingen ja Daten nach draußen gesendet hat, die dann eben über relativ große Entfernungen empfangen werden konnten.
Insgesamt kann man sagen, als Privatperson kann man das von keinem knicken, sich dazu schützen. Aber man sollte zumindest mal gehört haben, was so geht.
Nein, man sollte wissen, dass wenn jemand den Aufwand treibt, dann wird er wahrscheinlich Erfolg haben. Die Frage ist halt nur, ob er den Aufwand treibt.
Und ob man das so teuer wie möglich machen kann.
Ja, genau. Man kann den Aufwand halt schon drastisch erhöhen. Was sie dann tun, wenn sie halt keinen Weg finden, dann gibt es halt so eine Black-Back-Jobs. Das heißt also, da wird dann einfach eingebrochen. Früher hat man halt Codebücher geklaut, meistens aus Botschaften.
Oder Kurierunternehmen.
Kopien angelegt. Wenn halt die putzfrau nicht an den Tresor kam, dann musste halt eingebrochen werden. Die putzfrau hat nur die Tür offen stehen lassen und die Alarmanlage sabotiert. Heute wird das halt gerne gemacht, um Mailware zu installieren, also um Trojaner zu installieren auf dem Rechner oder Keylogger, um Platten zu mürren oder sonstige Backdoors da einzubinden.
Ja, oder was auch gerne gemacht wird, ist, dass sie im Rechenzentrum dann eben nicht den ganzen Rechner mitnehmen, sondern nur eine der Platten aus dem Raid-Verbund. Ja, und dann läuft halt der Rechner weiter. genau, bei mir ist gerade so was passiert und dann hab ich dann auch gedacht, hmmm, gucken wir doch mal nach. Das Problem ist, dass man das halt nicht wirklich sagen kann, wenn man nicht physisch vor Ort ist.
Das ist halt das Dobe mit gemieteter Hardware.
Also was ich halt sehen konnte, ist, dass die Platte noch da war, aber sich weigerte sauber aus Gazi zu sprechen. Insofern sah es nicht aus, als wenn sie jemand rausgenommen hat. Aber es kann natürlich sein, dass jemand die Platte rausgenommen hat, irgendwie es geschafft hat, dass der Bus weiterläuft und mir da irgendwie Kram untergeschoben hat. Man weiß es nicht.
Hast du wenigstens kritische Sachen auf der Maschine?
Nein. Da ist halt irgendwie Kopie von meinem CVS drauf und so. Also nichts Wichtiges, was ich nicht noch woanders hätte. Nichts Wichtiges. Nichts, wo ich nicht gucken kann, ob jemand gefummelt hat.
Verstehe, okay. Du meinst, wenn demnächst ein komischer Post in deinem Blog auftaucht, wissen wir warum?
Ja, das wäre natürlich echt kritisch, aber da gibt es auch ein Backup von... Aber ja, das ist ein echtes Problem. Wenn man anfängt, paranoid zu werden, dann muss man auch an sowas denken. Zurück zu unserem Thema.
Wir sind mir andern heute ein bisschen, aber ich glaube, wir kommen mit.
Aber wir haben solange keine Sendung mehr gemacht, da machen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen länger. 1968 gab es den ersten Com-In-Satelliten der NSA. Also das war ein Satellit, der das Ziel hatte, Kommunikation der Russen abzufangen. Es gab auch andere Satelliten, die in der Beziehung wichtig waren, nämlich eigentlich, was man so als Keyhole kennt, das sind so Kamerasatelliten, die einfach Fotos machen. Da kommen wir auch noch zu. Da gibt es nämlich auch eine lustige Anekdote mit dem Hubble. Aber ComInt, das waren Schnüffelsatelliten, die einfach die Signale der Russen auffangen sollten. Und da an der Geschichte ist ganz witzig, dass immer wenn es rauskam, was ein paar Mal passiert ist, haben sie halt schnell den Namen von dem Programm geändert. Ursprünglich hieß das Canyon. Und es ging halt über Sibirien, weil es da geologisch, geographisch unmöglich war, im Grunde das per Kabel zu machen. Da haben sie halt neben diesen länglichen Strecken gehabt und haben selber Satelliten benutzt auch. Und das hat sich halt besonders geeignet, uns abzufangen. Und weil die Russen dachten, es würde ja keiner machen, den Aufwand treiben, einen eigenen Satelliten hochzuschießen, was ja eine Milliarde an Investitionen einfach so mal ist.
Erinnert man vor den 68, da war Satellitentechnik eine richtig Rocketschein.
genau. Deswegen haben die Russen sich da auch nicht viel Sorgen gemacht, ob sie das jetzt verschlüsseln müssen, oder ob sie da die Botschaften eingrenzen, sondern die haben einfach viel mehr über die Leitung verschickt, als da wirklich hätte verschickt werden müssen. Und dementsprechend war das eine Goldgrube für die Amis. In dem Programm gab es dann insgesamt sieben Satelliten bis 1977, also von 68 bis 77 Satelliten, das heißt ungefähr jedes Jahr ein.
Für ungefähr eine Milliarde oder mehr?
Ja, also die haben ein unglaubliches Geld da investiert. Dann ist das irgendwie rausgekommen, also es gab erstmal Version 2.0 dann, die Satelliten werden ja auch verbessert. Und so ein Satellit läuft auch nicht für ewig, sondern da ist dann so eine nukleare Stromquelle drauf, die Technik wird besser, sowas expirert irgendwann. Außerdem sind die Orbits meistens nicht so stabil, sondern die nach einer Weile haben keinen Treibstoff mehr, um die Orbe zu korrigieren und fallen dann halt runter und haben also eine natürliche Lebenszeitbegrenzung. Es gab da eine Version 2.0 namens Chalet, das ist in der Presse aufgetaucht, dann haben sie es unbenannt nach Vortex. Vortex ist auch tatsächlich mir mal irgendwann über den Weg gelaufen als Begriff für sowas. Vortex tauchte auch mal in der Presse auf, dann haben sie es nach Mercuro unbenannt, aber so läuft das halt. Das ist halt wie so ein Stein, den man hochhebt und die ganzen Kakerlaken unter den Hübschen schlitzen. Also 1968 haben sie die ersten Schnüffelsatelliten gemacht, das ist schon echt unglaublich. Die ersten, von denen wir wissen heute.
bildaufklärungs-satelliten haben sich schon früher hochgeschossen, das Corona-Programm war schon davor.
Ja, aber das ist auch erstaunlich schwierig, da belastbare Daten zu finden.
Für Corona ist ja komplett deklassifert. Aber die Comments haben nicht deklassifert geworden. Die Bildsatelliten, das Bildmaterial von den Corona-Satelliten, ist komplett deklassifert. Kann man sich auch ordern.
Das ist auch richtig erstaunlich, was die damals schon für eine Auflösung hatten. Da kannst du richtig die Flugzeugtypen auseinanderhalten.
Wenn die Ami-Regierung dann mal wieder funktioniert, dann kann man sich da auch tatsächlich Daten ordern aus diesem. Das ist lustig. Die schicken einem entweder Digitalisator oder schicken einem tatsächlich unbelichtete Filmstreifen. Da kannst du tatsächlich so einen Filmstreifen schicken lassen. Und dann hast du so ein Webinterface, wo du die Mission auswählen kannst.
Nein, das ist ja geil.
Von wo und wann. Und dann siehst du halt, die müssen unglaublich frustriert gewesen sein, weil zwischendurch haben die dann halt, was weiß ich, irgendwie sind so zu 61 haben sie dann halt versucht, irgendwie DDR zu fotografieren. Und dann haben die ja offenbar wochenlang nur Wolken fotografiert.
Scheißwetter.
Die haben halt nur programmiert, so zu sagen, wenn so vertrieben wird. Das vom Earth Research Observation and Science Center. Und ich hab mir da mal so ein paar Filme.
Ist das irgendeiner Uni-Angeglieder? Das klingt sowieso.
Klingt was nicht genau. Insofern hab ich dann mal irgendwann die...
Du hast dir mal was geordnet?
Da hab ich mal was geordnet. Und guck dir mich denn damals die Sekretärin so ein bisschen komisch an. Du, hier ist was aus dem Eros Center für dich.
Super!
genau.
Oh, ich kann dir klären.
Das war sehr hübsch. Nee, das kann man tatsächlich immer machen, das ist durchaus interessant. Ich glaub, mittlerweile liefern sie reiere Scans aus, aber damals halt eben nur Filme. Und wenn man halt gerade mal ein bisschen gucken will, wie damals irgendwie die Sachen aussahen, die Auflösung ist halt teilweise so auf zwei Meter runter, also schon echt erheblich so und am Ende sogar 70 Zentimeter oder so.
Also man kann definitiv einzelne Autos sehen und teilweise die Typen erkennen.
Man sieht echt viel, man sieht schon viel Zeug.
Aber so Bildzeitungen lesen aus dem Orbit geht halt nicht.
Nee, geht damit nicht, nee. Das ist halt aber eines der wenigen Programme, die halt so komplett die Klassivheit wurden damals, wo halt eben doch man, ja, ruhig zu Teil ranhaut tatsächlich was von hat, wenn man halt zum Beispiel Veränderungen von Landschaft sehen kann und so. So, zurück zur Krypto.
Ja, 1970 ging das los mit Public Key Krypto. Völlig geheim, das ist von Forschern beim GCH QF und worden, das ist das britische NSA-Äquivalent, die mit dem Temporasystem. 1970, 1973 gab es da Memos intern, das ist aber nie wirklich irgendwo hingegangen. Das Problem war, damals gab es nur symmetrisches Cipher, das heißt, man hat den Schlüssel vorher austauschen müssen. Und wenn ein Dritter den Schlüssel hatte, dann konnte der sowohl alles mitlesen, als auch selber verschlüsselte Botschaften schicken. Und das ist ja eigentlich nicht, was man haben will. Also kennt man auch heute von PGP und SSL. Das will man eigentlich anders haben. Man will das so haben, dass man sagen kann, das ist der Server, ich weiß, dass ich mit dem richtigen Server rede, dass es keine schlüsselaustauschgeschichten gibt, sondern dass man nur noch eine CA hat, wie man das heute nennt. Also diese Idee, dass man andere Sachen signieren kann digital, das ist alles Public Key-Kryptographie. Und das ist erst erfunden worden 1970, 1973, aber noch nicht ein fertiges System, sondern das waren einfach nur Memos. Ja, man könnte mal das hier angucken und vieles.
Also die Mathematik dazu.
genau.
Vielleicht sollst du nochmal Public Key-Krypto kurz erklären für die.
Okay, Public Key-Krypto ist die Idee, dass man einen zweigeteilten Schlüssel hat, einen öffentlichen Teil und einen privaten Teil. Und der Public Key-Krypto, der wird weltweit veröffentlicht. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas mit meinem privaten Key bearbeite, dann kann jeder mit dem öffentlichen Key sehen, dass das nur von diesem privaten Key hätte kommen können. Das heißt, ich kann eine Sache signieren. Oder umgekehrt kann jemand mit dem öffentlichen Schlüssel eine Nachricht bearbeiten und die kann dann nur der Inhaber des privaten Schlüssels bearbeiten. Aber da der ja nie...
Entschlüsseln.
Entschlüsseln. Und da der aber nie den einen Benutzer verlässt, den muss ich halt nicht weitergeben. Das ist der private Schlüssel. Dadurch ergibt sich so eine Sache, dass man Sachen signieren oder an einen persönlich verschlüsseln kann. Und dass es nicht so ist, wie vorher, dass man, wenn man eine Gruppenkommunikation haben will, dass man dann in der Gruppe den Schlüssel verteilt und nicht weiß, wer das jetzt konkret lesen kann.
Also in der Praxis funktioniert es so, dass eigentlich alle Public-Verfahren sind halt nicht dafür geeignet, große Mengen Texte zu verschwinden, sondern deswegen kombiniert man die halt dann meistens mit noch einem symmetrischen Verfahren.
Es sind auch viel langsamer als symmetrische Verfahren.
genau, das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt an Fefe was verschlüssel mit seinem öffentlichen Schlüssel, dann wird de facto ein symmetrischer Schlüssel erzeugt und dieser wird mit dem öffentlichen Schlüssel verschlüsselt und an die Nachricht angehängt.
Und mit dem kann ich dann die Nachricht entschlüsseln. Aber den kann halt nur ich entschlüsseln, weil nur ich den privaten Schlüssel habe. Ja und tolle Sache, will man unbedingt haben, aber die Mathematik dahinter existierte vorher nicht. Da kann es auf die Idee gekommen sein, dass man das so machen kann. Das ist auch heute noch sehr schwierig. Es gibt da nun eine Handvoll von Verfahren, die da überhaupt vorgeschlagen wurden.
Na vorgeschlagen wurden viele, aber es gibt nur eine Handvoll, wo man sich so ansatzweise sicher ist, dass sie zumindest eine Weile halten werden.
Na es gibt es gibt so zwei oder drei, von denen man sagt, okay, also bis die Quantencomputer kommen. Dann gibt es noch so ein paar esoterische, von denen man hofft, dass sie auch danach gehen. Das Problem ist halt, erstens ist das höhere Mathematik, das heißt, schon die Operationen sind deutlich teurer als bei den symmetrischen Verfahren in Sachen CPU-Zeit. Und das Problem ist eben auch, dass die Mathematik voranschreitet und die Rechner schneller werden. Das heißt, man muss immer die Schlüssellängen hochdrehen, weil es in der Zwischenzeit neue Erkenntnisse gibt, wie man so ein Verfahren brechen kann und so. Also nur weil das Verfahren alt ist, heißt das nicht, dass wir das immer noch genauso anwenden wie damals, sondern die Schlüssellänge hat sich irgendwie verzehnfacht seit dann. Krypto war damals eigentlich noch ausschließlich ein Geheimdienstspiel. So Privatleute haben nicht verschlüsselt, konnten es auch gar nicht. Es gab damals auch die ersten spezialklauseln in so Patentgesetzgebung.
Ja, die sind schon älter. Die sind tatsächlich aus den Zeiten von mechanischen Kryptomaschinen.
Ach, tatsächlich?
Die sind echt alt.
Okay. Aber sind die angewendet worden oder wie?
Doch, doch. Also die klauseln für militärisch verwendbare Erfindungen, und dazu zählt halt Krypto und hat halt Krypto schon immer gezählt, die sind halt schon richtig alt. Aber die haben halt eben dafür gesorgt, dass halt eben auch in den 70ern Krypto im zivilen Umfeld also quasi nicht vorkam. Also war halt tatsächlich was, was die Staaten gemacht haben.
Na, bis auf so Hinterhalt für Krypto, an der Krypto AG und so, ne? Wann war das? 18er Jahr?
Ja, aber auch die haben am Wesentlichen von Regierungen gelebt.
Ja, natürlich. Aber die haben im Moment auf Messen aufgestellt, ne?
Ja, aber ich sag mal, so Verschlüsselung für Privatleute oder für Unternehmen oder so, war eigentlich in den 70ern nicht so richtig in Wog. Also es gab halt so ein paar Kryptosysteme, die waren halt alle sehr so ein bisschen fischig und also hat halt niemand es so richtig verwendet. Also gab halt keine massenweise Anwendung von Verschlüsselung in dem Sinne.
So eins der Probleme mit diesen ganzen Verfahren ist, dass man bei keinem eigentlich wirklich weiß, das ist sicher, also sicher in dem Sinne, wie das ist auch in Zukunft sicher. Wenn ich das jetzt mache und in 10.000 Jahren findet ein Alien das und der hat meinen Schlüssel nicht, dann kann er das nicht entschlüsseln. Diese Art von Sicherheit, die gibt es eigentlich nicht. Da gibt es nur ein Verfahren, wo das der Fall ist, nämlich der One-Time-Pad. Und der funktioniert so, dass man einen Schlüssel hat, der genauso groß ist, wie die Nachricht, die man überträgt. Und den hat man vorher ausgetauscht und benutzt ihn nur genau ein einziges Mal. Also das ist die Idee, dass man vorher so eine Art Codebuch hat. Aber man benutzt es halt nicht zum Lookup von einzelnen Wörtern oder so, sondern man macht einen XOR, das ist eine mathematische Operation, eine Bit-Operation und verschlüsselt seine Botschaft, indem man den Zufall darauf addiert, kann man sich das vorstellen.
genau, also und zwar für jedes einzelne Bit des Klartextes gibt es einen Bit des Schlüssels.
Und wenn man jetzt den Schlüssel nicht kennt, dann kann jeder Schlüssel zu einem völlig anderen Klartext kommen. Das heißt, es gibt überhaupt keine Methode zu erkennen, ob das jetzt sauber entschlüsselt wurde oder nicht, weil zu jedem, zu jeder Entschlüsselung gibt es einen möglichen Schlüssel, der das erzeugt hätte.
genau. Und diese Art von Krypto...
Von der ist schon relativ lange klar, dass sie sicher wäre, deswegen haben Regierungen sie auch angewendet, aber nicht immer richtig angewendet.
Vielleicht noch einen kurzen Exkurs dazu. Also wie man das verwendet hat, war zum Beispiel für Agentenfunk, also wenn man halt irgendwie Agenten im feindlichen Ausland hatte, dann hat man denen so kleine Code-Büchlein mitgegeben, von denen dann immer eine Seite abgerissen wurde und auf denen stand dann halt so in Fünfergruppen Zufall. Und der Zufall war halt als Buchstaben und Zahlen codiert, oder nur als Zahlen. Und dann hat er seine Nachricht aufgeschrieben, in möglichst wenigen Buchstaben, weil verschlüsseln wir dann anstrengend. Und hat dann sich hingesetzt und hat halt einfach für jeden Buchstaben oder jede Zahl, die er da aufgeschrieben hat, dann jeweils den Schlüssel drauf addiert und hat danach das Code-Buch verbrannt oder aufgegessen oder ein Wasser aufgelöst, also meistens vernichtet. Und diese Code-Bücher waren halt häufiger eben auf so super Wasser, also quasi Löschpapier gedruckt, sodass sie halt, also wenn man Wasser drauf macht, dann zerflosset halt alles.
Als Feature.
War halt ein Feature, oder man konnte sie aufessen oder irgendwie sonst wie einfach vernichten. Oder sie waren halt mit einer Hand hinter geschrieben. Also da gab es alle möglichen Tricks und Kniffe. Und das Problem ist halt, man kann...
Das muss halt wirklich zufällig sein.
Das ist das erste Problem. Das muss halt richtig zufällig sein. Die Geheimdienste haben da tatsächlich damals eine Menge manuellen Aufwand getrieben. Also die Briten haben zum Beispiel, um halt irgendwie ihre One-Time-Pads zu generieren für ihren Agentenfunk, also für die paar Systeme, wo sie Agentenfunk gemacht haben, haben sie wirklich Horden von frauen vor Tombola-Maschinen sitzen gehabt. Aus denen halt dann einfach die Würfel fielen. Also die haben die halt gedreht und dann fielen halt diese Kugeln da raus. Also du kennst das wie aus dem...
Ja, ja, war der Lotto-Fiel.
Wie so Lotto. So und tippen die dann im Durchschlagpapier, sodass es halt zwei Exemplare davon gab.
Das ist ja auch ein cooler Job.
Und dann fielen die Kugeln halt hinten wieder in die Maschine. Also die haben den ganzen Tag vor einer Tombola-Maschine gesessen und getippt, was da in Zahlen rausfiel.
Resozialisierung für Spielsüchtige.
Oder halt eben gewürfelt oder sich sonst wie irgendwas ausgedacht. Oder später haben als dann halt physikalische Zufallsgeneratoren halt irgendwie bekannt worden, haben sie dann zum Beispiel Zählerohren genommen für nuklearanzer Fall oder thermisches rauschen umgesetzt und dann die halt generiert. Es gibt ein zweites Problem daran, also außer, dass beide Seiten müssen halt den Schlüssel haben. Sonst geht es halt nicht. Man muss physikalisch den Schlüssel irgendwie zu beiden Seiten bringen. Und das zweite Problem ist, man darf es halt auf jeden Fall nur einmal verwenden. Also wenn man halt so einen One-Time-Path ein zweites Mal verwendet, kann man mit relativ einfachen mathematischen Tricks ja den Schlüssel und beide Nachrichten sozusagen rauskriegen. Und das ist den Sowets passiert. Und zwar, als die nach den Stahlinschen Säuberungen hatten sie ein paar Krypto-Experten zu viel erschossen oder ins Lager geschmissen.
Ach, das sieht zufällig genug aus.
Und dann haben die, weil sie halt gerade große Agentennetze in den USA versorgen mussten, haben die halt One-Time-Paths mehrfach verwendet. Und die Amis haben zu diesem Zeitpunkt aber schon alles was an Krypto war aufgehoben. Die haben tatsächlich dann noch Nachrichten aus den 30ern gehabt, mit denen sie halt dann in den 50ern Sachen entschlüsseln konnten. Also das Programm bei den Amis ist damals Winona und war halt ein riesiger Aufwand. Man muss sich vorstellen, die haben halt die ganzen Kurzwellen-Agentenfunk-Nachrichten halt aufgezeichnet und erstmal beiseite gelegt. Und dann irgendwann kam mit auf die Idee her, lass mal probieren, ob sie ihre Mantanpads nochmal verwendet haben.
Ein Schuss ins Dunkel.
genau. Und dann haben die Amis richtig große Mengen sowjetischer Agenten aufgerollt.
Das ist ja auch Teil der Snowden-Enthüllung gewesen, dass sie immer noch Spezialriegel haben. Verschlüsselte Daten werden aufgehoben.
genau.
Länger als andere Daten. Die werden weggeschmissen, wenn man sie eine Weile nicht braucht.
Und der Hintergrund ist halt einfach, dass wenn man heute den Kryptosystem nicht brechen kann, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass man es nicht später brechen kann. genau. Insbesondere wenn das sogar One-Time-Pad-Krypto, also von denen sie wussten, dass es ein One-Time-Pad ist, aufgehoben wurden. In der wagen Hoffnung, irgendjemand könnte mal den Fehler machen, das nochmal zu verwertigen.
Sie können das verkackt haben.
Sie können es verkackt haben. genau.
Na gut, wir kommen in den 70er Jahren dann. Die Telcos waren alles irgendwelche Long-Distance-Monopole. Das waren staatliche Telcos. Oder es war sowas wie AT&T. Und das hat für Staaten den großen Vorteil gehabt, dass es nicht so viele Partner gab, mit denen man reden musste, wenn man mithören wollte. Also man konnte da halt hingehen und sagen, du bist das Monopol, dafür musst du aber auch mit uns zusammenarbeiten. Und dann haben die es halt gemacht. Es ging aber in den 70er Jahren los mit der Deregulierung. Das hat das so ein bisschen schwieriger gemacht. Aber es hat auch Vorteile gehabt für die Amis insbesondere, weil dadurch eben die Preise runtergegangen sind und in gut Teil des globalen Telefonverkehrs tatsächlich durch die USA gingen.
Also dieses strategische Vorteil der Deregulierung.
Ähnlich wie beim Internet.
Ja.
Das ist ja dasselbe Problem mit den Grünen.
Naja, ich meine, das ist halt genau dasselbe Spiel. Dass halt diese strategische Vorteile, dass ihre Telekommunikationskonzerne in der Lage waren, sie billig anzubieten durch den hohen Konkurrenzdruck und auch durch staatliche Förderung im Übrigen. Also es ist halt nicht alles nur Markt, sondern die haben da auch aktiv reingebuttert. Unter anderem auch dadurch, dass sie halt diesen Telekommunikationskonzern in NSA Aufträge gegeben haben, weil die NSA natürlich einen riesigen Bedarf an Telekommunikationsleitung hat, um ihre Stützpunkte weltweit zu vernetzen, wurden diese Telekommunikationskonzerne halt subventioniert und das führte halt dazu, dass eben auch Ferngespräche innerhalb von Europa billiger waren, wenn sie über die USA geführt wurden. Und zwar in vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeiten. Also ihr erinnert euch dunkel, als man noch diese Vorwahlen gemacht hat, um halt billiger Fernse telefonieren. Das war halt häufiger dann halt irgendwelche komischen Gesellschaften, die die Anrufe halt über die USA geleitet haben, weil es billiger war.
Klingt scheiße, hat ewig Latenz drauf gehabt. Aber es war halt billiger.
genau, weil man halt darüber, selbst wenn man nach Frankreich telefoniert hat, im Zweifel über New York billiger telefoniert hat. Mit dem Effekt, dass die Anrufe alle in den USA vorbeikam und die NSA sie mitgenommen hat.
Schlurf. Ja, in den 70er Jahren ging es dann noch langsam los mit den richtigen Verschlüsselungsverfahren. Und seit 71 Jahren IBM ein Verfahren namens Lucifer patentiert. daraus ist später DESS geworden. Lucifer hatte eine Schlüssellänge bis zu 128 Bits. DESS ist dann aber kastriert worden bei der Standardisierung auf 56 Bits. Und das ist ein Muster, was wir häufiger sehen in der Geschichte. Dass Krypto-Verfahren eigentlich mal so halbwegs sicher aussahen, aber dann runtergeschnitten werden von NIST oder von irgendwelchen anderen Behörden bei der Standardisierung. NIST ist da der hauptakteur, aber das kommt von vorn auch andersherum. 1971 gab es auch den ersten dokumentierten Fall von so einem Induktionsabhörgerät an einem Unterseekabel. Und zwar war das ein sowjetisches Militärkabel in der See von Ohotsk. Das war relativ lustig, die Geschichte, weil sie ja zwar ahnten, dass da ein Kabel ist, aber sie wussten nicht, wo es ist. Und sie haben es dann gefunden, indem sie am Ufer Schilder gesucht haben, wofür die lokalen Fischer dransteht, hier nicht ankern. Und so haben sie das Kabel dann gefunden. Ja, sehr witzig. Und als sie das Kabel gefunden hatten, das war so eine völlige Hail Mary-Geschichte, sie wussten überhaupt nicht, ob das funktionieren würde oder nicht, haben sie so als Demonstrator da ein bisschen eine Spule rumgewickelt mit tauchern und haben tatsächlich Signal abfangen können. Und das haben sie dann zu hause erzählt. Und daraus ist dann ein offizielles Programm gemacht worden namens Ivy Bells. Und da gab es mehrere ungebaute U-Boote über die Zeit. Das damals hieß USS Hallibut. Das war relativ legendär. Und weil sie nicht wussten, ob das funktionieren würde oder nicht, wollten sie da jetzt auch nicht groß ein Commitment eingehen. Und deswegen hat es eigentlich eine andere Mission gehabt, nämlich sollte das da Fragmente von irgendwelchen Raketentests einsammeln. Und da sind sie ja sehr mit tauchern losgezogen und haben so Fragmente so im Zentimeterbereich und noch kleiner. Also das Größte war irgendwie drei Zentimeter oder so. Haben sie gesammelt von diesen Torpedos und haben damit zu hause den Torpedom noch gebaut. Das ist schon völlig unglaublich, was sie da für Aufwand getrieben haben. Nicht nur für Sigint, sondern auch für andere Militärsachen. Grundsätzlich kann man davon ausgehen, nur weil es viel Aufwand ist, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass es nicht getan wird. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, dieses Gerät, was sie um dieses Kabel gewickelt haben. Also es gab da ein richtiges Gerät, das war irgendwie sechs Meter lang und hatte Tape drin. Da haben sie einfach das Signal immer raufgeschrieben und einmal im Monat kam die dann mit ihrem U-Boot vorbei, haben sich da reingeschlichen in die sowjetischen Hoheitsgewässer und haben die Tapes gewechselt. Das ist schon echt unglaublich. Und die Akkus.
Also da gibt es ein Buch drüber, heißt The Blind Man's Bluff, wo das mal einer beschrieben hat von 1998, glaube ich.
Das habe ich hier auch irgendwo gelistet.
Ja, das sieht man mal wieder so, das war 71.
1971 und das hat 20 Jahre oder was genau, nein 30 Jahre fast. Die Russen haben das Jahre später mitgekriegt, weil ein amerikanischer Überläufer ihnen das verkauft hat, der halt Kohle brauchte. Und er hat das irgendwie für 30.000 Dollar verkauft. Das war zwar mehr Geld, als es heute wäre, so mit Inflation und so, aber also lächerlich wenig im Vergleich zu den Kosten. Na klar. Der KGB hatte dann ein paar Jahre später auch einen Überläufer, der es den Amis wieder erzählt hat. Und als die Amis dann hinfuhren, um den Akku zu wechseln, war das Gerät weg. Und das ist jetzt angeblich im KGB-Museum. Also da müsste man echt mal hin, nicht ins Test angucken. Das klingt sehr lustig. 1972 gab es den ersten Whistleblower in der NSA. Der hat ausgepackt in einem... Ich hab die Zeitung jetzt gar nicht aufgeschrieben. Kann ich hier mal draufklicken.
Klick, klick.
Also in einem irgendeinem Magazin, von dem ich noch nie gehört hab. Da hat der das halt ausgepackt. Und es war so völlig sensationalistisch. Ja, wir hören alles und jeden ab. Und wir können das und wir können jenes. Und der hat halt keine Dokumente vorgezeigt und konnte sich auch nicht ausweisen. Natürlich, weil er halt ein anonymer Whistleblower war. Der da also nicht anonym, sondern Pseudonym. Alles sehr. Also im Grunde rückblinken hat er natürlich die Wahrheit gesagt. Der ist da noch aufgedeckt worden.
Ach, echt, da haben sie ihn gekriegt.
Die haben ihn gekriegt und der sitzt wohl. Ich weiß nicht, ob er noch sitzt. Aber also das war tatsächlich ein echter Whistleblower. Aber der hat halt so die technischen Details hat er nicht gebracht, natürlich, sondern er hat im Wesentlichen gesagt, wir können und hören jeden ab. Und naja, wie das so ist, da denkt man sich erst, naja, ach, das wird irgendein Typ sein, der sich wichtig machen will, bla bla. Hat mich völlig schockiert, dass ich das jetzt gesehen hab. Ich dachte, das ist erst später gewesen, dass da ein Whistleblower gab. Also ich hatte von dem noch nichts gehört vor den Recherchen hier. Aber das waren so die formativen Jahre, nicht nur für Verschlüsselung, sondern auch für überhaupt den wissenschaftlichen Umgang damit, was jetzt eigentlich Geheimhaltung ist. Da gab es auch das Bell-LaPadula-Modell, das ist auch aus der Zeit 1979. Das ist relativ wichtig. Da geht es darum, dass man Informationen labelt. Je nachdem, ob sie von einer hohen Geheimhaltungsstufe kommt oder von einer kleinen und dass man eben dafür sorgt, dass die nur in eine Richtung fließen können. Aber das war das erste Modell, was sich überhaupt formalisiert damit beschäftigt hat, wie man mit Informationen mit verschiedenen Clearance-Levels umgeht. Das war alles so Handwaving vorher.
Na, man hat also eine Erfahrungswissen, würde ich mal sagen.
Sag ich doch.
Also wo sie halt versucht haben, ihre praktischen Erfahrungen in Systeme zu gießen. Bell-LaPadula war halt das erste System, was quasi eine mathematische Grundlage darunter gezogen hat für was Einstufung als Geheimen und der Umgang damit angeht. Also dieses System war dann halt auch entscheidend dafür, wie die Klassifizierungssysteme innerhalb dieser Geheimdienste ausgelegt sind.
Und wie Protokolle ausgelegt sind. Also es gab ja auch die ursprüngliche Version von IP, also dem Internetprotokoll hat auch so ein Feld, um zu sagen, das ist jetzt privilegiert. Das kam auch aus dieser Idee, dass man sagt, okay, das ist classified. 1975 gab es die Church-Kommission, die hat sich in den USA mit geheimdienstmissbrauch beschäftigt. Ursprünglich kam das, glaube ich, von Watergate. Also es ging gar nicht so um die Dienste, aber es gab eben auch zum ersten Mal so einen richtigen NSA-Skandal, als eben rauskam, dass da abgehört wurde, dass es die NSA gibt. Die war vorher überhaupt nicht public und auch die Church-Kommission hat, glaube ich, nicht öffentlich über die NSA geredet, sondern es gab halt Dokumente. Jetzt ist lustigerweise gerade rausgekommen vor ein paar Tagen, dass die NSA auch Frank Church abgehört hat.
Also den Vorsitzenden der Kommission.
Den Vorsitzenden von dieser Geheimdienst... Reformkommission. Da ist natürlich nie wirklich groß was draus geworden, aber so diese Freedom of Information Act-Geschichten kommen, glaube ich, aus dem großen und groben Umfeld davon. 1976 gab es dann Diffie-Hellman. Das ist der erste Public Key-Algorithmus, der tatsächlich öffentlich vorgestellt wurde in einem Forschungspaper. New Directions in Cryptography heißt das Paper. Da geht es um diskrete Logarithmen als mathematisches Problem zur Auseinandersetzung von einem Schlüsselpaar. Das war bahnbrechend und hat die Cryptografie verändert. Lustigerweise, die Ansage, dass es bei GCHQ vorher schon Public Key gab, ist auch relativ neu.
Die ist neu, ne?
Die gibt es nicht.
Fünf Jahre her oder sowas.
Ja, fünf bis zehn Jahre. Also es ist noch nicht lange her, dass die überhaupt öffentlich zusagen können. Ja, da muss man sich mal vorstellen, du arbeitest irgendwie als Mathematiker bei so einem Dienst und machst so eine bahnbrechende Sache, die danach die Welt revolutioniert, weil sie jemand anders wie zehn Jahre später publiziert, oder etwa fünf Jahre. Und dann kannst du da nicht mal irgendwie Credit zu bekommen. Das ist echt, das muss wirklich scheiße sein, im Dienst zu arbeiten.
Wie wenig über die Geheimdienste damals bekannt war, also insbesondere was irgendwie die Abhörgeheimdienste anging, zu einer Zeit, wo die CIA wegen ihrer Aktivitäten in Lateinamerika in aller Munde war und auch irgendwie allehand gerade von Seiten der Sowjets und des OZBlox darüber publiziert wurde, sieht man daran, dass 1976 Duncan Campbell zum ersten Mal im New Statesman in einem Artikel namens The Eve's Droppers die Abkürzung GCHQ, also Government Communications Headquarter, in der Presse erwähnt.
Mit einem amerikanischen mitautor, lustigerweise.
genau, mit einem amerikanischen mitautor.
Und der wurde sofort ausgewiesen. Und Duncan Campbell selbst war seitdem unter MI5-Überwachung. Also das heißt, da haben die Dienste noch nie Humor gehabt, wenn man ihre Existenz aufdenkt.
genau, also allein die Existenz, also die NSA hieß ja eben über viele Jahre, war ja die humorvolle Abkürzung für... No Such Agency, also die Agency gibt es halt nicht. Und da sieht man halt auch daran, wie tabuisiert eigentlich im öffentlichen Bewusstsein dieses massenweise Abhören war. Also selbst die Tatsache, dass es da eine Agency gibt, die sowas tut, durfte halt nicht diskutiert werden.
Und die Budgets sind natürlich auch nicht öffentlich. Also das heißt, das Parlament, was ja eigentlich dafür zuständig ist, so was zu machen, nicht mal die wissen das.
Ja, und die Begründung damals war natürlich, okay, kalter Krieg, die Sowjets dürfen es nicht wissen. So die Sowjets wussten natürlich alles darüber, aber natürlich nicht die Öffentlichkeit im Westen. Und einer der Gründe dafür war eben unter anderem auch, dass diese Abhörgeheimnisse natürlich nicht nur gegen die Sowjetinnen eingesetzt wurden und die anderen Ausblockstaaten, sondern eben auch gegen politische Gruppen im Inneren. Na also, Kempe hat 78 aufgedeckt, dass Hongkong quasi von den Briten wie so eine fiese Diktatur betrieben wurde, inklusive Überwachung und Unterwanderung der Oppositionsgruppen, wofür die halt auch ihre Abhörgeheimnisse eingesetzt haben. Das dauerte noch fünf Jahre oder so, bis diese Behörde, also diese Oppositionsüberwachungsbehörde, dann irgendwie eingestampft wurde. Haben sie die eingestampft oder haben sie nur umbenannt?
Nee, die haben sie richtig aufgelöst. Ich meine, Hongkong gehört ja auch nicht mehr den Briten jetzt. Da haben sie das angeblich richtig aufgelöst, aber das weiß man ja nie. Wir haben ja vorhin schon bei den Satelliten gesehen, dass sie dann einfach das Programm umbenennen. Ja, nee, Vortex gibt es hier nicht mehr, wir haben nur noch Mercury.
Andere Satellitenprogramme gab es halt auch zuhauf. 76 haben sie.
Allein die Liste der Nachrichtendienste, die in den USA existieren, ist irgendwie 18 oder so. Völlig unglaublich, wie viel. Und in Deutschland ist das ja auch...
Na gut, aber da sind die ganzen Landesämter auch noch dabei. Die Satelliten, wo wir gerade dabei waren, so eines der bekanntesten Programme von den Amis ist halt Keyhole, was halt auch lange Jahre nicht bekannt war, weil es es überhaupt nicht gab so. Und im Gegensatz zu den Corona-Satelliten, die es vorher gab, hatten die zwei Unterschiede. Zum einen war die Auflösung nochmal höher und zum anderen hatten die elektro-optischen Kameras. Das heißt also, da wurden nicht mehr Filme zurückgeschickt. Also bei den Corona-Programmen haben die mit Kameras im weltraum fotografiert auf Film und diesen Film dann in Kapseln in einen Wiedereintrittskopper verpackt und nach unten geschickt und dann am Fallschirms eingesammelt. Und tatsächlich während des Fluges des Fallschirms eingesammelt, weil man wollte nicht riskieren, dass sie irgendwo runterkommen. Und die Kiro-Satelliten, KH11 war so einer der bekanntesten, die haben halt per Funk die Sachen runtergeschickt. Und auch da brauchten sie natürlich Krypto, weil die wollten natürlich nicht, dass die Russen ihnen dabei zugucken, wo sie gerade hingucken.
Wobei, das wussten sie natürlich, weil sie sehen können, wo die Satelliten waren. Da gab es ja schon ein Programm, oder nicht?
Ja, aber natürlich willst du ja gerne wissen, wo sie hingucken.
Du weißt, wo der Satellit ist, das reicht ja auch nicht.
Nee, das reicht natürlich nicht, weil du hast natürlich einen riesigen, breiten, breiten, schreifenden Landprozess.
Siehst nicht, wo sie hinzoomen.
genau, weil die haben ja oben ein spiegeloptisches System drinnen, wo sie halt auf schon einen relativ großen Winkel gucken können. Und wohin sie genau gucken, hat die Russen natürlich schon interessiert, aber deswegen hat die NSA da auch eigene Verschlüsselungsschips eingebaut. Also überhaupt war halt irgendwie, Krypto für diese Satelliten zu bauen, war durchaus auch eine wesentliche Aufgabe. Weil das ist halt auch so ein Punkt, den wir vielleicht mal erklären sollten. Keymaking oder Code making, also Verschlüsselung bauen und Code breaking, sind ja zwei sehr verwandte Dinge. Also wie ihr vorhin schon sagt, ist halt normalerweise, wenn man ja eigentlich ein Team haben, was es kaputt macht und ein Team, was es baut, uns erst releasen, wenn das Team, was es kaputt macht, irgendwie keine bezahlbare Idee mehr hat, wie man es halt irgendwie bricht. Und bei NSA ist es halt auch so, dass die zuständig sind für die Verschlüsselung der Amerikaner. In Deutschland ist das halt ein bisschen anders geregelt. Seit einigen Jahren ist es halt so, dass die Verschlüsselung für die Regierung wird halt von BSI, Bundesamt für Sichende Informationstechnik, gemanagt und das Code breaking ist halt so ein bisschen verschwobelt zwischen BND und wie heißt es, Zentralamt für Verwaltung oder so was und noch so ein paar Stellen halt irgendwie. Also in Köln gibt es halt so eine, ich vergess es nicht, Verwaltungszentralamt oder so was. Da haben sie halt dann irgendwie das Code breaking angesiedelt und halt bei BND.
Ich finde das ja durchaus, hat so einen Charme, dieses Bürokratie-Decknamenspiel, was die deutschen Dienstländer spielen. Wie war das so, Vermögensstelle Ost, NIO, das Bundesvermögensamt? Forstverwaltung. Das ist alles großartig. Aber in den 70er Jahren, also wir haben Diffie-Hellman gehabt, 76, 77 gab es dann RSA, das wird auch heute noch verwendet. Und 1977 ist auch DESS publiziert worden. Die Standardisierung war erst 1979 von DESS. DESS war der Vorgänger von AIS.
Aber interessant darin ist, dass irgendwie die beiden...
Das ist noch nicht so lange her, ist mein Punkt. So lange ist das noch nicht her.
Wiederum andererseits, die wesentlichen Public-E-Verfahren sind so alt wie wir. Also die sind halt schon echt ganz schön alt.
Naja, tipptopp, an der Perspektive.
Also die sind halt schon echt eine Weile unterwegs. Und seitdem sind halt nicht so viele neue dazugekommen.
Aber vergleich das noch mit der Mathematik, wo alle Verfahren irgendwie hunderte, tausende von Jahren alt sind. Also das ist schon noch mal ein Unterschied. Ja, also bei der Standardisierung von Destas, das hab ich vorhin schon kurz vorhergegriffen, haben sie die Schlüssellänge reduziert. Und das ist eine Sache, die man immer wieder sieht in den NSA. Das ist auch wieder passiert bei AIS. Da haben sie jetzt nicht das stärkste Verfahren genommen, sondern haben halt gesagt, aus Performancegründen, nehmen wir eins der schnelleren, was sich besser in Hardware implementieren lässt. Und ich meine, das ist eine Sache, die eigentlich immer nur nach hinten losgeht, weil die Zeit arbeitet halt gegen dich. Du willst ja ein Verfahren haben.
genau, Krypto-Verfahren werden mit der Zeit nie besser, sondern immer nur schlechter.
Deswegen willst du genug Sicherheitsmarge in deinem Verfahren drin haben, dass selbst wenn du in zehn Jahren noch was verschlüsselst, dass es noch zehn Jahre lang hält. Das heißt, du musst 20 Jahre Marge drin haben. Und so wie sich die Hardware entwickelt, ist das eher ein exponentielles Problem. Das heißt, man muss auch exponentiell Marge drin haben. Naja.
Aber interessant an dieser Geschichte mit der Journalisierung von DESS. Also DESS war halt der Versuch, einen öffentlichen Krypto-Standard zu schaffen. Also sozusagen...
Wir sehen ein, das kann nicht nur Geheimdienstgrad sein, sondern auch für die Banken braucht man das jetzt.
Es gibt halt den Bedarf nach kommerzieller Krypto. So Ende der 70er. Und wenn halt das funktionieren soll, dann muss man einen Standard schaffen, an dem sich alle halten. Und die müssen zwar jetzt nicht unbedingt kompatibel sein, dass also dieses gesamte Verfahren mit einem Protokoll nicht so kompatibel ist. Aber dass es zumindest einen vorgeschriebenen, funktionsfähigen Minimalstandard gibt für die Verschlussungsgüte. Und in den USA gibt es halt das NIST, das Nationale Institut für Standards and Technology, die genau für sowas zuständig sind. Also die sind alles mögliche, aber unter anderem auch Krypto-Verfahren.
Man kann grob sagen, sowas wie der DIN bei uns.
Ja, funktioniert halt anders, aber so grob. Ungefähr so nur, dass sie halt alles mögliche standardisieren, nicht nur halt irgendwie technisch.
Ja, die DIN ja auch.
Ja gut, aber es gibt keine DIN-Krypto, glaube ich, oder gibt es DIN-Krypto? Interessante Frage. Na gut, also jedenfalls dieser Prozess, wie halt aus Lucifer DESS wurde, ist halt spannend, weil zum einen hat die NSA...
Also NIST hat keine eigenen Kryptografen, sondern verlässt sich auf die NSA. Und die NSA hat ja dann eigentlich auch die Rolle, Krypto zu brechen. Deswegen ist das immer schon so ein bisschen anrühig gewesen. Und besonders anrühig war es, weil die NSA so ein paar untransparente Änderungen an Lucifer durchgeführt hat, um daraus DESS werden zu lassen. Und von denen hat sich zumindest partiell später rausgestellt, dass die nützlich waren, obwohl es zu dem Zeitpunkt noch keiner wusste. Weil die DESS gegen ein Verfahren gehärtet haben, was öffentlich noch nicht erfunden waren, nämlich die differenzielle Kryptoanalyse.
genau.
Das heißt, die NSA ist nicht immer böse. Das macht es auch so ein bisschen schwierig, um die Sachen zu bewerten, wenn die irgendwas tun. So ist das jetzt der zweite Fall, wo sie mir was richtig machen oder drehen sie uns gerade die Hintertür an?
Das ist natürlich auch eines der Probleme in dieser ganzen NSA-Diskussion. Also gerade bei der Stabilisierung, dass halt dieses Primat, das sie abhören können, was sich jetzt bei den bekannt gewordenen Hintertüren jetzt, was du zum Beispiel bei diesem EZB-Krypto oder RNG da zeigte, da haben wir eigentlich immer gedacht, die werden das schon nicht so schwach machen, dass die Russen das brechen können.
Gerade bei diesem Krypto, der hat die ganze Zeit schon schlecht gerochen. Also das ist ja nun so, dass du ein Zufallzeilengenerator bist und der war nicht mal ein guter Zufallzeilengenerator. Du guckst dir in den Hals und der Zufall sieht nicht, sondern nicht so völlig aus. Du denkst so, wat? So schlecht können die doch nicht sein. Das ist doch die NSA, die wissen doch, wie man sowas macht.
genau, eigentlich versteckt man die wissen, wie man sowas macht.
Ja, und dann denkt man sich so, vielleicht gibt es einen guten Grund. Das ist doch nicht so eine Plumpe hinter der Tür, wenn die das nicht machen. Also so gingen die Gedanken gingen. Aber auf dem raus, doch, das war genau eine Plumpe hinter der Tür.
Wir sind eben auch angesichts der Geschichte mit DESS, also wo sich hinterher herausgestellt hat, dass sie halt zwar die Anzahl der Bits reduziert haben, was irgendwie dazu führte, dass sie es dann tatsächlich auch mal brechen konnte mit Boat Wars, aber auf der anderen Seite es wiederum härter gemacht haben gegen eine Form von Grundanalyse, die zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht öffentlich bekannt war. Das ist halt diese Janusköpfigkeit, die ist halt immer dabei. Die es halt auch echt schwer macht, dem NIST irgendwie irgendeinen Art von vertrauen entgegenzubringen als Journalisierungsbehörde für Crypto.
Zumal die das auch immer wieder machen. Also bei AS haben sie dann den schlechteren Verfahren, naja schlechter, würde ich jetzt vielleicht nicht on the record sagen, aber so eins, was weniger Marge drin hatte als andere Verfahren und weniger konservativ designt war als andere Verfahren. Und jetzt gibt es gerade eine aktuelle NIST-Sache, das ist H3 und da sieht es wieder so aus, dass sie ein Verfahren gewählt haben, wo es sogar ein Sicherheitsbeweis gab, der eine bestimmte Härte bewiesen hat und dann fummeln sie danach Doktoren danach an den Verfahren rum, mit der Begründung, das sei dann aber besser für die Performance und damit gilt aber dieser Beweis nicht mehr. Und da kann man auch nur sagen, was soll denn das Leute? Es ist ja schon eh schwer genug euch zu trauen. Was macht ihr denn auch mit der Scheiße, dass das doch mal... Naja, aber so ist das halt mit NIST.
Aber interessant daran finde ich eben immer noch diesen Punkt, dass wir gedacht haben, die werden es nicht so schwach machen, dass die Russen das knacken können.
Aber das hat sie nicht zurückgehalten. Das muss man rückblickend sagen. Doch, das tun sie. Sie machen es so schwach, dass die Russen das mitlesen können. Offensichtlich ist es wichtiger für die NSA, dass sie alles mitlesen können, als zu verhindern, dass die anderen alles mitlesen können.
genau.
Das wird halt dankend in kauf genommen.
Das ist tatsächlich eine grundlegende Fehlentschätzung gewesen, muss man sagen, auf unserer Seite, dass wir halt davon ausgegangen sind. Wenn sie es schon schwächen, dann werden sie es halt nicht so weit schwächen, dass es halt wirklich kaputt ist, sondern nur so, dass es für sie vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher in der Zukunft ist oder so was.
Wobei, es gab ja schon diesen einen Fall bei Lotus Notes, wo relativ klar war, dass die da keine Schmerzen mit haben.
Das Workload Reduction Field.
Da kommen wir auch noch drauf. Ja, haben wir noch später. Langsam hat die Überwachungsdebatte auch Deutschland erreicht. Da gab es 1980 einen schönen Zeitartikel über den strauß. Kann ich nur empfehlen, werden wir verlinken. Das ist absolut großartig, der Artikel, weil da geht es eben darum, dass sie dann das Telefon von dem strauß in dem haus, wo er gewohnt hat. Aber was wohl irgendwie ein mehrfamilienmiethaus war, und sie den Postfuzzi befragt und jemand sagt, ja das geht doch nicht, das ist doch verboten, da kann man doch nicht dran rumfummeln. Und dann meint sie so, wir haben extra so ein rotes Klebeband benutzt, das machen wir nur bei VIPs so. Das heißt, dass man da ist rechtlich rangehen darf. Und da denke ich mir so, aah, die Schmerzen. Also das ist echt ein Zeitdokument, dieser Artikel, sehr großartig.
Oh ja, der ist großartig.
Ja, 1980 ging dann auch die Forschung richtig los, wie man größere skalierende Systeme bauen kann. Da gab es am MIT das Project Athena, das hatte noch ganz andere Ziele, aber es hatte eben auch dieses Ziel und da ist Kerberos erfunden worden. Das ist auch heute noch im Einsatz als Teil von Windows und ich glaube OS X supportet das auch. Das ist nicht Public Key basierend gewesen damals, obwohl Public Key gerade erfunden war. Das ist so ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal gegenüber anderen, da war vorhanden die Richtung. Ist aber wie gesagt heute noch im Einsatz. Kerberos 5 ist aktuell. 1982 gab es dann wieder ein Enthüllungsbuch, das war sogar noch das Enthüllungsbuch. Das Enthüllungsbuch, diesmal nicht über Codebreaking im antiken Zusammenhang, sondern da hat James Bamford das Buch The Puzzle Palace geschrieben. Und das war ein echter Dammbruch, weil der hat sozusagen alles enthüllt, was er über die NSA finden konnte. Und der hat sich da keine Kosten und Mühen gescheut. Also eine Anekdote dazu ist, dass er auf den NSA Parkplatz gefahren ist und hat die Nummernschilder von Diplomaten, nummernschildautos gefilmt und hat ein Freedom of Information Act Anfragen gestellt, um herauszufinden, ob man weiß, aus welchem Land die kommen. Und hat so rekonstruiert, mit welchen Ländern es da Kooperationen gibt. Und da hat also die NSA kalt erwischt, die nicht gerechnet hat, dass irgendjemand so einen Aufwand treibt. Und das ist aber strikt legal gewesen. Der ist also nicht durch irgendwelche Mülleimer geklettert oder so grauzonen-sachen, sondern der ist komplett auf dem Fundament der Rechtsstaatlichkeit geblieben und so konnten sie auch nicht wirklich irgendwas gegen ihn tun. Aber der hat aufgedeckt, es gibt die NSA, das ist zum ersten Mal richtig irgendwie Popkultur geworden. Damals hat sich ein Millionenfach verkauftes Buch, hat lustigerweise im Nachlass von irgendeinem Militär-Fuzzi, der in irgendeiner Militärbibliothek einsehbar war, eine Kopie von einem NSA-Newsletter gefunden, wo drinsteint, das geht an alle NSA-Mitarbeiter und ihre Familien und hat dann vor Gericht argumentiert, weil es auch an die Familien geht, kann man nicht sagen, dass es classified gewesen sei, sondern es sei ja auch General Republic und damit dürfte er auch die anderen sehen. Also so ging der vor, das war so ein richtiger Wadenbeißer. Er hat sich da auch echt unbeliebt gemacht bei der NSA und die NSA hat daraufhin diese Drummente versucht zurückzuziehen und teilweise ist es für ihn wohl auch gelungen. Also es war ein epischer Kampf zwischen der NSA und diesen Bremford und der hat noch ein paar Mehrbücher geschrieben, aber das war so das wichtige Buch.
Die Bremford-Bücher sind eigentlich alle zumindest durchsehenswert. Also Puzzle Palace ist halt teilweise ein bisschen trocken, weil er halt wirklich auch so diese Details von der Organisationsstruktur und welchen Medizineinheit jetzt dazu was gehört und so. Also die Strukturen der NSA intern sind halt irgendwie so byzentin, wie sie halt bei so einer Multidutzend-Milliarden-Dollar-Behörde halt irgendwie natürlich sind.
Na nicht nur das, sondern also das war überhaupt jetzt schönste Detail, dass das Buch innerhalb der NSA gern gelesen wurde, weil die selber aus Clearance-Gründen gar nicht Einblick hat, was da noch so für Abteilungen gibt und wer da jetzt wuchan arbeitet. Also ein großartiges Buch in der Beziehung, aber jetzt vielleicht für den Privatkonsum nur so partiell genießbar, aber ist halt sehr schön als Zeitdokument, um zu sehen, was da so passiert ist.
Definitiv. 1983 gab es den ersten Artikel der New York Times darüber, über die NSA.
genau, das dauert ja immer so ein bisschen, bis so was hochblubbert. Also das kam 1983 in der New York Times an und war damals halt Public Record. Das ist irgendwie, wenn es in der New York Times steht, das ist wie wenn es bei uns im Spiegel steht.
Aber interessanterweise ist diese Aura der NSA, hat so diese Gehandesvolle, gibt es eigentlich nicht so. Die gingen nie so richtig weg. Es gab halt irgendwie so einzelne, wenige Publikationen, aber es war jetzt nicht so wie heutzutage, dass in jeder Zeitung was über die NSA steht.
Das ist echt Snowden hat das angeregt.
Das war halt eigentlich, gab es halt nicht so.
Damals war das auch eher noch so Turf war zwischen den Zeitungen, dass die halt gesagt haben, das fassen wir jetzt nicht an, das ist ein Scoop von den anderen, das werden wir nur aufwendigst anfassen.
Oder unter anderem auch so, dass die diverse Zeitung gesagt haben, darüber schreiben wir nicht, weil das geht ja gegen die Staatsversorgung und so.
Naja, New York Times ist aber da auch an sich nicht so.
Nee, aber das ist dann halt nicht in der Washington Post und so halt irgendwie mehr verreichlich.
Und die Washington Post, okay. Mir kommt zurück zu Duncan Campbell.
genau, 88.
Das ist eigentlich ein Schotte. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was der studiert hat, aber eigentlich was völlig unrelated, irgendwie nicht, ich glaube Physik oder so. Aber der hat sich halt damals zu so einem richtigen Wadenbeißer gemacht, das hat er in der linksradikalen Presse Linkliberal. Beim New Statesman hat er also einen peinlichen Artikel nach dem Nächsten geschrieben. Und 1988 war also der große Schlag, da hat er nämlich aufgedeckt, dass es Echelon gibt. Echelon ist das weltweite Abhörsystem der NSA.
Der Five Eyes.
Und der anderen Five Eyes-Radikale.
Und Echelon ist halt insofern wichtig, das ist das erste System gewesen, was eine richtig integrierte, flächendeckende Abhörinfrastruktur für Telefon, Telefax...
Und zwar global. Also nicht nur Europa und vielleicht... Sondern die haben richtig alles abgedeckt. Da waren auch Neuseeland und Australien dabei. Und die haben dafür gesorgt, dass auch China und Japan und so und Korea betroffen waren. Also die haben sich wirklich Mühe gegeben, ihre Listening Posts so zu verteilen, dass wirklich die gesamte Welt, die für sie interessant war, abgedeckt wurde, soweit sie herankamen. Also Teilen in Russland war vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig geografisch, aber dafür haben sie die Satelliten gehabt. Und Echelon war halt so ein richtig allumfassendes Ding. Also die haben Kabel angezapft, die haben Satelliten mitgehört, die haben Bodenstationen gebaut, da war kein Kostenpunkt zu teuer. Die haben eigene Satelliten gebaut, die hinter anderen Satelliten standen, um deren Signale auch noch abzufangen. Also unglaubliche für damalige Verhältnisse völlig unfassbare Technologie haben die da im Einsatz gehabt. Peinlicherweise gab es dann aber in Neuseeland so einen Fall, wo jemand einfach auf so eine NSA Listening Station reingelaufen ist. Weil die haben...
Im Fernsehteam.
genau. Also erst alleine und gesagt, das sieht aber alles komisch aus hier. Und dann ist es ihnen irgendwie klar geworden, nach diesem Duncan-Campbell-Ding, dass das eine Erinnerungsstation ist. Und dann sind die da mit dem Fernsehteam reingelaufen. Und das ist ja auch heute, könnte man sich das gar nicht vorstellen, wenn es so eine Militärinstallation gibt, würde man denken, die haben da irgendwie Kameras, Selbstschussanlagen, Fettest Security, irgendwie Wächter mit Hunden und so. Aber damals, nö, da konntest du einfach in der Wüste von Neuseeland, da bist du einfach hingegangen, so reingelaufen. Also so, das fand ich immer einen sehr lustigen Kontrast eigentlich zwischen der unglaublichen, wie Geld spielt keine Rolle, Mentalität, aber dann kein Geld haben, um da einen Wert dahin zu stellen.
Das interessante an Echelon war, dass die Struktur so ähnlich ist, wie das, was wir heute von Prism und ähnlichen Systemen kennen. Nämlich, dass die auf den damals ja meistens Sprachkommunikationskanälen Suchmaschinen laufen hatten. Das heißt, die haben nach Worten gesucht.
Das war tatsächlich eine Neuerung in Echelon und auch nicht von Anfang an dabei, sondern es war Version 2 von ihrem Kram.
Und dass sie Telefax-Buchstabenerkennungen drin hatten, also dass man halt da drin suchen konnte, also dass man Suchworte in die Installation der Partnerdienste einspeisen konnte.
Peinlicherweise hing eine von denen ausgedruckt rum, als dieses Fernsehteam kam. Das war so der größte peinliche Moment daran. So eine Liste mit Worten, an denen sie interessiert sind. Da so, ups, so da wussten dann alle Beteiligten, hm, das kann man jetzt eigentlich nicht im Fernsehen bringen, so und das gab auch wie großen Wind damals. Also Echelon war also damals technologisch ein Hammer. Das war also teilweise überhaupt nicht vorstellbar gewesen vorher in der Zivilgesellschaft, dass solche Technologie überhaupt existieren könnte. Und vor allen Dingen, dass man die in diesem Scale, nicht nur, dass es sie überhaupt gibt, sondern dass sie das ausgerollt haben und zwar weltweit. Damals gab es noch so, nee, das machen wir lieber nicht am Telefon, facks das mal. Ja, was ja aus heutiger Sicht natürlich total eine Lachnummer ist. Aber so, das war halt der Mindset, in dem die Welt war damals bei Echelon. Dass Telefone abgehört werden können, war irgendwie so ein bisschen, hat ein, zwei Leute gehört, aber facks galt noch als sicher. Und das hat Echelon eben aufgeräumt. So, das wird alles abgeschnorchelt und endlos gespeichert und es gab da High-End-Computer und man konnte suchen und man kriegt Echtzeit-Alerts, wenn irgendwelche Sachen auftauen. Also das war alles Rocket Science Technologie, was auch bei uns im CCC zu großen Diskussionen geführt hat, ob wir das überhaupt glauben können, dass das funktioniert. Ich weiß noch, dass wir uns da, ne, ach, das glaube ich nicht, das behaupten die bestimmt nur. Also wir haben da auch eine Weile gebracht, bis wir das geglaubt haben.
Und 98 kam es dann noch im Spiegel an, mit einer Titel-Story über die NSA.
Das hat richtig eingeschlagen, diese Echelon-Geschichte. Also nicht nur im CCC, sondern auch in Amerika gibt es ja so eine libertäre Bewegung in Kalifornien hauptsächlich. So Nachfolgergeneration der Hippies, die irgendwie Freiheit ist wichtiger als andere Sachen. Und wir müssen jetzt unsere Freiheit bewahren. Und die haben dann angefangen, also wir waren ja durchaus beteiligt als CCC. Wir haben gesagt, okay, also wenn die das können, dann müssen wir irgendwas tun jetzt. Dann müssen wir gegenhalten. Und haben gesagt, okay, das Einzige, was wir tun können, ist, dass wir flächendeckend Crypto verteilen. Und dann müssen wir als erstes dafür sorgen, dass es überhaupt Crypto gibt, die man da einsetzen kann. Und das Problem ist eben damals, dass Crypto gab es einfach nicht so auf dem Massenmarkt, schon gar nicht. Nicht mehr als freie Software, es gab einfach nix.
Also ich weiß nicht, gab es sowas wie PC-DES?
Und es gab halt so kommerzielle Lösungen, die überhaupt nicht vertrauenswürdig aussahen. Und die waren aus Amerika und durften dann nicht exportiert werden, außer einer total zusammenkaskierten Version, auf 40 Bit runterskaliert, was als Schlüssellänge schon damals offensichtlich zu wenig war. Schon damals, das hätten wir irgendwie mit unseren paar Rechnern zusammengeschlossen knacken können in der realen Zeit. Also das war völlig klar. Das ist unzumutbar. Und daraufhin hat sich in Amerika Phil Zimmerman hingesetzt und PGP geschrieben.
Moment, lass mal kurz mal die zeitliche Reihenfolge beantworten. Also diese Bewegung lief halt unter dem Namen Cypherpunks. Also nicht verwechseln mit dem heutigen Versuch der Wikileaks-Fraktion.
Der Redcon-Versuch.
Der Wikileaks-Fraktion halt irgendwie sich diesen Cypherpunks-Mantel anzuziehen. Die Cypherpunks waren und sind, gibt es tatsächlich immer noch, die Gruppen in Kalifornien vorwiegend. Kommen halt aus einer ideologisch relativ hardcore-libertären Ecke, die halt zum gewissen Ding namens Krypto-Anarchie nachhängen, so als Ideologie. Also zu sagen, okay, wir versuchen den Staat möglichst weitgehend aus allem rauszuhalten, indem wir alles verschlüsseln und auch die Wirtschaft irgendwie digital verschlüsselt abwickeln und also versuchen halt, ein digitales Utopia zu schaffen, indem halt irgendwie Staaten und ihre Geheimnisse halt nichts mehr zu sagen haben.
Man muss auch sagen, dass es der Libertarismus sieht den Staat generell als suspekt an. Also das sind die Leute auch so Ron paul immer noch aktiv gerade so politisch, die sagen, wir müssen das alles abschaffen. Der Staat muss so klein wie möglich werden, so wenig wie möglich an Leistungen und Befugnissen haben. Das muss alles die persönliche individuelle Freiheit der Personen ist viel wichtiger als der Staat. Und das ist so ein bisschen suspekt. Also das ist nicht nur positiv. Also die haben, Kryptoanarchismus ist nicht nur ein Wortspiel, sondern es war wirklich die Idee, Anarchie herbeiführen zu können, indem wir dafür sorgen mit unserem Lebensstil und unserer Software und Kryptographie, dass die uns auch gar nichts mehr können. Die können uns nichts nachweisen, weil wir das alles verschlüsselt haben. Die können abhören, so viel sie wollen. Das bringt alles nichts. Also das war nicht nur die Idee, wir wehren uns jetzt gegen die NSA, sondern es hat eben auch Rückenwind für so eine Gruppierung gegeben. Und die haben tatsächlich Output erzeugt.
genau, also die waren tatsächlich effektiv in dem, was sie taten.
Weil die halt auch Erfahrungen hatten als Gruppe, die unabhängig von anderen.
Und eine Menge sehr smarter Leute. Und ein Bestandteil von dieser Krypto-Anarchie-Idee ist natürlich digitales Geld. Also Geld zu schaffen, was irgendwie nur im digitalen raum existiert und was unabhängig von Staaten und anderen Institutionen ist. Und der erste Versuch dazu war...
Das stellt sich als erstaunlich schwierig heraus.
genau, der erste Versuch dazu war halt von David schaum, das E-Cash oder Digi-Cash, war halt so das erste praktikable Digitalgeldsystem. Und das wurde 1990 patentiert.
Hat allerdings eine trusted third party, also das heißt man braucht irgendeinen Server, dem beide Seiten vertrauen.
Und interessanterweise hat es nicht so richtig abgehoben.
Da haben wir damit richtig mit gerechnet, dass es so richtig einschränkt. Wir haben gesehen, das gibt es jetzt, und haben gedacht, okay, das ändert jetzt die Welt. Und dann warteten wir und es passiert irgendwie nichts. Das fand uns richtig überrascht auch. Wir waren so, wieso, wann kommt denn jetzt hier? Was ist denn jetzt so, wo bleibt es denn jetzt?
Und der Grund dafür, es gab halt mehrere Gründe. Einer der Gründe war zum einen, dass alles patentierte Technologie war, die auf eine Firma, nämlich diese DigiCash Incorporated, zurückfiel. Und David schaum, sagen wir mal, auch ein bisschen schwierig ist als Persönlichkeit. Ja, also persönliche Umgang ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig ist. Und die andere Sache war, dass natürlich die Banken, nach der ersten Euphorie, digital Geld, Internet und alles toll und neu, dann doch so ein bisschen verstanden haben, dass sie sich damit halt ein echtes großes Loch ins Knie schießen.
Aber es gab tatsächlich, ich erinnere mich, es gab tatsächlich irgendwie einen Pilotversuch von der Postbank, oder was war das damals?
Nee, Deutsche Bank.
Deutsche Bank.
Bei der Deutsche Bank kannst du ein E-Cash-Konto einrichten.
Also es ist nicht völlig versickert, sondern es gab auch Versuche. Aber die Leute haben halt in Deutschland auch den Vorteil nicht gesehen davon. Warum sollte ich das machen?
Interessanterweise sind jetzt mittlerweile die Patente abgelaufen und es gibt Open Source-Implementierung von DigiCash.
Aber es ist halt immer noch trusted third party. Das ist immer so ein bisschen doof.
Ja, aber da gibt es halt auch Mutationen und Veränderungen. Allerdings muss man sagen, wie immer, 25 Jahre später passiert dann tatsächlich was, nämlich Bitcoin.
Bitcoin ist seitdem die erste große wirkliche Innovation bei digitalem Geld. Zumindest ist es das erste digitale Geld, das keine zentrale Stelle hat.
Was so eine signifikante Volumengeld enthält, muss man sagen. Alles, was vorher war, waren halt diverseste Versuche und Suchen.
Es waren ja so Pilotversuche. Prototypen, die halt entweder was wurden oder halt auch nicht.
Interessanterweise erst nach DigiCash gab es dann PGP 91.
Na gut, das dauert ja auch ein bisschen, so was zu programmieren.
Na gut, ja.
Also das war aber tatsächlich im Grunde im Wesentlichen ein einzelner Fils im Moment, der das gemacht hatte. Und der hat gesagt, das muss open source sein, sonst kann man dem nicht vertrauen. Und dann stellt er fest, dass das nicht exportieren durfte. Gut, das ist für die Amerikaner normalerweise nicht so eine Einschränkung, weil der wichtige Teil der Welt ist ja eh in Amerika. Aber er hat halt gemerkt, so die Leute im Ausland wollen das auch haben. Und dann haben wir überlegt, was man da machen kann. Und die Lösung war relativ lustig. Wir haben nämlich den Quellcode ausgedruckt und dann als Buch über die ganze getragen und dann gilt das als Free Speech und sie konnten nix dagegen tun. Dann war das nicht eine Export von Software, sondern von Ideen. Und dann gab es tatsächlich in Europa so eine relativ frei-atoxisch-zusammenfindende Mitte der 90er-Jahre. die sich gesagt haben, okay wir tippen das jetzt mal ab. Und dann gab es noch eine Gruppe, die darüber gegangen ist und Proofreading gemacht hat und ich erinnere mich, ich weiß nicht mehr welcher Kongress das war, aber auf einem Kongress haben wir irgendwie so die finale Proofreading, so die letzten Seiten und damit war PGP offiziell exportiert. Und dann haben wir das hier gehabt. Also ich meine, das war tatsächlich ein Durchbruch, weil das war zum ersten Mal eine starke Kryptographie in Europa, die nicht irgendwie close source von irgendeiner Regierung ist, der man nicht trauen kann. Gut, also jetzt rückblickend muss man sich auch fragen, ob wir irgendwie so PGP getraut haben, haben wir auch eigentlich nicht alle, oder? Sondern gab es auch irgendwie so Diskussionen. Aber im Grunde gab es keine Alternativen. Das war das Einzige, was es gab. Und es war eine große Euphorie, ich erinnere mich, dass alle Leute gesagt haben, oh, jetzt kann ich endlich mal richtig verschlüsseln. genau, ich erinnere mich, dass ich irgendwann mal vor dem Internet, vor meinen Internetzeiten, war ich im FIDO-Netz. Das war so ein zusammengekoppeltes BBS-System damals. Und da habe ich mal PGP benutzt. Und die kamen dann nicht an, die Mail. Also FIDO funktioniert so, dass man es halt bei der Mailbox abgibt und die wählen sich dann nachts zusammen und gibt es der überliegenden regionalen Mailbox an. So, wenn man einen Tag wartet, dann geht es halt irgendwie.
Und wieso kam es nicht an?
Und es kam nicht an, weil der damals für Berlin zuständige Hub im FIDO-Netz gesagt hat, nee, das verschlüsselt, das kann ich nicht lesen, das gebe ich nicht weiter.
Was?
Ja, man kann sehen, der Mindset war auch, es war eine andere Zeit, muss man einfach sagen. Da würde man heute sagen, ab in Knastkeule, ja. Aber das war halt so ein kooperatives System und so Postgeheimnis fand der appliziert nicht, weil er ist ja sein Geld, mit dem er das irgendwie weitergibt, an die nächste Mailbox so. Also, dass man überhaupt eine Möglichkeit hat, sich gegen solche Leute zu wehren, das war eine echte Neuigkeit damals. Und ich war richtig froh, als ich dann PGP hatte, muss ich sagen. Und als dann raus kam so PGP, da gibt es hier noch ein Problem und da noch ein Problem, da ist ja dann gebaut worden und später gab es OpenPGP, eine richtige Standardisierung im Rahmen der ITF sogar.
Und GNU-PG dann noch später.
Und GNU-PG als freie Implementierung in Europa entwickelt. Das war alles nur möglich, durch den Aufwand damals diesen Scheiß abzutippen. Und da haben wir auch wirklich gedacht, also es war nicht nur Euphorie, wir haben jetzt ein Tool, sondern da haben wir auch gedacht, so jetzt haben wir den Krieg gewonnen.
Ja, wir kommen noch mal gerade zu dem Krieg so, weil...
Ja, man muss sagen, dass die Regierung und die Dienste haben das natürlich gemerkt, dass da ein anderer Wind weht gerade. Und haben dann angefangen, so Gesetze vorzuschlagen. Also es ging los in England, da gab es jahrelange Debatten.
Also wir kommen jetzt sozusagen zu den ersten Crypto Wars, um noch mal den Flock einzuschlagen. Also jetzt geht es um die Auseinandersetzung zwischen den Regierungen und den freiheitsliebenden Menschen, darüber, ob man verschlüsseln darf oder nicht.
genau, also die Amerikaner haben halt diese Exportgeschichte gehabt.
Nicht nur die Amerikaner.
Und haben dann aber Druck gehabt? Also ja, das war bei uns in Frankreich, war auch verboten.
Nein, im Moment kann ich mir erklären. Und zwar gibt es da das sogenannte Wassenaer-Abkommen, unter dem halt Kryptoexport reguliert wird, was so ein Exportkontrollabkommen ist, was der Nachfolger von CoCom ist. CoCom war halt der...
War das nicht Schalck oder Kowski und Co?
Nein, das war CoCo. Und zwar war das Abkommen, da ging es halt darum, zu verhindern, dass irgendwie wesentlich Technologien aus Block gerät. Da wurden zum Beispiel Computer, waren oberhalb bestimmter Leistungsklassen oder CAT-Software oder Elektroniklayout-Software oder bestimmte Sensoren und so was, die wurden darunter reguliert und durften nicht exportiert. Und unter anderem halt Krypto auch. Und dieses Wassenerabkommen regelt bis heute tatsächlich, dass bestimmte Kryptographie exportkontrolliert ist. Und da gibt es halt unsere Spezifizierung mit Keylängen und mit allem Möglichen. Und die Ausnahme da drin ist halt, und das war der Punkt, an dem wir dachten, wir hätten die ersten Krypto Wars gewonnen. Als diese Ausnahme da reinkam, ist die sogenannte Software Exemption. Nämlich, wenn eine Verschlüsselung in Software implementiert, für den Massenmarkt zugänglich ist, fällt sie nicht unter Exportkontrolle. Das heißt, da entwickle ich jetzt Open Source Software für, oder die kann halt von jedem auf einfachen Wege erworben werden.
Also offensichtlich PGP fällt darunter?
genau, offensichtlich fällt PGP darunter. Und das war der Punkt, wo wir dachten, okay, der Versuch der Regierung, Krypto einzuschränken, den haben die verloren. Und zwar war es so, dass die Regierung gesagt hat, okay, also Krypto ist halt ein Problem, weil zum einen die bösen Kriminellen und dann später halt die Terroristen und natürlich der böse Ostblocker. Gut, der böse Ostblock fiel dann Anfang der 90er erstmal unter den Tisch, der hatte mit anderen Sachen zu tun.
Die Extremisten, die damals noch radikale hießen.
genau, wir müssen halt bei sonst die Kriminellen. Der gute Staat...
Es geht ja nicht um euch, sondern es geht um die da hinten.
genau, der gute Staat muss in der Lage sein, wenn es denn um die Wurst geht, so war die Ansage, halt irgendwie Krypto oder verschüsselte Sachen mitzulesen, nach dem Motto, okay, wir sehen ja ein, dass ihr verschüsseln müsst, damit die Kriminellen nicht eure Kommunikation lesen können, aber verschlüsselt man nicht so doll, dass wir nicht lesen können. Da gab es halt zwei Methoden. Die eine war, Krypto schwächer zu machen. Die haben es halt probiert mit dieser Einschränkung auf 40 Bit und so. Und die stellte sich dann als zunehmend lächerlich raus. War halt klar, dass die Leute nicht wollten, weil klar war, wenn der Staat auf 40 Bit einschränkt, dann können es kriminelle im Zweifel auch die Krypten. Also haben sie zwei unterschiedliche Sachen probiert. Die eine war halt natürlich, Krypto weiter schwächer zu machen und die Verbreitung zu verhindern. Und das zweite war zu sagen, okay, ihr könnt stark Krypto haben, aber nur mit sogenannten Key Escrow.
Na vorher war doch dieses, das war doch immerhin in Deutschland so, dass das Bild in Frankreich wirst du direkt verhaftet, wenn du Krypto-Software hast. Ich meine, in Russland ist das noch viel später gewesen, aber in Frankreich damals war so in Europa das Beispiel, wenn du da irgendwie mit Krypto erwischt wirst, kommst du direkt in den Knast, also das war der erste Versuch, dass man das einfach komplett verbietet und sagt, nee, das dürfte er nicht. Aber als das nicht mehr ging, und das ist, glaube ich, auf die Banken zurückzuführen, die irgendwann gesagt haben, ja, aber wir brauchen hier auch Krypto. Das war gar nicht so der Privat...
Nicht nur die Banken, sondern auch alles, was irgendwie digital kommuniziert...
Aber das war so der Teil der Industrie, der gesagt hat, wir brauchen hier aber Krypto.
genau.
So Flug-Sicherheit und so, was mir auch noch einfallen wurde, haben gesagt, naja, wir haben hier unser eigenen Kabel, das geht schon. Aber Banken haben gesagt, wir brauchen hier Krypto.
Die Banken haben gesagt, die brauchen Kry und auch ein Teil der Industrie haben gesagt, wir brauchen Krypto. Und was die Regierung dann einfiel, war das sogenannte Key Escrow. Das Key Escrow funktioniert so, dass sie sagen, okay, du kannst ein starkes Verschließungsverfahren verwenden, aber der Schlüssel wird entweder hinterlegt bei einer neutralen dritten Stelle.
Also die Regierung, denn die Regierung ist prinzipiell vertrauenslos.
Oder ja, da gab es auch so diverseste Schemen. Oder er wird zum Beispiel im System, was die Amis halt vorgeschlagen haben, dass an jeder verschiedenen Kommunikation wird der Schlüssel, mit dem diese Kommunikation verschlüsselt ist, mit einem Regierungsschlüssel verschlüsselt angehängt. Da gab es diesen sogenannten Clipper-Chip.
unglaublich, wenn man sich das heute überlegt hat. Ich meine, das war wirklich nicht nur auf dem Tisch als Vorschlag, sondern das war die Ernst gemeint. Und das wollten die in Gesetz tun. Und dieser Clipper-Chip, da ging es noch mehr als um diesen Escrow, sondern es ging darum, dass sie gesehen haben, wenn wir denen keine Krypto anbieten, dann bauen die sich selber welche und da kommen wir nicht mehr ran. Und dann haben sie Panik gekriegt und gesagt, okay, dann müssen wir jetzt schnell Massenmarkt-Krypto haben und die muss aber so sein, dass wir die mitlesen können, damit es keinen Leidensdruck mehr gibt, dass die sich eigene Krypto bauen. Und das war meines Erachtens eine Reaktion auf PGP. Der Clipper-Chip war ein Chip, der von der NSA designt und auch tatsächlich gebaut wurde. Das machen wir heute wohl weniger oder nicht mehr?
Nee, die sind ausgestiegen. Also die haben noch eine Contract Factory, aber...
Im Wesentlichen haben sie damals ihre Hardware selber gebaut und da sind sie einfach komplett überrollt worden von der Industrie. Aber die haben halt diese Chips gebaut und das haben die so in Telefone eingebaut und diese Telefone sollten alle Amerikaner kriegen.
Und Modems.
Und Modems. Und die hätten halt dieses Verfahren so gemacht. Die hätten den Schlüssel mit dem Regierungsschlüssel angehängt.
genau. Und das haben die tatsächlich richtig ernsthaft mit großem Aufwand argumentiert. Und da gab es auch so ein paar Wissenschaftler, die dann da auf ihrer Seite waren.
Die sich haben kaufen lassen, weil sie natürlich von Regierungsgeld abhängig sind.
Oder nicht mal zwingen kaufen lassen. Also zum Beispiel hier Dorothy Denning, die damals die hauptvertreterin auf der Wissenschaftsseite für dieses Verfahren war. Die haben sie wohl überzeugt, indem sie ein paar gruselige FBI-Files gezeigt haben. Sie haben gesagt, hier gucken sie mal diese Kinderschänder hier.
Na, das macht ja jetzt immer noch die Zirke-Show. Das ist ein Verfahren, das funktioniert.
Wenn wir nicht dieses Kiesco-Verfahren haben, dann würden diese Kinderschänder hier weiter mit...
Dann können wir die nicht mehr fangen...
.können die weiter Krypto benutzen. Also das war sozusagen der Höhepunkt der Crypto Wars in dem Punkt. Und am Ende...
Das ist natürlich ein rotes Zu für die Libertären, weil die sagen, eh wir trauen der Regierung nicht und dann zu sagen, ja aber ist ja sicher nur das mit dem Regierungsschlüssel nur wenn wirklich notwendig. Das glaubt natürlich keine sau von denen.
Und dann kam die Wende...
Die Wende kam ein Buch von Bruce Schneier, der immer noch einen guten Namen hat, deswegen eigentlich unverdient, wie ich finde.
Na ja, also dafür kann er sich schon eine Kerbe ins Gebot schützen.
Der hat im Grunde sein Lebenswerk mit diesem einen Buch gemacht, das heißt Applied Cryptography, das kam 1994 raus. Das war ein Meilenstein, weil es tatsächlich nicht nur mathematisch an Wissenschaftler gerichtet war, sondern es war populärwissenschaftlich an Programmierer gerichtet. Er hat gesagt, aber dieses Verfahren funktioniert so, hier ist der Code, musst du nur abtippen, geht. Und hat gesagt, dieses Verfahren würde ich lieber nicht benutzen. Also hat auch zum Beispiel über die Ghost-Standards geredet, das war die russische Crypto, gesagt, also würde ich lieber nicht benutzen, also auf dem niveau. Das war nicht irgendwie dieses Verfahren existiert, sondern er hat auch ein bisschen bewertet und hat gesagt, also das sieht mir sauberer aus als jenes Verfahren. Und dieses Buch hat erstmalig die breite Menge an Leuten die Möglichkeit gegeben, selber Krypto-Software zu schreiben. Muss man rückblickend zu sagen. Also die Open-Source-Bewegung gab es zwar schon, aber es war sehr klein. Der Großteil der freien Software war damals Binär-Only, so Share-Wertzeug und auf Floppis verteilt.
Und 1996 kam dann das Handbook of Applied Cryptography, was sozusagen nochmal ein...
Das war noch eine Stufe cooler, weil es nämlich tatsächlich als PDF im Netz steht, seit vielen Jahren downloadbar.
Und man da halt einfach den Code einfach copy-pasten konnte.
Und wir haben auch erklärt, wie Public Key funktioniert. Der Schneier hat hauptsächlich die ganzen symmetrischen Sachen erklärt.
Ja, zumindest in der ersten Auflage, ja.
Aber das war so eine Aufbruchszeit, ja. Wir haben gesagt, okay, das Key is growth, das können wir nicht... Wir müssen jetzt selber, wir müssen jetzt was machen. Und damals war auch so die Aufbruchszeit des Internets, da ging dann das Web richtig los und Netscape hatte gerade den Mosaic-Browser genommen und daraus Mozilla gebaut oder Netscape, ich sehe damals ja noch. Mhm, das geht noch. Da gab es dann irgendwann, okay, wir müssen jetzt hier Crypto anbieten, weil die Leute wollen ja Banking machen. Und da gab es dann auch verschiedene konkurrierende Standards. Der von Netscape hieß SSL, der hat sich durchgesetzt. Der wurde direkt noch während der Vorstellung gebrochen. Das war eine richtig peinliche Angelegenheit. Und dann haben sie ihn ein paar Wochen später, haben sich dann mit Kryptografen hingesetzt und haben die SSL-Version 2 gemacht. Das gilt heute auch als furchtbar. Und da ist dann den Regulierungsleuten klar geworden, so jetzt haben wir verloren. Jetzt muss hier was gemacht werden.
Dann hat zumindest mit dem Ansatz von... Also KeySpro funktioniert nicht und Kryptoverbreitunglimitien funktioniert auch nicht mehr so richtig.
Also das Lustige war ja, dass Netscape, als sie SSL hatten, trotzdem an diese Exportrestriktion gebunden waren und nur 40 Bits exportieren durften. Und dann haben aber die Amerikaner angefangen, im Inland SSL zu benutzen, um ihr Banking zu machen. Und haben dann argumentiert, ja, aber das geht ja nicht. Und zwar haben das die Banken gesagt, die haben gesagt, hör mal, wir haben hier Regulierung, wir sagen so und so, sicherheitsniveau muss gegeben werden. Das ist damit nicht erreichbar, wir brauchen hier eine Ausnahme. Und dann haben die angefangen, so Dinge in diesen SSL-Start reinzuhacken. Das nennt sich Server-Gated-Crypto. Also die Idee ist, dass man sich verbindet mit dem kastrierten Browser. Und die Gegenseite hat dann ein Spezialzertifikat, in dem drin steht, ich bin eine Bank, ich habe das nachgewiesen. Ja, die mussten tatsächlich dann ihre Gründungsurkunde und so, blablabla, an ICA schicken, um so ein Zertifikat zu kriegen. Und daraufhin hat der Browser einen neuen key-austausch gemacht, mit richtigen Verfahren freigeschaltet.
Das heißt, der Code war in dem Browser schon drin.
Der Code war in dem Browser drin. genau, und das hat den guten Effekt gehabt, dass man das frei cracken konnte. Und es gab damals gecrackte Versionen von Netscape im Netz, die generell die harten Zweifel frei hatten. Also das war eine groteske Situation damals. Aber im Grunde war beiden Seiten klar, die Fronten sind verhärtet und wir müssen jetzt hier Fakten schaffen, sonst ist das verloren.
Das war so der Zeitpunkt, so Ende der 90er, hatten wir eigentlich so das Gefühl, okay, das mit den Crypto Wars haben wir gewonnen. Da passiert jetzt nichts mehr. Und was wir halt übersehen haben, dass die Gegensätze natürlich nicht aufgegeben hat.
Aber da war die Euphorie hat uns irgendwie abgelenkt.
Wir waren zu happy.
Wir haben uns dieses CA-Modell eingetreten damals. Das war so ein KMOS X 509.
Certificate Authority. Muss man vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen genauer erklären, vor allen Dingen, was das Problem daran ist. Also was das Problem mit einem Großteil der Crypto im Web ist, die wir gerade haben, nämlich dieses Certificate Authority-Modell.
Also nehmen wir an, man verbindet sich zu einem HTTPS-Server per SSL und der sagt dann, ich bin blog.pefe.de. Woher weiß ich denn, dass das stimmt? Oder ich bin, was weiß ich, postbank.de. Woher weiß ich, dass das stimmt? Das weiß ich nicht. Der Browser hat eine Liste mit Ausstellern von Zertifikaten. Das muss man sich vorstellen wie Ausgabe-Stellen von personalausweisen. Nur, dass die nicht staatlich sind, sondern das sind irgendwelche Funden.
Man kann es eher vorstellen wie Nutriater eigentlich.
Na, es sind auch nicht Nutriater, weil da geht es ja auch gesetzliche Regelungen für. Das sind irgendwelche Arschlöcher im Internet. Muss mal ein bisschen unfreundlich zu formulieren. Die halt gesagt haben, wir stellen diese Zertifikate aus. Und denen kann ich im Grunde vertrauen oder auch nicht. Aber die Wahl stellt sich für die meisten Leute nicht, weil sie das ganze System nicht blicken. So, jetzt hat der Browser eine Liste von CAS, die er traut. Und der Webserver, zu dem ich mich connecte, gibt mir sein Zertifikat und das ist unterschrieben von einer von denen. Und wenn die unterschreibende Instanz jetzt im Browser drin ist, dann sagt der Browser, okay, dann vertraue ich dem. Und winkt durch. So, und dann gibt es auch keine Pop-ups mehr und gar nichts.
Ja, Moment, lass noch mal genauer sagen, was vertraue ich dem. Was er nämlich tut ist, der Webserver präsentiert mir ein Zertifikat, was unterschrieben ist von dieser Instanz. Also sozusagen nutraiell beglaubigtes Wurkundchen.
genau, aber halt nicht vom Notar, sondern von irgendeiner kommerziellen Firma.
genau, von dieser kommerziellen Instanz. Und die Art und Weise, wie diese kommerzielle Instanz überprüft, dass derjenige wirklich der ist, der dir vorgibt zu sein, ist halt weit schwankend. Und das zweite Problem ist halt, dass so eine CA, so eine Certificate Authority, kann natürlich dich verarschen. Kann zum Beispiel irgendjemand sein Zertifikat stempeln und dann kann derjenige die Verbindung in der Mitte abhören. Also dann kann der sich sozusagen hinstellen und sagen, ok ich bin postbank.de.
Also nehmen wir mal an, ich bin jetzt bei Notar Frank und Frank unterschreibt mein Zertifikat und der Browser kennt Frank und sagt, ok Frank vertraue ich. Und jetzt kommt die Polizei zu Frank und sagt, hör mal der Mann ist ein Krimineller, den müssen wir abhören. Gib uns doch auch mal ein Zertifikat, wo drin steht, ich bin blog fefe.de. Und Frank müsste das dann tun, weil das nämlich die Regierung ist. Und da gibt es Gesetze und der muss dem folgen.
Oder ich gehöre sowieso der Regierung.
Das ist sogar in Deutschland tatsächlich der Fall. Eine der CAs, denen weit vertraut wird, gehört der Telekom. Und die gehört zum überwiegenden Teil der Regierung. Also niemand verbietet Frank für mehr als ein Zertifikat in die Hand zu drücken, was sagt...
Ich verspreche, aber mach ich nicht. Ich schwör.
Natürlich. Das heißt aber letztendlich muss ich Frank vertrauen. Schlimmer noch, jetzt gibt es auch noch die Honest Ali-CA. Die ist so als Running Gag, weil irgendwer bei Mozilla mal einen Bug gefeilt hat. Wie hieß der? Honest Ali? Oder Mohammed oder so? Honest Ahmed, genau. Mit used car salesman und CA. Also die unseriöseste Geschichte überhaupt. Hat halt beantragt, dass seine CA auch in die Liste der vertrauten CA kommt. Nur um mal zu sehen, was dann passiert. Also jetzt nehmen wir mal an, irgendeine andere CA kommt und stellt ein Zertifikat aus. Auf meinen Namen. Da kann ich auch nichts gegen tun.
Also vor allen Dingen sieht der User im Browser sich nur schloss es zu, weil da kommt etwas.
genau, der User im Browser sieht nichts davon, egal ob das zweite Zertifikat, egal von wem das kam, solange es irgendeine CA ist, die im Browser als vertrauenswürdig deklariert ist. Und diese Liste sollte ich euch mal angucken.
Die geben wir euch mal als hausaufgabe. Guckt mal in eurem Betriebssystem bzw. in eurem Browser nach, was da alles für Certificate, Authorities drin sind.
Findet erst mal überhaupt raus, wie man das nachguckt. Das ist nämlich alles andere als trivial. Denn das wollen die nämlich nicht, dass du da nachguckst, weil dich das echt unsicher zurücklässt. Mit einem schlechten Gefühl.
Also bei Mac OS ist es relativ einfach. Da gibt es halt irgendwie ein Browsersystem dafür. Also kannst du halt einfach...
Na, wenn du es weißt, wo du klicken musst, das ist überall einfach.
Du kannst in den Keychain-Manager gucken.
Aber der Punkt ist jedenfalls, das ganze System ist letztendlich vertrauensbasiert. Und die Entscheidung, wen du vertraust, liegt zwar letztendlich bei dir, aber die defaults fasst keine sau an. Das heißt, wenn ich mir so einen Firefox frisch installiere, dann vertraut der irgendwie 34 Cards oder so. Oder noch mehr. Es waren mal 34 als vor Jahren. Jetzt sind es so 50 oder was? Wie viele sind es jetzt? Also unglaublich viele. Und da sind so Namen drin wie halt die Telekom oder TurkTrust.
Ja, TurkTrust ist auch super.
Und so Sachen wie DigiNOTAR war da natürlich auch drin. DigiNOTAR ist eine CIA, die regierungsnah bei den Holländern lief und die ist komplett geohnt worden. Das heißt, da wissen wir, dass die Schlüssel ausgestellt hat, die nicht koscher waren und denen haben Browser vertraut. Und selbst wenn ich jetzt von Software-Sachen absehe, sollte man allein deswegen seine Browser trotzdem immer updaten, nur damit diese Liste schön up to date bleibt.
Die hilft dir halt auch nicht.
Selbst wenn die Liste okay ist, kannst du nicht ausschließen, dass irgendeine der korrupten Regierungen in irgendeinem der Länder, wo irgendeine dieser CAs ist, nicht doch ein Zweitzertifikat ausgestellt hat.
Oder ein Waldkartzertifikat bekommen hat.
Und was man kaufen kann kommerziell, tatsächlich so im Laden sind Router, die sich bei SSL in die Mitte hängen. Das heißt, wenn irgendein User, wie ich jetzt zum Beispiel, zu Postbank gehen will, dann kann dieser Router ein Zertifikat generieren, was sagt, ich bin Postbank. Und wenn ich einen CA-Schlüssel konfiguriert habe, der vom Browser vertraut wird, dann sagt der Browser, okay.
genau, also alles, was du brauchst, ist ein zweitzertifikat.
Das gibt es. Und es ist auch bekannt, dass solche Waldkart-Zertifikate benutzt wurden von Unterdrückungsregimes. Also es ist natürlich noch nicht irgendwie nachgewiesen worden, dass die NSA sowas macht, aber sie könnten rein von der Technik her.
Wir wissen aus den Snowden-Freunden, dass sie sowas machen, dass sie Large-Scale-Mannende-Mittel-Installationen haben. Und wo sie jetzt ihre Zertifikate haben, ist irgendwie irrelevant, weil irgendwie im Zweifel brechen sie halt bei CIA und holen sich es.
Also es gibt ja in Amerika diese National Security-Letters, mit denen man im Grunde ohne richterlichen Beschluss alles Mögliche abschnorcheln kann an Daten von wem auch immer. Und derjenige unterliegt einem Gag-Order und darf mit niemandem darüber reden, auch nicht mit seinem Anwalt.
genau, so lief halt zum Beispiel diese Geschichte mit Lava-Bit, die hier gerade hergekommen ist.
Da sind sie hingegangen und haben gesagt, gib uns doch mal eure SSL-Schlüssel.
genau, gib uns mal den Schlüssel. Der Mann, das ist übrigens auch ein Kandidat für den Balls of Steel Award.
Ja, der hat gesagt, oh Scheiße, mach ich über die Firma zu.
Nee, Moment, was er getan hat, er hat direkt davor den Schlüssel ausgeliefert, um den Feind zu umgehen, indem man sie in Vier-Punkt-Schrift auf elf Seiten ausgedruckt und übergeben hat. Den Schlüssel. So, also da hat der Bote so.
Ihr Schweine.
Go fuck you. genau. Also gut, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt dachten wir noch, okay, wir haben SSL, wir kriegen ganze Zeitverschlüsse.
Wir haben PGP, so IPSEC, irgendwie war auch so eine Neuentwicklung, kommen wir auch noch drauf. Also wir haben gedacht, so jetzt haben wir aber echt alles verschlüsselt, jetzt wird alles gut.
Oder wir können es zumindest. So 95 kram noch S-MIME, was halt die Verschlüsselung für...
Für E-Mail ist, so alternative Verschlüsselung, das ist X509, ist sowas wie PGP nur halt mit dem CR-Modell.
Ja, für zentralisiertes System, also ein zentralisiertes vertrauensmodell. PGP ist halt ein verteiltes vertrauensmodell, das heißt also, man vertraut den Leuten, von denen man einen Schlüssel kriegt, deren Fingerprint man gelesen hat und dann halt eben die entsprechenden Signaturen darunter. Also man unterschreibt halt gegeneinander Schlüssel und sagt halt, okay, also ich hab Fefes Schlüssel gesehen und da schreib ich den. Das Dove daran ist nur, wenn dann der Schlüssel auf dem Server landet, dann wissen alle Leute, dass sie was mit Fefe zu tun haben. Na gut, okay.
Komm, man hat mein soziales Netz aufwesen, das ist auch alles scheiße. So, also in diesem Euphoriemoment fing es dann an mit den Rückschlägen. Es ging los 1996, da läuft Nikki Hage, das ist halt diese Neuseeländerin, läuft mit dem Fernsehteam in die NSA-Station rein, in die Echelonstation und da wurde das so ein bisschen konkret plötzlich. Vorher war das alles so, wie man es hat gesagt, aber dann hat man halt die Bilder gesehen und diese fetten Schüsseln, die die da hatten und damit war das weniger abstrakt und dann kommt man sehen, okay, also das ist shit just got real. So, das war irgendwie das Ding und dann kam die Sache mit Lotus Notes raus 1997. Lotus Notes war als erstes richtig fettes, kommerzielles E-Mail-System in der Lage, Public Key-Krypto zu machen, aber durfte das halt nicht exportieren. Und dann haben sie so ein Deal gemacht, weil sie halt auch viel an Regierungen ausliefern und an Banken. Und der Deal war, dass sie zwar größere Schlüssel nehmen, aber die obere Hälfte ist der NSA bekannt. So nur die unteren 40 bits sind nicht bekannt.
Und schön war der Name.
Und das haben sie aber offensiv bekannt gegeben. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sie das geschafft haben, dass sie das nicht irgendwie geheim halten mussten.
Na, es war nicht so richtig offensiv. Am Anfang wollten sie da nicht so gerne darüber reden und dann hat irgendjemand bei IBM entschieden, okay, wir wollen uns jetzt hier der Peinlichkeit hingehen und rumzustottern. Schreiben wir es halt in die Doku rein und dann haben wir...
Und die hieß ja eh keiner so und dann hat es aber noch jemand gelesen.
genau, und dann haben sie halt einen großartigen Namen dafür gefunden. Weißt du, wie es geht?
Workload Reduction.
genau, das Work Factory Reduction.
Also grandios, was typisches IBM-Beamtenenglisch. Und da war klar, okay, also die Gegenseite schläft nicht.
genau, also versucht, wo es geht, zu verhindern, dass man Krypto mit langen Keys verwenden kann.
Und da fiel uns dann auch langsam auf, dass wir vielleicht mit den Krypto-Verfahren ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein müssen. Damals, das galt so langsam als unsicher, aber es ist ja immer noch so ein Unterschied, ob man abstrakt irgendwas für unsicher hält oder ob das konkret wird. Und die EFF hat 1998 dann Deepcrack gebaut. Das war so ein ASIC-Ding mit Spezialchips. Eine Maschine, die einfach nur das Ziel hatte, das zu cracken, indem es alle Schlüssel durchprobiert, weil einfach die Schlüsselhänge nicht lang genug war.
Für eine Viertelmillion Dollar?
Das hat eine Viertelmillion gekostet. Das ist ein haufen Geld auch damals gewesen für ein Non-Profit wie EFF, aber das war es wert, rückblickend.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt war es halt so, dass da schon andere Krypto-Verfahren verwendet wurden, also Trippel, zum Beispiel.
Ja, es gab Ideen, das war ein guter Pg, aber das war halt patentbehaftet und immer so ein bisschen schwierig alles. Aber das fing an konkret zu werden, das Problem, dass wir möglicherweise Krypto-Agilität brauchen, nennt man das heute, dass man nämlich bei einer bestehenden Software-Suite im Nachhinein die Verfahren ändern kann oder upgraden kann. Das war schlagartig klar, dass es jetzt so sein muss.
Also Ende der 90er war die Euphorie dann so ein bisschen vorbei. Digi-Cache ging dann pleite, also die haben da keinen Fuß auf den Boden bekommen. GNU-PG kam, ne?
GNU-PG, das erste Release, was ich gefunden hab, war von 1998. Das war von Werner Koch, der versucht, PGP nachzuprogrammieren als freie Software, also auch im Sinne von freier Lizenz-GPL. OpenPGP als Standard ist auch in dem Jahr gemacht worden. Das ist ein RFC von der ITF, das heißt ein offener Standard. Wenn man den liest, kann man das nachimplementieren. Das hat GNU-PG gemacht.
Und TLS?
Ja, TLS kam danach. Also IPSEC war noch in dem Jahr 1998. Und TLS 1.0, das war die Standardisierung von SSL für die ITF. Das war auch danach. Das war 1999. Aber da war halt klar, das Internet braucht Kryptografie. Und das müssen wir auch richtig als Internet-Standards machen. Und aus dem Jahr sind es die ganzen wichtigen Krypto-Standards. So TLS, IPSEC.
1999, also zum Ende sozusagen des Jahrzehnts, war dann auch der Zeitpunkt, als in Deutschland die Krypto-Fonds offiziell vorbei waren. Da gab es dann diese sogenannten Eckpunkte der deutschen Kryptopolitik. Ganz wesentlich mit durchgesetzt von damals Staatssekretär Ulrich Sandl, der sich da sehr verdient gemacht hat, indem halt eben festgelegt wurde, dass effektiv zu verschlüsseln gut für die Wirtschaft ist.
Und das trumpft ja bei uns andere.
genau, das trumpft ja sozusagen alles bei uns, Wirtschaft und Arbeitsplätze. Und dass der digitale Selbstschutz vor allen anderen Überlegungen halt vorrang hat und der Staat nicht versuchen wird, mit Key Escrow oder ähnlichen Verfahren Krypto schwächer zu machen.
Also wir haben zwar keinen Gesetzentwurf gehabt über Key Escrow, aber das war wirklich in der Debatte.
Das war in der Debatte. genau, das war jahrelang in der Debatte. Und es wurde immer wieder gefordert, dass es eingeschränkt werden sollte, die Verbreitung von Krypto und so. Und das war halt 99 dann vorbei. Also es war halt dann diese Eckpunkte der deutschen Kryptopolitik, war halt so ein fetter Meilenstein dafür, auf dem man sich immer noch berufen kann und man sagen kann so, okay, das ist tatsächlich die offizielle deutsche Politik zum Thema Krypto, ist halt irgendwie verschlüsselt, so gut du kannst und so gut du willst. Niemand kann dich daran hindern, niemand darf dich daran hindern. Das gab es in vielen anderen Ländern so nicht. Es ist tatsächlich eine relative deutsche Besonderheit, dass es also ein offizielles Ende der ersten Krypto Wars gibt, mit so einem fetten Flock, der da eingeschlagen wird.
Also bei den Briten gab es auch Krypto Wars, die geendet sind. Da gab es so ein Gesetz, wo es hieß, der Schlüssel muss hinterlegt werden und das ist dann aus der nächsten Revision des Gesetzes sagen und klanglos, kommentarlos, verschwunden.
Aber dafür haben sie halt dann den...
Auch schön, aber es ist nicht so ein Flock, das darf nie wieder probiert werden. So was gab es da nicht. Und die Briten haben dieses andere Gesetz, das sagt, du musst deine Pass-Race rausrücken.
Den Regulation of Investigatory Powers Act, der ist eigentlich ein echtes Fascho-Gesetz, das muss man so sagen.
Das ist echt ein Fascho-Gesetz.
Also in Deutschland ist es halt so, wenn die Polizei zu dir kommt und sagt, hey, gib mal irgendwie deine Pass-Race raus, dann sagst du, la, la, nee, nee, gehst du nicht. Und die Grundlage dafür ist, es ist so ein selbstbelastungsverbot. Also es ist halt in Deutschland im Strafverfahren kannst du nicht gezwungen werden, dich selbst zu belasten. Und du kannst halt einfach sagen, so mit Verweis auf Selbstbelastungsverbot verweigerst du der herausgabe des Passworts oder des Schlüssels. Und damit war es das dann als der Fisch geputzt.
Man kann natürlich versuchen die Passphrase zu raten.
Sie können versuchen sie zu raten, sie können versuchen die Crypto zu brechen, sie können versuchen den Computer zu raten, können sie alles tun.
Aber du musst ihnen nicht helfen.
Du musst ihnen dabei nicht helfen. So und in Großbritannien ist es halt anders, da gibt es eben diesen Rip Act.
Da kannst du in Beugehaft kommen, wenn du dich weigerst dein Passwort auszurücken.
genau und zwar bis du es rausrückst.
Oder vielleicht hast du es ja auch vergessen oder vielleicht gibt es ja gar kein Passwort. Also wenn du zufällige Daten hast auf deiner Platte und die behaupten, das ist Krypto und wollen die Passphrase haben und es gibt keine Passphrase, das kannst du ja nicht beweisen. Aber trotzdem können die dich dann im Knast behalten, bis du es rausrückst.
Also die Briten sind da echt faschon in der Beziehung. Und interessanterweise in den USA ist es ja so, da gibt es ja das Fifth Amendment, wo es auch so ein Selbstbelastungsverbot gibt. Da gibt es halt Taking the Fifth, also sozusagen sich darauf zu rufen, gibt es halt im Strafverfahren. Und interessanterweise ist...
Das ist aber noch umstritten. Da gab es Entscheidungen in beide Richtungen, ob das auf Passworte auch zutrifft.
Na ja, interessanterweise ist die Mehrheitsmeinung ja, aber die haben den Weg gefunden drum rum. Und zwar im Rahmen von Grand Jury Investigations können sie den Leuten, die nicht unmittelbar die Beschuldigten sind, Immunität zusichern für alles, was sie auf dieser Festplatte finden und sie damit zwingen, den Schlüssel raus zu rücken.
Ach, weil es dann keine Belastung mehr ist.
genau. Das heißt, wenn du das Zeuge geladen wirst, sagen sie dir halt irgendwie hier, wir wollen nicht dich, wir wollen den da drüben.
Und das machen die deutschen Polizisten ja auch immer wieder gerne.
Ja, aber hier kannst du sagen, ne, tut mir leid, da sind noch andere Sachen drauf, die möglicherweise mich belasten und da passiert halt nichts. Und damit kommt es halt in der Regel auch durch. Die versuchen es halt immer wieder. Also es ist halt so, dass die, muss man auch sagen, das dürfen sie auch, sie dürfen halt mit Tricks versuchen, dich dazu zu bringen, dein Passwort trotzdem rauszuregen. Dann sagen sie, ja, pass auf für irgendwie, wenn du irgendwie das Passwort nicht gibst, dann bist du angeklagt, dann gehst du in den Knast und alles doof für dich. Und hey, drück doch mal dein Passwort raus, wir wollen noch gar nichts von dir. Wir wollen auch nur den da drüben.
Das entlastet dich doch selbst.
genau, hilft dir doch mal, dich selbst zu entlasten. So einen Bullshit dürfen sie halt alles probieren. Da muss man dann einfach sagen, danke, nein. Mein Passwort ist mein Passwort und das werdet ihr nicht bekommen. Dazu habt ihr auch alles recht. Auch dieses, was sie dann versuchen zu sagen, es sieht aber echt schlecht aus, wenn du uns nicht dein Passwort gibst. Das Vorgerecht sieht wirklich doof aus.
Das mögen Jury's aber nicht.
genau, das mögen die Richter halt nicht so oder hättest du ja was zu verbergen und so. Alles Bullshit irgendwie, das wird dir auch dein Anwalt erklären, wenn du das Problem hast, der wird dir halt sagen, die Verpflichtung, dich selbst zu belassen, existiert nicht. Du kannst dich da einfach drauf verlassen, dass du einfach nie sagen darfst.
In anderen Ländern ist das teilweise anders. Insbesondere ist es so, dass sie teilweise am Flughafen, bevor man offiziell eingereist ist, sich Spezialbefugnisse rausnehmen und dich dann einfach...
Zum Beispiel die USA.
Oder was jetzt halt kürzlich passiert ist, die Briten haben das gemacht mit dem Partner von Clean Green World. Also das ist schwierig, deswegen ist der offizielle Rat einfach nicht mit verschlüsselten Sachen irgendwo einreisen, sondern mit leerer Platte oder gar keine Platte und dann vor Ort eine Platte kaufen oder so. Ja, 1999 war auch noch mal so ein richtiger Meilenstein. Da war nämlich diese Echelonsache dann richtig endgültig amtlich. Da hat nämlich Duncan Campbell, dieser Wadenbeißer-Reporter, hat einen Bericht geschrieben für das Europäische Parlament über Echelon und der hieß Interception Capabilities 2000. Und der hat richtig Fotos drin von solchen Abhörstationen und listet alles auf, was geht. Und da konnte dann wirklich keiner mehr sagen, er hat es noch nicht gehört. Damit war die Sache echt amtlich. Da gibt es sogar ein Foto von einem dieser Vortex-Schnüffelsatelliten. Und das ist sehr witzig, wenn man das mit Pressefotos von den Turaya-Satelliten vergleicht. Sieht das verdammt ähnlich aus. Vielleicht wird so noch mal kurz ausgeführt, was Turaya eigentlich ist.
Turaya ist ein Satellitensystem, was betrieben wird von einem arabischen Konsortium, was in den Golf-Imiraten sitzt. Die sind halt ein bisschen besonders. Also das Geld kommt von den Arabern. Die Satelliten werden von USA in den USA gebaut, die auch dieselben sind, die die Vortex-Satelliten gebaut haben. Und die...
Die technische Besonderheit ist, dass es GSM ist, aber über Satellit.
Quasi GSM mit ganz wenigen Modifikationen, was halt über einen Satelliten abgewickelt wird. Und dadurch können sie halt sehr billige Satellitentelefone bauen. Und die statt Zellen haben die so eine Spotbeams. Das heißt also auf diese Antenne werden verschiedene, sage ich mal, schmale Kanäle gerechnet, die halt so neuneinhalb Kilometer Durchmesser dann auf der Erdoberfläche haben. Und jeweils innerhalb dieser Zelle können sich Telefone mit dem Satelliten verbinden. Und dazu brauchen wir halt eine spezielle Antennenkonstruktion. Und diese Antennenkonstruktionen bestehen halt aus so ganz dünnen Kohlefaserstäben, die dann halt sich im All ausfalten. Also wie so ein Mikado so rückwärts quasi. Und das ist schon so richtige Raketentechnologie. Und die Spekulation ist halt, dass irgendwie US, die und zum Beispiel damit Thoraya, dann halt diese Antenne-Technologie halt von der NSA sozusagen recycelt bzw. lizenziert hat. Und da gab es einen Hinweis in einem Buch, ich hab leider vergessen, wie es hieß, dass diese Konstruktion so fragil ist, dass man sie auf der Erde nicht testen kann, weil sie dann unter der Gravitation zusammenbricht. Sondern dass man sie halt sozusagen so leicht gebaut hat, damit man die halt in die Rakete noch reinbekommt, dass sie halt nur an Schwerelosigkeit ausgefeilt wird.
Das klingt ein bisschen nach diesem Blackbird mit seinem Fuelsystem. Naja, so ist das eben, wenn Geld keine Rolle spielt, dann ist man auch nicht an reguläre Labumgebung gebunden.
Ja, genau.
Ja, also aber diese Duncan Campbell Geschichte hat es halt richtig reingereben so damals. Da konnte dann keiner mehr leugnen.
Und aber interessanterweise, also richtig die Diskussionen gingen halt relativ langsam los nach diesem Bericht, zog sich dann so 2000 hin und dann war es...
Bis zum NSA-Key. Das war nochmal so ein richtiger Kracher. Der hat es hier auch richtig in die Presse geschafft. Und zwar war es so, dass Microsoft für NT4, Service Pack 5 versehentlich die Symbole mit ausgeliefert hat. Das passiert eigentlich selten. Das ist ein echter Verkacker. Und da konnte man dann die Symbole der Crypto Library angucken und da gab es dann ein Symbol namens Unterstrich NSA-Key mit 1024 Bit-Key. Und das erinnerte natürlich fatal an dieses Key-Scroll-Modell, was sie vorgeschlagen hatten. Dass man sagt, mit dem Regierungsschlüssel nochmal separat verschlüsselt. Das wäre genau so was. Also wenn man einen Regierungsschlüssel sucht, der würde ungefähr so aussehen. Und dass der dann auch noch NSA-Key heißt, also da war für viele Leute völlig klar, okay, also der Krypto in kommerziellen Produkten kann man auch nicht mehr trauen.
Hat denn mal jemand eigentlich mal dem hinterher getraced, wo dieser Key gelesen wird?
Ich glaube, man hat irgendwie rausgefunden, dass der unter bestimmten Umständen benutzt wird. Aber Microsoft hat geleugnet, dass der damit irgendwas zu tun hat. Der hat immer gesagt, das sei ein Backup-Key, falls der erste kompromittiert wird oder sowas.
Und wofür war der Key da?
Unklar, ist bis heute unklar. Mehr als diese Microsoft-Geschichte weiß man nicht.
Also hat sich niemand...
Und die NSA sagt natürlich, das würden wir nie tun.
Da hat sich niemand mal mit Oddy DeBug hingesetzt und dem hinterher gelaufen, oder wie?
Na doch, also man konnte sehen, dass man mit dem irgendwie Sachen signieren und in Systemen einbringen kann und dann irgendwie... Also das war schon...
Achso, das war schon ein Key für...
Das war schon ein richtig wichtiger Key, ja. So, aber das hilft natürlich nur, wenn du den Private Key dazu hast, ne? Und deswegen konnte man das nie probieren.
Na ja, verstehe.
Und man konnte den durch einen Bug an einer anderen Stelle wohl irgendwie ersetzen mit irgendwas anderem. Und das war dann so, ja, so schlimm ist das nicht, weil...
Aber gut, 1024 Bits könnte man doch eigentlich mal machen, ne?
Heute meinste, ja. Machen wir mal. Also das ist schon immer noch sehr aufwendig, in 1024 Bits.
Ja, gut, okay.
Aber also damals, das war irgendwie die Smoking Gun, auf das alle gewartet haben, dass man kommerzieller Software nicht mehr trauen kann. Und die Gerüchte ging ja vorher schon rum, ja. Auch von Cisco hat man sich das jahrelang zugeräumt, dass die in ihren Exportroutern irgendwelche Hintertüren drin haben.
Haben sie offenbar auch.
Ja, naja, gut.
Also, wie wir jetzt wissen, war dieses Ganze auf hoher Wege Zeige ja auch nur Abgelenke.
Ja, also jedenfalls damals, das war echt ein, wie würde man sagen, ein Watershed-Moment, dass irgendwie klar war, okay, also Echelon gibt es wirklich, hier sind Fotos. Krypto wird wirklich mit Hintertüren versehen. Hier sieht man irgendwie das Symbol. Und da war so irgendwie, okay, jetzt können wir das auch nicht mehr schönreden oder wegleugnen.
genau, und dann gab es halt auch diese EU-Debatte dazu, also mit Anhörung im Europäischen Parlament. Und dann kam der 11. September 2001. Und dann war die Diskussion plötzlich vorbei.
Dann hieß es wieder, naja, okay, also vielleicht müssen wir doch alles mitlesen können.
Nee, da hat auch niemand mehr drüber geredet. Also das Thema war komplett verschwunden. So, also das war halt einfach weg. So richtig, so hat niemand mehr interessiert, wollte niemand mehr, gab keine Anhörung mehr, war irgendwie alles so irgendwie alles war nur noch Terror, Terror, Terror, Terror, Terror. So und irgendwie.
Sagen wir die Terroristen, die machen auch Verschlußungen, oder?
genau und die.
Das ist auch unpopuläre Sache, so was bespricht man da nicht mehr.
Und das war halt so ein Punkt, was mir wirklich aufgefallen war damals, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, das ist so kurz davor, so im Sommer 2001, war halt irgendwie diese EU-Debatte-Geschichte und dann sollte doch, ich glaube, da gab es auch noch einen Spiegeltitel oder so was, also da gab es irgendwie so allerhand Geschichten dazu, wo eigentlich klar war, so jetzt müssen wir mal über diese NSA reden und diese Echelon und so und irgendwie, in welchem Umfang die das alles betreiben, so.
Aber war nicht mehr.
Und dann war vorbei. So, dann ging es halt nur noch irgendwie um die bösen Terroristen.
Und dann blieb es wieder an den Cipherpunks hängen.
Ja.
Die sind wieder aus ihrem Loch gekommen, haben gesagt, na gut, also, E-Mail stirbt langsam vor sich hin. Die Leute benutzen jetzt Instant Messaging. Dann müssen wir da mal was tun. Und 2004 gab es dann OTA. Das ist so einer der letzten großen Meilensteine in der Cryptografie. Off the Record? Das ist ein Plugin für diverse Instant-Messaging-Verfahren, mit dem man die Daten verschlüsseln kann. Aber nicht so wie bei PGP, dass ich die signiere und du hast dann mal ein Public Key und kannst es entschlüsseln und weißt, das kam von mir, sondern das ist so ein Deniability-Ding. Also das heißt, in der Sekunde, wo wir reden, können wir zwar relativ sicher sein, dass der andere ist, wer er sagt, aber wenn jemand das interceptet oder abfängt und dann danach irgendwie macht, kann der nicht mehr beweisen, dass wir wir waren. Also die Idee ist quasi, dass man auch so eine Art Fähigkeit zum Leugnen hat zu sagen. Selbst wenn es irgendwer mitliest, kann ich danach irgendwie sagen, ja wieso, das hätte ja jeder sein können. Und das ist schon relativ abgefahrene Cryptografie, die die da machen.
Deswegen heißt es halt off the record.
Deswegen heißt es off the record. Das heißt, ich kann mich unterhalten und ich weiß, ich kann im Nachhinein kann ich irgendwie belegen, dass es auch beliebige andere Scheiße hätte sein können, die da über den Dings ging.
Ja, also sollte man tatsächlich in all seinen Instant-Messaging-Clients aktivieren. Es hat zugegebenermaßen ein paar Nachteile. So einer der großen Nachteile ist, dass es halt nicht besonders gut funktioniert, wenn einer der kleinsten Mobiltelefone ist, weil es nicht besonders gut damit klarkommt, wenn Verbindungen, Abrechnungen wieder hergestellt werden. Und dann kommt es dazu allen möglichen Synchronisations-Fuck-Ups. Da ist das Protokoll ein wenig bearbeitungsbedürftig an der Stelle.
Naja, und die meisten Instant-Messaging-Clients sind unsicher bis zur Hölle.
genau.
Also die Situation ist alles andere als toll, aber das war ja auch bei allen anderen Sachen noch im Wesentlichen.
Das ist ja bei den Browsern auch so. Also meine, was wir jetzt ja gerade sehen, ist ja diese Flut von neuen Instant-Messaggern, die jetzt...
Alle behaupten, Snowden sicher zu sein.
genau, wir machen jetzt halt Crypto und Instant-Messaging. Ist ja gerade der neue Hit Bescheid.
Ganz vorsichtig mit sowas.
genau, guckt euch die Sachen ganz in Ruhe an. Guckt euch die Krypto an. Da gibt es halt auch eine Menge Leute, die halt, sagen wir mal, überhaupt nicht wissen, was sie tun, wie es sich...
Wenn es den Quellcode nicht gibt, Finger weg. Wenn es den Quellcode gibt und die eigene Krypto machen, Finger weg. Wenn jemand eigene Protokolle erfindet, Finger weg. Wenn jemand sagt, es ist militärer Kryptosicherheit, Finger weg. Es gibt da so eine Liste an roten Fahnen, so wie gesagt, Military Style.
Nur wenn es Military Grade Krypto ist?
Alles Snake Oil, ja ja, Finger weg. Das dauert 10 Jahre, bis man Kryptographie trauen kann.
Oder wenn die Leute noch nie vorher Krypto gemacht haben.
Ja, Finger weg. Aber das kann man ja immer schlecht sehen von außen.
Na ja, gut, also zum Beispiel dieses fieses JavaScript.
Manchmal ist es KryptoCat, manchmal ist es offensichtlich.
Ja, meine KryptoCat ist halt die Vollkatastrophe. Also guckt euch mal die Geschichte von KryptoCat an. KryptoCat ist ein JavaScript Instant Messenger, der sagt, okay, die Leute wollen sich nicht so komplizierte Software installieren. Deswegen machen wir das im Browser. Da kratscht sich natürlich schon mal jeder an den Kopf. Weil irgendwie der Weg, wie die Software in diesen Browser kommt, ist halt nun alles andere als sicher und irgendwie beherrschbar. Und dann, zudem stellte sich dann halt noch aus, dass das für den Jungen, der das geschrieben hat, so ein My First Crypto Product war und der so genau alles, wirklich alles, was man an Krypto falsch machen kann, falsch gemacht hat. Das ist halt so richtig, so ein, literally ein, ja...
Gut gemeint.
Nicht mal Applied Cryptography zu Ende gelesen, so, sondern halt einfach...
Ich würde dir jetzt Mühe gegeben, würde man sagen.
Also ist halt so, also der, wie war der Begriff? Wikipedia-Kryptograph hieß glaube ich irgendwie das vernichtende Urteil dazu. Und das Schlimme daran war halt, dass halt eine Menge Leute das empfohlen haben, weil es doch so schon einfach zu benutzen ist.
Für die Dissidenten, das war also die Ansage. Oh nein, das ist schlecht.
Dissidenten und Aktivisten, so. Und der Punkt ist halt, ja, wenn man nicht weiß, was man tut, dann macht man es lieber nicht, also dann nimmt man lieber die Unbequemlichkeit in kauf.
Das ist auch so ein rotes Zuwenn, wenn jemand sagt, es ist für Dissidenten, echte Kryptografen sind sehr vorsichtig damit, ihren eigenen Scheiß zu empfehlen. Sondern es dauert Jahre, bis sie ihrem eigenen Scheiß vertrauen. Und wenn jemand sagt, das hier habe ich gerade geschrieben, das ist für Dissidenten in China, dann ist so, f***er weg.
Dann kannst du ganz sicher sein, dass es irgendwie ein Scheiß ist, so. Die Frage halt eben, gerade so bei Krypto Instant Messagern, ist halt eben, Leute, die es halt richtig machen, benutzen halt zum Beispiel einigermaßen gut abgangende Krypto-Libraries von Leuten, die wissen, was sie tun. So, also zum Beispiel benutzen sie halt von DJ Burnstein die NACL-Library oder sie benutzen halt irgendwie andere, schon relativ gut eingeführte, gut getestete Krypto-Libraries und fangen halt nicht an, ihren Kram selber zu machen oder sie sind schon so lange im Business, dass man ihnen trauen kann und sagen kann, okay, die wissen wahrscheinlich, was sie tun und das ist halt nicht ihr erstes Kryptosystem, was sie bauen. Und der Punkt ist halt, man muss sich diesen Erwägungen nicht als User stellen, sondern man fragt um zweifel seine Freunde, die davon Ahnung haben. Aber gute Krypto ist immer konservativ. Also die ist halt immer darauf ausgerichtet, möglichst große Sicherheitsmaden zu haben und prahlt halt nicht damit, dass sie irgendwie Military Grade oder für Dissidenten halt so. Also mein Problem gerade mit dieser KryptoCat Geschichte ist halt, dass eben da auch eine Menge Organisationen halt hingegangen sind, die eben für Dissidenten halt so Technologie empfehlen.
Und jemand sagt, ey da steht dran für Dissidenten, das empfehlen wir mal. Und dann ist das nach Iran und so gegangen. Die Leute haben das benutzt.
Das empfohlen haben halt irgendwie, weil es halt eben so einfach zu benutzen ist. Und da kam halt immer dieser Vorwurf, ja ihr doofen Nerds, ihr macht doch Krypto so schwer zu benutzen. Und jetzt gibt es endlich mal was, was irgendwie leicht zu benutzen ist. Und dann seid ihr auch dagegen. Und dann kann ich leider nur sagen, sehr Entschuldigung, irgendwie diese Krypto, die der da gemacht hat, hat im Zweifel Leute umgebracht. Anders kann man es nicht formulieren. Weil sein Random-Normal-Generator kaputt war, weil man die Keys vorher sein konnte, weil man den Kram mit trivialen Per-Scripts dekodieren konnte. Das war schon wirklich peinlich. Das ist schon richtig schlimm so. Und das ist eben genau der Punkt. Also wenn man anfängt, Krypto-Software zu machen, dann macht man die mal für sich und spielt damit eine Runde rum und guckt mal irgendwie, was man falsch gemacht hat. Und dann gibt es mal jemanden, einen Freund, um zu gucken, was man falsch gemacht hat. Und dann macht man dann auch fünf oder zehnmal und dann überlegt man sich, ob man möglicherweise dann doch irgendwie eine Krypto-Library nimmt, auf die schon ein paar Leute mehr geguckt haben.
Also lustigerweise muss man ja wirklich sagen, dass die gute Krypto-Software erkennt man daran, dass sie unbenutzbar ist. Denn Krypto hat einfach eine inhärete Komplexität. Und je mehr Software versucht, es zu verbergen, desto weniger vertrauenswürdig ist es.
Ne, das würde ich nicht unterschreiben. Also es gibt halt, gut, ich bin in dem Business, ich muss das sagen.
Kannst du jetzt nicht durchgehen lassen.
Ne, kann ich nicht durchgehen lassen. Aber es gibt halt gute Gegenbeispiele. Wo man halt einfach sehen kann, dass man schon die Komplexität von Krypto so, hinter User-Unterfaces nicht verbergen, sondern kapseln kann. Dass sie halt für normale Nutzer gut so zu benutzen ist, dass man sich nicht in den Fuß schießt. Aber halt für Expertennutzer immer die Möglichkeit besteht, jedes beliebige Detail möglichst nachzuprüfen. Das kann man schon machen, bloß der Aufwand dazu zu tun ist halt relativ groß. Und zu fordern und zu erwarten, dass man das in Free Software mit GaM-User-Interface bekommt, ist halt möglicherweise ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, leider muss man sagen, wenn jemand bei so einer Krypto-Software so viel Aufwand in das User-Interface gesteckt hat, dass es gut aussieht, hat er normalerweise den Aufwand eben nicht in den Krypto teilgesteckt.
genau, aber dann nimmt man halt eine Krypto-Library, die fertig ist.
Ja, das ist aber schwer zu beurteilen für End-User. Deswegen ist es, die Leute kommen auch immer zu uns und sagen, hey, was können wir denn nehmen? Was ist denn sicher? Und das Problem ist, dass ich kann auf keinen Fall irgendwo und ein Record gehen und sagen, also das Tier ist total sicher. Denn das ist einfach so komplex alles, dass es nicht mehr einfach zu beurteilen ist. Ich kann nur sagen, was sicher genug ist oder wo ich mich gut genug mitfühle, um es selber einzusetzen. Aber weitergehende Aussagen bei Krypto-Software sind einfach unseriös. Bisher ist noch alles irgendwann gebrochen worden und man musste die Keys größer machen oder die Verfahren ändern. Das ist alles nicht so einfach.
Nein, es ist tatsächlich noch nicht alles gebrochen worden, aber es sind halt eine überraschende Menge von Sachen gebrochen worden, wo man es nicht erwartet hätte.
Nenn noch mal ein Verfahren, wo wir nicht den Schlüssel verlängern mussten oder was nicht unsicher ist inzwischen. Da ist die Liste echt kurz. Das sind alles irgendwie Sachen wie IAS, die es noch nicht so lange gibt.
Naja, Diffie-Hellman zum Beispiel.
Na, da haben wir die... Diffie-Hellman hat man am Anfang irgendwie mit 512-Bit gemacht.
Na gut, okay. Ja gut, die Schlüssellänge wurde mal verlängert. Ja, das ist richtig.
Das ist einfach alles nicht so einfach vorhersagen.
Ja, das stimmt. Die Frage ist halt natürlich, was tun jetzt? Diese NSA-Entfüllung fand ich eigentlich jetzt an vielen Stellen nicht so überraschend, was jetzt irgendwie Technologie angeht, aber was ich aber echt überraschend fand, war...
Also das haben wir, glaube ich, auch gut dargestellt in dem Podcast hier. Wenn man sich dafür wirklich interessiert hätte, hätte man das alles schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren wissen können. Oder zumindest ahnen können. Aber es ist noch mal ein Unterschied zwischen das abstrakt zu ahnen und das konkret zu sehen.
genau. Und was mich schon überrascht hat, war, dass der Scale, also wie groß der Aufwand ist, den sie getrieben haben und wie, in welchem Umfang sie Technologie einsetzen, die teuer und aufwendig und schwierig ist und wie hartnäckig und wie vor allen Dingen, wie gnadenlos sie da vorgehen bei der Implementierung von so einer Technologie, der hat mich schon ein bisschen überrascht. Also das war schon so eher so zwei bis zehnmal größer, als ich irgendwie so angenommen habe.
Also mich hat überrascht, wie viel Blößen sie sich gegeben haben, indem sie an andere Leute herangetreten sind. Ich hätte gedacht, die NSA kauft sich zwar die größten und geilsten Computer, die es gibt und rechnet da dann mit, was sie können, aber dass sie zu allen Kabelprovidern gehen, wo man ja damit rechnen muss, dass es irgendwann liegt. Das sieht doch irgendjemand, das liegt einfach nicht ohne das. Oder bei AT&T haben sie doch diesen raum da gehabt, wo sie ja immer das Kabel ab und an...
Was hast du gehabt? Die haben immer noch eine Vermittlungsstelle.
Das ist ja auch geleakt. Aber ich mein, dieses Risiko, hätte ich gedacht, gehen die nicht ein. Weil es ist doch klar, wenn man es in so einem Umfang macht, dass es nicht für immer geheim bleiben kann. Das ist doch klar. Und das sieht auch immer scheiße aus, wenn es dann rauskommt.
Naja, bloß die Frage ist halt, ob es ihnen nicht vielleicht egal ist, dass es scheiße ist, dass es rauskommt.
Wahrscheinlich. Sie sind einfach verzweifelt, würde ich mal sagen. Vielleicht haben wir einfach doch gewonnen mit dem Crypto Wars, dass wir sie so verzweifelt gemacht haben, dass wir diesen ganzen Scheiß jetzt treiben müssen. Die Argumente wären ja auch immer so ein bisschen fraktaler an der Stelle. Wenn ich mir irgendwie anfänge zu sagen, das Web of Trust im PGP, das legt zwar meine sozialen Kontakte offen, aber ich kann ja davon ausgehen, dass sie nicht meinen Kontakte eh wissen. Die können ja mein Handy sehen. Die sehen ja, mit wem ich E-Mails austausche. Die Metadaten haben sie ja eh. Und diese Art von Argument, die hätte es früher so weniger gegeben haben. Dass wir überhaupt sehen, dass die Metadaten wichtig sind, ist eine relativ neue Sache. Aber auch diese Überlegung zu sagen, dass man abwägt und sagt, aber den Teil wissen sie ja eigentlich eh schon über mich. Das ist schon relativ traurig, dass wir so weit sind in der Gesellschaft.
Der Punkt, dass man nicht mal abstrakt annehmen muss, dass sie es wissen könnten, sondern nicht sicher sein kann, dass sie es haben. Das ist schon tatsächlich ein Unterschied.
Ich hab mir diesen Scherz gemacht, als ich jetzt bei der Blackight war für die FAZ, hab ich eine Mail an die Presseabteilung der NSA geschickt und hab mir gedacht, ich weiß, dass die GCHQs jetzt mitgelesen hat, was ja eigentlich sehr witzig ist. Wenn ich aus Europa eine Mail schreibe an die NSA, dann liest die GCHQs mit. Das wäre auch mal eine Frage an die NSA gewesen. Aber diese Überlegung, dass sich das einfach weiß, natürlich lesen die das mit, denn es ist internationale Mailverkehr, das ist schon sehr bizarr eigentlich, dass deren Mission jeweils so wichtig ist, dass sie mit anderen kooperieren, die ja eigentlich befreundete Geheimdienste gibt es ja nicht. Sondern eigentlich sind die ja alle verfeindet. Aber dass sie das überbrücken können, diese Differenzen, weil es ihnen doch wichtiger ist, noch mehr abhören zu können, das ist schon echt erstaunlich. Und das zeigt auch, dass es so eine Art Weltregierung gibt aus Geheimdiensten. Den Punkt wolltest du eigentlich noch ansprechen.
Ja, ich meine gerade diese Geschichte mit den Briten und der NSA weißt halt irgendwie klar darauf hin, dass die Dienste die Dienste haben. Die Dienste sind sich halt irgendwie näher als ihre Regierung. Und ich meine, selbst wenn sich die Regierung halt komplett verstritten haben, haben die Dienste immer noch weiter kooperiert.
Das ist ja bei den Briten sogar noch halbwegs vorhersagbar gewesen. Aber als bei uns diese Ansage kam, wie war denn das? Der Regierungssprecher meinte irgendwie so was. Ja, die Unterhändler der Geheimdienste haben...
Nein, nein, das war Poffeller.
Poffeller war das, genau.
genau, Poffeller hat gesagt, bei seiner Beendigung des Eiskandals, hat Poffeller gesagt, hat er aus einem NSA-Papier zitiert, was ihm sozusagen als Argumentationshilfe gegeben wurde. Er hat gesagt, ja, es ging alles nach Recht und Gesetz zu entsprechend der Vereinbarung, die zwischen den Regierungen, vertreten durch ihre Geheimdienste, getroffen wurden.
Da dachte ich auch so, äh, so, äh, wollen die irgendwie mit Neukalibrierung der Realität? So weit, das so weit, das geben die offen zu, dass ihre Geheimdienste im Grunde die Zepter in der Hand haben?
Die Dienste verhandeln unter einen datenaustausch. Den Regierung wurde es nur mitgeteilt, was notwendig ist. Und auch zum Beispiel bei der Verhandlung vom Verfassungsgericht, als es da um die Anti-Terror-Datei ging, da hatten wir in Argumenten aller Sachen eingebracht, insbesondere, dass der internationale datenaustausch zwischen den Diensten angegangen ist. Da wollte niemand ran, auch das Verfassungsgericht wollte da nicht ran. Das ist halt tatsächlich ein echter Skandal, dass also einfach diese Schattenwelt, die da existiert, unbehindert vor sich hin wuchert, dass irgendwie von allen angenommen wird, ja, was diese Geheimdienste da machen, das wird schon alles in der Richtigkeit haben. Und dass irgendwie auch kein Politiker da ran will, ist doch vollkommen klar.
Das ist halt so eine Geheimdienstmetastase, wo keiner im Grunde die Details sehen will, weil du dann nämlich in Handlungsdruck wärst.
Ja, natürlich, sobald du weißt, was da passiert, bist du irgendwie in der Verpflichtung, zu handeln.
Auch dieser Obama-Spruch, weißt du den noch? Als Obama meinte, ach, immer wenn diese slowen Sachen kommen, dann muss ich zur NSA gehen und fragen, ob das alles stimmt. So, wat, ja? Wat? Du wolltest wissen, was da funktioniert, weil das dein Befehl sein sollte.
Ja, so. Und diese Art und Weise, dass die Politik da nur noch zaungast ist, bei diesem internationalen Darma, und Regierungssprecher der Geheimdienste, ja?
Die Regierung ist der Sprecher der Geheimdienste, so ist das doch. Die eigentlichen Entscheidungen beginnen bei den Dienstenschaften.
Das kann halt einfach so nicht weitergehen. Also vollkommen klar, dass, wenn wir uns mal angucken, was damals bei der Church Commission passiert ist, war ja quasi eine, naja, ich sag mal Revolution in den US-Geheimdiensten, dass es plötzlich sowas wie Oversight gab und dass es irgendwie so ein bisschen Transparenz war.
Dann lach noch mal.
Naja, das hat tatsächlich ja eine Weile geholfen. Also das war ja nicht so, dass es halt irgendwie folgenlos blieb. Bloß die haben natürlich über die Zeit komplett sabotiert irgendwie und invertiert. Und das ist ja nicht umsonst so, dass da so viele Juristen arbeiten, deren hauptaufgabe im Wesentlichen darin besteht, möglichst spitzfindig Loopholes in den Gesetzen zu finden und die so zu interpretieren, dass irgendwie dann ihr Chef in der Senatsanhörung sagen kann, so ja nicht unter diesem Gesetz haben wir irgendwie die Amerikaner abgehört. Oder nicht unter diesem Gesetz haben wir irgendwie diese Erinnerungen getan. So und was in Deutschland hier passiert, dass also quasi niemand mehr nachfragt, also dass weder die Grünen noch die SPD irgendwie es für nötig halten, irgendwie das zum Thema zu machen und irgendwie die CDU damit durchkommen lassen.
Das verstehe ich, weil die ja selber mit schuld waren. Natürlich sind die schuld. Aber dass die Linken da auch nicht noch mehr drauf kloppen.
Na die tun das schon, aber den hat ja wieder keiner zu.
Da muss doch mal jemand einen Fass aufmachen.
Aber ich meine, dass die SPD und die Grünen können ja sagen, ok, es war damals ein Fehler, wir haben es gemacht, weil irgendwie war 11. September, war alles scheiße, wir können nichts dafür. Aber lass uns doch bitte mal irgendwie jetzt unsere Fehler korrigieren. Aber nein, die Größe haben sie nicht, sondern die machen weiter mit.
trauen sich alle nicht.
Die trauen sich halt alle nicht. Und der Grund dafür ist offensichtlich klar. Die wissen natürlich, dass die Dienste jede Menge dreckige Wäsche über sie haben. Und das ist irgendwie im Zweifel echt unklug für so ein Politik. Ich meine Politik ist halt ein kriminalitäts- und skandalgeneignetes Fach. Und die Dienste haben halt einfach irgendwie alles über die. Damit müssen die halt einfach festrechnen. Diese Nummer mit dieser Senatsanhörung, die da zitiert wurde in Amiland.
Erinnerst du dich an die Spitze-Geschichte?
Na warte mal, dass wir dieses Zitat nochmal bringen. Da hat tatsächlich zitiert ein präsentantenhaus-mitglied.
Der wollte seine Daten sehen?
In der Anhörung hat die NSA gefragt, can I have my file?
Ne, can I see my file?
genau, will you give me my file? Und die NSA hat nicht gesagt, ne wir haben keinen, sie hat gesagt, no, we won't, wir geben es dir nicht.
Und da ist doch klar, wer hier der Dienstbote ist und wer hier der Herr ist.
Und das ist halt eben auch keine Verschwörungstheorie mehr, sondern das ist offensichtlich die Realität da draußen. So dass halt einfach die Dienste, die Politik in einer Art und Weise in der Hand haben, dass die Politik eben nicht mal mehr in der Lage ist, sich da irgendwie das primar zu verschaffen und einfach eine klare Ansage zu machen, zu sagen okay, Entschuldigung, das geht hier nicht mehr so weiter. Ihr seid hier über die Stränge geschlagen und irgendwie jetzt ist mal langsam Schluss. Abgesehen davon, was habt ihr eigentlich irgendwie in den letzten 20 Jahren geleistet? Und können wir jetzt bitte mal darüber reden, was ihr dann tatsächlich wirklich davon braucht? Und könnt ihr bitte mal begründen, was ihr wirklich davon braucht? Aber das findet halt nicht statt, weil irgendwie niemand in der Politik die Eier in der Hose hat zu sagen, okay, wir hauen jetzt mal auf den Tisch. Und irgendwie erstmal gibt es einen untersuchungsausschuss. Alle Spitzen der Geheimdienste kommen vor diesen untersuchungsausschuss. Wenn sich das rausstellt, kommen sie nötigfalls vor Gericht. Ansonsten machen wir den Laden einfach mal zu.
Das ist doch das Problem. Die haben doch da so ein Isolationslehr dazwischen.
Spitzen heißt halt, bis auf die Abteilungsleiter.
Ja, gut, das muss man...
Also eben mal tatsächlich die Leute, die die sauerei machen. Weil klar ist halt, in diesen Diensten und auch zur Ministerien gibt es natürlich eine Menge Leute, die sind da halt einfach länger als die Regierung.
Das ist so ein Lügengebeuge auch, was sie sich da gewahrt haben. Dass du da auch durch die Indirektionen... Die Leute sagen ja die Wahrheit, wenn sie dir sagen, sie wissen davon nichts. Weil das einfach intern auch so kompartmentalisiert ist alles. Ich glaube, dass dieser Spitzer nicht durch Zufall, während der Bankenkrise, das Elis Spitzer war irgendwie der Generalstaatsanwalt von New York, zuständig für Wall Street. Und der ist unter richtig peinlichen Umständen in so einem Sexskandal gescheitert. Und der galt als letzter aufrechter Typ. Ich frage mich wirklich, ob das nicht irgendwie auch so eine Warnung, der Dienste war. Guck mal, das passiert mit euch.
Ich meine der Chef von Qwest, den haben sie damals absolviert wegen Insider Trading, weil er sich geweigert hat, der NSA halt irgendwie zu Infrastruktur zu geben.
Das war eine richtig geile Geschichte. Die NSA hat angekloppt bei dem, wollte seine Infrastruktur zugefahren. Er hat sich geweigert und er hat aber so ein aktienverkaufsding gehabt. Und hat argumentiert, dass da kein Insider Trading, weil er davon ausgehen musste, dass der Kurs nach oben geht und nicht nach unten. Und er wäre nach oben gegangen, weil nämlich ein NSA-Auftrag ausstand. Und der hat dann aber nicht stattgefunden. Und daraufhin haben sie ihm Insider Trading angehängt. Also das ist schon alles so eine widerliche Mischpoke. Und auch so ein Dickicht, wo du einfach das Gefühl hast, außer einer Machete oder so eine Rodung, hilft da nicht mehr.
genau, da hilft dann nur noch Roden. Das heißt, irgendwie den Laden abschalten, alle Leute rausschmeißen und hinterher sehen, was wir davon wirklich mal brauchen. Alles andere hilft da einfach nicht mehr. Ich meine, es gibt halt irgendwie keinen anderen Weg.
Es ist ja auch, dass dieses Narrativ inzwischen so offensichtlich selbst widersprüchlich ist. Die NSA stellt sich ja hin und sagt, wir verhindern hier Terrorangriffe. Und dann kommt dieser Boston-Marathon-Bombing.
Sie haben nichts gesehen, nichts, wenn ihr nichts gewusst habt.
Nicht nur haben sie das nicht verhindert, sie haben auch ihr Narrativ überhaupt nicht geändert. Die stellen sich danach immer noch hin und sagen, wir verhindern hier Anschläge.
Und mit dem Edit Twist, das brauchen wir noch extra, damit wir nicht den nächsten Boston verhindern können. Ein Frechheit. Und den Mogadischen, die Nairobi da gerade?
Ja, die sind in Nairobi dabei ja auch.
Wussten sie nix, haben sie nicht mitbekommen und irgendwie, naja.
Also jedenfalls, das sieht alles nicht so aus, als wenn es mit demokratischen Mitteln noch aufzulösen wäre, außer man macht wirklich einfach Tor zu und alles neu. Oder man lässt es einfach weg. Ich persönlich glaube ja nicht, dass wir Geheimnisse brauchen.
Ja, wie gesagt, man kann ja einfach erst mal auflösen, dann mal gucken, was wir davon brauchen. Da kann man immer noch drüber reden, aber auch irgendwie von der Position irgendwie.
Allein, ich meine, bei uns allein, was diese Verfassungsschutzberichte für einen Schaden angerechnet haben, das geht auf keine kuhhaut. Wieso gibt es die noch?
Na, deren Nutzwert zu belegen, fällt wahrscheinlich wirklich schwer.
Ist alles classified. Ich könnte es dir sagen, aber...
Tut mir leid.
Aber ich meine, wenn jemand mit so einem Argumentationsmuster ankommt, wieso wird es da nicht sofort aufgelöst? Wenn du dein Nutzen nicht belegen kannst, weil das classified ist, dann hast du kein Nutzen.
Ja. Naja.
Nicht zu fassen. Aber auf dem niveau arbeitet unser postdemokratisches System, um mal den Herrn Enzensberger zu zentieren. Das finde ich ja ein sehr schöner Begriff. Den sollten wir tatsächlich nicht pflegen. Naja.
Na gut.
Jetzt haben wir uns hier in Rage geredet. Also wir werden mal versuchen, dass die nächste Sendung ein bisschen weniger zeitlichen Abstand hat.
genau.
Mal gucken, was sich da anbietet als Thema.
Ja. Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Den Flatterbutton gibt es immer noch.
genau, den Flatterbutton gibt es immer noch.
Wir bemühen uns, wir machen, was wir können.
Wir tun, was wir können. Und du mein, bist du jetzt erstmal eine Weile hier?
Jetzt bin ich erstmal hier.
Na gut, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.